Oh, hallo Wolfgang.
Hallo Stefan.
Warst du beim Friseur?
Nein, noch nicht, aber am Montag um halb acht Morgen setze ich mich in mein Auto und rase los.
Das ist er, der Februar, gerade noch so. Der kurze Februar, heute noch mal schnell abgefangen. Du hast also Friseurtermin.
Und ja, ich hab das große Glück. Hast du bei Iberia gesteigert? Nein, ich bin da ganz normal drangekommen, beziehungsweise ich hab einen guten Draht zu meinem Friseur und ich hab tatsächlich den ersten Termin und bin sehr, sehr froh, dass ich dann endlich nach drei Monaten wieder beim Friseur bin.
Wieder allererste. Du bist der allererste Termin nach zwei Monaten Öffnung dort.
Ja, das ist doch großartig, oder?
Musst du dafür einen Clean-Bonus zahlen?
Nein, nichts.
Also...
Du bist bestellt, fällt ein, fällst.
Ich werde mich aber bestimmt irgendwie doch sehr dankbar weisen. Also es ist für mich ja ganz existenziell, beim Friseur zu sein. Ich hab mich ja gefreut darüber, dass man jetzt dort wieder hin kann, wenngleich mir schon auch diese gewisse Willkür bewusst ist, dass man jetzt sagt, die Friseure machen jetzt eine Woche früher mal auf. Aber naja, so ist es halt. Es ist alles nicht so nachvollziehbar.
Es ist die Würde. Ich war gestern so ein bisschen draußen, komme Richtung nach Hause, laufe über den Lehrerparkplatz der Schule, auf der auch meine Fünftklässlerin geht und sehe dort ungefähr ein Dutzend, ich nehme mal an, so Siebtklässler, die in Maske auf dem Beton Sport machen. Das ist dort genau die gleiche Situation wie beim Friseur. Ja, die Schule hat jetzt wieder auf in Hessen seit dieser Woche. Und dann muss ich echt dran denken. Du hast auf der einen Seite junge Menschen, denen Covid nun wirklich nicht nahegeht, selbst wenn sie es als Infektions haben, die mit Maske auf betonierten Platz plötzlich Sport machen müssen, um sich nach zwei Monaten mal wieder zu ertüchtigen. Und gleichzeitig liest man, dass irgendeine Eisfabrik geschlossen werden musste, weil es da einen Ausbruch gab. Und man fragt sich ein bisschen, warum wird hier gerade Eis hergestellt in Deutschland? Und zwar unter der Bedingung, das ist nur möglich, dieses Eis zu produzieren, wenn die Kinder erstens zwei Monate zu Hause sind und dann mit Maske auf dem Lehrerparkplatz Sport machen. Also hier gerät einiges aus dem Ruder, dass jetzt die Friseure aufmachen. Ich habe mir meine Gäste wieder selber, so wie ich es seit 20 Jahren mache, abrasiert. Es ist allerdings auch eine Sache der Würde. Also da würde ich dem Herrn Söder zustimmen. Es ist eine Frage der Würde. Allerdings gilt diese Würde-Frage, wie wir wissen, laut Artikel 1 für alle Menschen und nicht nur für Friseure. Und in deren Sicht, na ja, ein Schritt in die richtige Richtung, würde ich sagen.
Ich denke auch. Aber wir haben eine ganz große Debatte ja jetzt mit den Impfstoffen. Und man kann da zum Beispiel bei Twitter 40, 50 Follower verlieren, wenn man auch nur irgendetwas von Kekulé twittert. Denn was mir gar nicht so bewusst war, dass es auch diesen Lagerkampf gibt. Also eigentlich gibt es, so scheint mir, nur das Lager Drosten und alles, was sich darum gruppiert. Melanie Brinkmann oder so. Und auf der anderen Seite gibt es nur böse Virologen und Experten.
Ja, sterben mit Strick.
Sterben mit Strick, dieser Hashtag ist da. Ich wusste aber nicht, dass Kekulé auch so verpönt ist. Ich muss dazu sagen, ich habe ja gar keine besondere Beziehung zu all diesen Experten. Insofern kann ich das von einer gewissen Distanz aus mir belustigt ansehen, finde es aber doch sehr eigenartig, dass man in ein solches Lagerdenken kommt und dann aber wieder betont, wie wichtig einem doch die Wissenschaft ist. Dabei muss einem ja klar sein, die Wissenschaft ist eben kein Lager und da kann sich heute der Irren, der gestern noch etwas ganz Wichtiges sagte, etwas sehr Richtiges sagte, und man kann das ja sehen, dass Streeck seine Meinung doch sehr häufig wechselt und mir ist auch diese gewisse Profilierungssucht aufgefallen. Ich würde zugleich aber auch sagen, na ja, wer der in der Öffentlichkeit steht, hat diese Profilierungssucht nicht. Das kann sich ja nur ein bisschen anders äußern. Die einen treten sehr eitel auf, die anderen machen das auf eine andere Art und sind solche Bescheidenheitsprotze, wie Fritz H. Radatz mal über Helmut Schmidt sagte. Das heißt, da bin ich sehr, sehr skeptisch und mit diesem Lagerdenken, das ist so unglaublich, weil es wirklich mit Wissenschaft gar nichts zu tun hat. Das ist eigentlich ein vorneuzeitliches Verständnis von Wissenschaft, das in Lager denkt. Also dann muss man sich zu etwas bekennen. Und so ist das jetzt also Team-Trosten oder Sterben mit Streeck. Das ist ein Bekennen, das ist also, dass man komplett alles teilt, was dieser oder jener Mensch macht. Und das ist dann aber schon eine Form, wie man dann einst von Galilée gefordert hat, er soll jetzt wieder rufen. Und da frage ich mich dann auch, sind wir jetzt so weit, dass man, das muss man jetzt, wenn man was von Kekole getwittert hat, erst einmal wieder rufen. Ich wieder rufe, dass ich diesen Experten überhaupt zur Rate gezogen habe.
Herr Sträck, treten Sie an und verkünden Sie, dass wir alle auf einer flachen Erde leben. Genau so wird das, glaube ich, gerade praktiziert. Ich glaube, das muss man sich so vorstellen. Wir wissen ja, Wissenschaft ist Teamarbeit. Alle stehen auf den Schultern von Riesen. Und diese Art von Teamgedanken, der da drin steckt, man gehört einer Fakultät an, sonst ist man niemand, der wird halt einfach ins Publikum kopiert. Wir alle sind jetzt Virologen, also müssen wir uns diesen Schulen zurechnen. Und wir haben das letzte Mal schon hier herausgearbeitet, dass man zum einen Drosten anhängen kann und zum anderen aber ihm auch mal zuhören müsste. Und alle, die wirklich Drosten zuhören, müssten eigentlich seit November, also seit Drosten in seinem eigenen Podcast vor Millionen Publikum, über seine eigene Antigen-Test-Studie, die selbst in Harvard gefeiert wurde, als das ist wirklich ein Masterpiece, müsste eigentlich der totale Verteidiger von Antigen-Tests sein. Aber nein, es gilt weiter Lockdown über alles, ansonsten zählt hier gar nichts. Jetzt kommen wir jetzt so langsam um die Antigen-Tests. Ich will ankündigen, wenn es heute klingelt, hier sind meine Antigen-Tests da, denn sie sind schon in Zustellung, habe ich gerade nochmal in der Sendungsverfolgung nachgeschaut. Außerdem will ich nochmal dran erinnern, Drosten saß bei den Formaten des Politischen, so heißt diese Deutschlandfunk-Veranstaltung, die einmal im Jahr in der Bundespressekonferenz stattfindet, wo die Journalisten selber ein bisschen reflektieren und sagte dort, was Kikulé sagt, ist im Grunde immer richtig. Und er sagt dasselbe wie ich. Es sind Nuancen, wo sich das alles unterscheidet. Es ist, wenn man da eine große Differenz reinarbeiten möchte zwischen Drosten und Kikulé, nur ein Aufhängen am Sprechakt.
Genau.
Dass man einfach im Quadcast hört, wie der Kikulé mal wieder sagt, dass er das ja schon im März letzten Jahres als Smart Concept vorgestellt hat. Aber ja, das S in Smart steht für Schutz der Risikogruppen und das ist seit März 2020 richtig. Und wir haben uns immer zurückgezogen auf das Argument, nein, wir müssen die Gesamtinzidenz runterbringen. Wir kriegen ja die Ausbrüche in den Pflegeheimen, also da, wo es wirklich gefährlich ist, wo es pocken im Mittelalter. Ja, war trotzdem das Zitat, wenn es da zuschlägt. Das kriegen wir nicht runter, wenn die Gesamtinzidenz hoch ist. Nein, wir wissen heute aus vielen Ländern, dass das durchaus anders funktioniert, dass man da differenziert rangehen kann. Und jetzt will ich noch ein Wort zu Streak sagen. Streak ist ja mittlerweile wirklich ein bedauernswerter Fall. Es tut mir wirklich weh, Streak zu sehen, weil auch jetzt diese Texte kommen, die hier so geteilt werden. Streak hat sich ja immer geirrt und so weiter. Streak hat ja gar keine zweite Welle vorausgesehen. Wenn wir uns die Programme von Streak mal angeschaut und umgesetzt hätten, besonderer Schutz dort, wo es nötig ist. Also niemand geht ohne Test in ein Pflegeheim. Wirklich niemand. Konsequente Umsetzung. So wie übrigens in Tübingen, in Böblingen, in Rostock. Wir haben es ja überall studiert, wie das dazu geht. Und wenn man auch dieses Ampelsystem mal ernst genommen hätte, und wenn man sehr viele Sachen von Streak ernst genommen hätte...
Was Melanie Brinkmann im Prinzip jetzt fordert und was auch diese Lokovic-Strategie ist. Jetzt reden ja alle von dieser Ampel.
Ganz genau. Was jetzt gefordert wird. Wenn wir das im Sommer schon mal ernst genommen hätten, was Streak gesagt hat, dann hätten wir eine zweite Welle ja vielleicht doch verhindert. Und dann hätte er vielleicht auch recht gehabt, einfach zu sagen, Streak hat schon immer Quatsch gesagt. Und wir haben uns ja nie dran gehalten. Und deswegen kamen dann diese Ausbrüche. Kann man sagen, ja gut, da hat man sich das Ei halt selbst gelegt. Und jetzt hängt man sich dran auf. Also in deren Sicht ist hier auch viel Aufarbeitung nötig. Und ich würde sagen, da es mit Ja so gestrickt wurde, auch bei einer Rehabilitation von Streak und Kikoli usw. Weil das ist mittlerweile wirklich nicht mehr erträglich, wie zumindest in der Twitter-Bubble das so abgeht.
Ganz genau. Und du hast vollkommen recht zu sagen, es hat was mit Kommunikation zu tun. Drosten fällt mir auf, es ist ein unglaublich guter Kommunikationsstrategie, der viele Dinge sagt und sie auch sehr detailliert ausführt. Manche Dinge aber auch weglässt, um jetzt nicht etwas zu verschleiern, sondern man kann eine Frage ja so und so beantworten. Kikoli ist eher derjenige, der sagt, so ich versuche eine Zuspitzung herzustellen. Also ich beantworte am Ende auch die Frage, wie ist das denn jetzt mit AstraZeneca? Wie gut oder schlecht ist dieser Impfstoff? Während Drosten dann, mir wurde nämlich dann, als ich Kikoli zitierte, dass AstraZeneca ein Impfstoff zweiter Klasse sei, sofort hundertmal dieser Drosten-Podcast noch zuge-twittert und per E-Mail geschickt und alles. Da muss ich sagen, na ja, ich weiß schon, dass es diesen Podcast gibt und ich habe den auch gehört und kann sagen, ja, Drosten hat eine etwas andere Haltung zu AstraZeneca. Er benennt auch ganz klar die Vorteile, die mit diesem Impfstoff verbunden sind. Er geht aber beispielsweise nicht darauf ein, inwieweit AstraZeneca vor Long-Covid schützt. Er ist auch sehr vage, was die Mutationen anbelangt. Also er weiß, das sagt ja auch Lauterbach ganz öffentlich, wurde er auch schon zurückgepfiffen für, dass gegen Mutationen das nicht so wirkt, AstraZeneca, nicht so gut wie BioNTech oder Moderna. Und das kann man natürlich alles so machen, aber vielleicht ist manchmal auch diese Zuspitzung ganz schön. Und du hast da ja einen Clip, er war ja auch bei Markus Lanz dann ein paar Tage nach seinem Podcast zu AstraZeneca und Kekole hat da was doch ganz Pointiertes losgelassen.
Kekole hat zum einen diesen ganz kurzen Spruch gemacht.
AstraZeneca ist ein guter Impfstoff, ja oder ja?
AstraZeneca ist ein guter Impfstoff, aber es gibt auch sehr gute Impfstoffe.
Und das stimmt, denn ich hatte ja zum Beispiel eine Maserninfektion, die auch ausbrach, obwohl ich gegen Masern geimpft war, weil, wie sich herausstellt, wir waren eigentlich immer zufrieden bei Impfungen, wenn die so ein bisschen, keine Ahnung, irgendwie und so. Bei Masern hat man es mittlerweile, glaube ich, ganz hoch gelevelt, aber bei 100 Prozent sind die alle nicht. Und der Biontech-Impfstoff gegen Covid-19 scheint nicht nur einer der besten gegen Covid-19 Impfstoffe zu sein, sondern grundsätzlich, scheint grundsätzlich einer der genialsten Impfstoffe aller Zeiten gewesen zu sein, den man da hat. Über den Preis reden wir auch gleich mal, aber den kann man auch mal vergleichen mit so anderen Impfstoffen. Und jetzt hatten wir einen Clip, den haben wir beide uns zurechtgelegt für heute. Und da kommen wir wieder zurück auf Drossen und die Impfstoffe und so weiter. Wir hören uns mal Kikole auch hier in derselben Land-Sendung an.
Die Frau von der Leyen hat ja eine Beratungskommission für die Pandemie. Da sitzen auch zwei Deutsche drinnen. Und die Frage ist, welchen Ratschlag haben die letztes Jahr im Juli gegeben, als Donald Trump die RNA-Impfstoffe bestellt hat, als die Israeli das gemacht haben. Darum haben sie jetzt so viel, als Kanada sich eingedeckt hat. Warum hat die EU damals Unmengen von AstraZeneca bestellt und nicht so viel von den RNA-Impfstoffen? Da müsste man eigentlich die wissenschaftlichen Berater fragen, welchen Rat die damals gegeben haben oder ob sie gar nichts gesagt haben.
So, hinter dieser Frage, welchen Rat haben eigentlich die sieben Experten der von der Leyen gegeben? Also der EU-Kommission, da war ein siebenköpfiges Gremium bestellt. Wir erklären erstmal die Frage, wer sitzt in diesen siebenköpfigen Gremien? Es sind aus Deutschland Christian Drossen und Lothar Wieler, also der LKI-Chef und unser Top-Virologe der Charité. Die beiden laut Tagesschau waren im Oktober, also nicht die beiden, sondern das Gremium, das Expertengremium, war im Oktober noch, Zitat, sehr skeptisch, was mRNA-Impfungen angeht. Wir wissen heute, sie haben es wegen der Trump-Wahl noch mal um eine Woche verzögert, auch noch mal eine Geschichte für sich, die aufzuarbeiten ist. Denn eigentlich waren die Ergebnisse schon vor der Trump-Wahl da, also sie hätten durchaus noch so einen Boost, so einen Oktober-Surprise für Trump geben können. Naja, wir wissen aber, wie es war. Am Dienstag war die Trump-Abwahl und am Sonntag drauf war dann diese Nachricht, BioNTech kommt mit 95, 94 irgendwas prozentiger Sicherheit gegen Covid. Und also wenige Tage vorher, Wochen vorher, noch im Oktober waren die sehr skeptisch. Es gibt also auch eine große Überraschung unter den deutschen zuständigen Virologen und Behördenleitern, dass das doch funktioniert hat mit diesen mRNA-Dingern. Und wir wissen, können daraus ein bisschen ableiten, warum die EU-Kommission so sehr auf AstraZeneca gesetzt hat, die dann erst mal später kam und dann auch jetzt Liefer-Schwierigkeiten haben, vielleicht sogar bis ins zweite Quartal hinein. Gleichzeitig weiß, wie es mich dann Wolfgang Michael auf Twitter hin, dass die beiden aber im Oktober entschuldigt waren. Sie waren also nicht vor Ort, als die EU-Kommission tagte. Trotzdem gehören sie zu diesem Gremium. Also wenn die, und wir haben ja den Text hier von David Wallace Wells gelesen, dass sich die Forscher gemeint, der eigentlich seit Januar, seit der mRNA im Stoff von Moderna designt wurde und danach getestet wurde, dass die eigentlich durchweg sicher waren. Das ist der große Wurf, das wird was. Jetzt müssen wir nur noch die Testphasen rumbringen. Also es gab eigentlich dieses Herrschaftswissen, natürlich noch nicht öffentlich, aber in der Community schon. Und ich glaube nicht, dass jetzt Drossen oder Wieler dieser Zugang zu dieser Information aus Biontech, von CureVac, von Moderna irgendwie versagt worden wäre, sondern wenn die da sich ordentlich informiert hätten, hätten die im Sommer schon gewusst, was da im Anmarsch ist mit diesen mRNA, mit dieser neuen krassen Technologie, mit der man jetzt plötzlich Impfstoffe macht. Und dann wären sich…
Trump musste ja gut beraten worden sein.
Trump wusste das, genau. Trump wusste das. Der hat ja die ganze Zeit drauf gesetzt, ja, tolle Impfung kommt hier, das wird meine Oktober-Surprise und so weiter. Und dann haben sie es wirklich verschleppt, weil die Daten lagen rechtzeitig da. Das hat ja Kirk Ulley auch mal im Podcast gesagt. Die Daten bei Moderna lagen rechtzeitig da. Man hätte da auch bei Biontech, ja, Biontech hat aber schon mit Pfizer zusammengearbeitet. Über Pfizer kam das dann auch in die amerikanische Regierung. Hätte man das durchaus mal kommunizieren können, aber es kam dann nicht dazu. Und naja, jetzt haben wir halt diese Misere, dass wir ganz viel AstraZeneca bestellt haben. Dieser Impfstoff jetzt in den Studien sich nicht ganz so bewährt, wie dieses Wunder-Zaubermittel von Biontech. Deswegen in der öffentlichen Meinung so ein bisschen abfällt. Man sollte sich trotzdem sofort damit impfen lassen. Es gibt einen sehr guten Vorschlag von Mark Schiritz zu sagen, bis 18 Uhr werden die Impf-Prioritäten abgearbeitet. Und nach 18 Uhr gibt es noch mal zwei Stunden für alle, die da sind. Steht man vor der Tür und im Impfzentrum, wird einfach geimpft. Und am Ende des Tages ist der angebrochene Impfstoff verbraucht. Das wird alles nicht aufgegriffen. Wir haben in Deutschland eine ganz große Weigerung, diese Erstimpfungsstrategie durchzuziehen. Obwohl wir das Studienwissen jetzt haben, wie gut das alles sogar nach der ersten Impfung wirkt. Und dass man die zweite durchaus ein bisschen nach hinten ziehen kann. Nein, wir lagern Millionen und Millionen Impfdosen. Auch von Biontech einfach in die Kühlschränken, weil das halt so im Verwaltungsablauf steht.
Und man hat ja dann schnell nochmal ein Narrativ gebastelt. Man wollte selbstverständlich nicht die Organisatoren verantwortlich machen, dafür, dass das liegen bleibt. Sondern man glaubte jetzt, ach, das sind jetzt alle, die skeptisch sind. Die wollen sich kein Astra impfen lassen. Und deshalb liegt das jetzt alles da. Und dann hat man ja auch recherchiert und rausgefunden, ne, da sind drei Prozent, die haben da jetzt erstmal ein bisschen Muffensausen bekommen. Aber sonst würden da schon ganz viele machen. Und wenn man das bei Twitter sieht, dann hat man den Eindruck, 99 Prozent wollen unbedingt Astra haben. Und woran liegt es ja? Es liegt natürlich an organisatorischen Sachen daran, dass dann priorisierte Gruppen nicht eingeladen wurden oder gar keine Möglichkeit haben, sich anzumelden. Ich hör da ja auch ganz viele Horrormeldungen, auch von Leuten, die ich kenne, die über 80 sind, die immer noch nicht geimpft sind, noch keinen Impftermin haben. Aber wir können uns ja mal ein bisschen mit den Argumenten auseinandersetzen. Darum soll es ja auch gehen, nicht nur um die Personen. Warum ist denn jetzt AstraZeneca nicht so gut? Kein sehr guter Impfstoff im Vergleich zu Biontech. Da hören wir mal, was Kekule sagt in seinem Podcast.
Ja, was heißt raten? Also es kommt auf die Situation an, wenn sie nichts anderes zur Verfügung haben. Und wir sind einfach in Deutschland, das muss man fairerweise sagen, schon irgendwo in einer Notlage. Dann ist es natürlich besser, den AstraZeneca-Impfstoff zu haben als gar nichts. Aber ich rekapituliere einfach nochmal, was der Unterschied zwischen AstraZeneca und den RNA-Impfstoff nach der derzeitigen Datenlage ist. Das kann sich natürlich noch ändern. Der AstraZeneca-Impfstoff ist weniger wirksam, wahrscheinlich im Bereich von 60 Prozent statt 95 Prozent. Und weniger wirksam heißt natürlich, dass man damit in dieser Größenordnung die Epidemie gar nicht kontrollieren kann. Weil wenn sie ein Virus haben, was eine Basisreproduktionszahl R0 von, sage ich mal, 3, 5 oder so hat, in diesem Bereich wird das wohl liegen, dann kommen sie mit einer 60 Prozent Wirkung nicht hin. Das ist ja glaube ich inzwischen hinlänglich bekannt, dass man bei R gleich 3 bräuchte man zwei Drittel der Bevölkerung immun, um die sogenannte Herdenimmunität herzustellen. Zwei Drittel wären schon 67 Prozent. Das ist also weit entfernt von dem, was man epidemiologisch bräuchte. Deshalb bin ich von Anfang an nicht so ein großer Fan von diesem Impfstoff gewesen.
Ja, wir erinnern uns alle noch, das war Christian Drosten's großer Aufschlag damals, der allererste Auftritt von ihm in der Bundespressekonferenz, als er noch, während er diese Herdenimmunitätsrechnung gemacht hat, von dem Vorsitzenden unterbrochen wurde. Und dann später darauf auch seinen medialen Ruhm. Da traut sich einer mal gegen, die Journalisten zu schießen und zu sagen, Leute, ich erkläre hier grad was, unterbrechen Sie mich nicht mit Ihrer Frage. Und da hat er genau diese Rechnung gemacht, die jetzt nicht aufgeht, wenn man mit dieser Wirksamkeit von AstraZeneca daran geht. Denn AstraZeneca ist supergut, um einfach Todesfälle und superschwere Verläufe zu verhindern. Aber wir wissen jetzt von BioNTech, die israelischen Studien sind jetzt da. Fallzahl 1, 2 Millionen. Das schützt auch wirklich vor der Infektion im Sinne von, die BioNTech-Immunität greift auch wirklich da an der Schleimhaut an, wo das Virus überhaupt erst mal anfängt, sich zu vervielfältigen und dann durch Atemluft wieder auszustoßen. Also diese sterile Immunität, die gibt es mit BioNTech. Und das wissen wir bei AstraZeneca noch nicht. Und deswegen werden wir immer dieses Virus haben. Es wird weiter mutieren. Streg hat ja schon immer darauf hingewiesen. Es wird dann sich so ein abgeschwächtes, ja, es wird dann das fünfte Coronavirus, das uns eine Erkältung macht regelmäßig, weil sich es immer mit verändert. Und wir kriegen auch eine Herdenimmunität nicht hin, wenn wir diese Zahlen kombinieren mit, wir haben noch gar keine Impfung für unter 12-Jährige zum Beispiel. Und auch für bis 12-Jährige wird jetzt gerade erst mal getestet, dass es steht dann irgendwann im Sommer oder Herbst.
Und das wird kaum thematisiert. Mich wundert wirklich, wie links liegen, wann man die jungen Leute lässt. Und jetzt kommt etwas, ein Aspekt, den er anspricht, den schon ein paar Tage vorher Karl Lauterbach getwittert hatte. Lauterbach twitterte, ja, gegen die englische Variante kann dieser Astra-Impfstoff nicht ganz so gut wirken. Aber das große Problem ist die südafrikanische Variante. Da wirkt er so gut wie gar nicht. Darunter ganz, ganz viele Kommentare dann auf Twitter von Politikern und so. Ja, jetzt wollen wir aber nicht den Leuten Furcht machen und man soll sie doch motivieren, dass sie diese Impfung bekommen. Da muss ich sagen, halten wir jetzt Wahrheit zurück. Sagen wir jetzt, oh, das können wir den Leuten nicht zutrauen, dass wir jetzt sagen, was der Fall ist. Auf die Herdenimmunität geht jetzt Kekule hier auch ein.
Die Daten sind umstritten. Ja, das liegt bei mir immer noch in der Waagschale, dass AstraZeneca da am Anfang so ein bisschen Hokus Pokus mit den Zahlen gemacht hat. Es ist ziemlich klar, dass die südafrikanische Variante durch den AstraZeneca-Impfstoff weniger abgehalten wird. Also der Impfstoff schützt weniger deutlich vor der südafrikanischen Variante. Da gibt es inzwischen einige Zahlen. Da sieht es auch bei den RNA-Impfstoffen besser aus. Mehr Nebenwirkungen hatten wir jetzt gerade schon mit Fragezeichen im Raum stehen.
Ja, und diese Argumentation zu sagen, ich finde das jetzt gefährlich, das jetzt zu sagen. Man kann jetzt nicht die ganze Wahrheit sagen. Das ist eine sehr verräterische Formulierung. Das ist nämlich eigentlich ein sehr undemokratisches Verständnis. Das heißt, man muss Teile wissenschaftlicher Erkenntnisse und Teile der Wahrheit als eine Gefahr ansehen. Muss sie zurückhalten, kann sie den Bürger nicht zumuten. Und das ist ein Demokratieverständnis, das dann eigentlich auf eine bevormundende Haltung hinausläuft. Und dann sagt man, liebe Bürger, wir können euch nicht alles sagen, aber glaubt mal, dass das alles so richtig ist, wie wir das machen. Und wir haben jetzt bei den Schnelltests ja gesehen, wie irregeleitet das dann sein kann. Deswegen finde ich das gerade wichtig, dass Leute wie Lauterbach auch darauf hinweisen. Und wir haben jetzt etwa 5%, sagt Lauterbach, dieser Fälle in Köln gemessen. Wir sequenzieren ja gar nicht, wie die Engländer das tun. Wahrscheinlich wird sonst noch alles viel schlimmer aussehen.
Wobei, man muss das gar nicht so sequenzieren. Wenn man weiß, was man sucht, kann man das schon in die PCR einbauen. Also das kleine Sequent, das man sucht, kann man da schon einbauen. Deswegen muss man gar nicht den Riesenaufwand der Sequenz... Das wäre dann... Sequenzwähr... Sequenzierung braucht man, wenn man Mutationen findet, die man noch nicht kennt. Aber wenn man die schon kennt, weiß man ja, wo man nachher sucht. Dann kann man das sogar da einprogrammieren.
Stimmt.
Also es wäre ein großer Aufwand, das wirklich ein Programm.
Fünf Prozent sind schon da. Wir hatten vor ein paar Wochen, als wir hier sprachen, fünf Prozent der britischen Variante. Jetzt spricht man von 25 Prozent. Man kann sich also denken, wie schnell sich möglicherweise diese südafrikanische Variante ausbreitet. Oder ob auch eine deutsche Variante noch entsteht. Auch das ist ja einfach möglich. Insofern ist das ja etwas, was man erst einmal äußern kann, als einen Grund dafür, dass AstraZeneca nicht so gut ist. Aber jemand, der jetzt akut die Möglichkeit hat, sich Astra spritzen zu lassen und aber auch vielleicht eine Garantie bekommt, dafür, dass er in vier Monaten Biontech bekommt. Das wäre ja auch was, mit dem man einen großen Anreiz schaffen konnte. Aber momentan scheint es mir eher so zu sein, als würde man sagen, naja, gut, das wird schon reichen. Jetzt habt euch mal nicht so. Denn eigentlich ist das doch schon mal viel mehr, als wir gedacht haben. Und damit ist gut. Und da muss ich sagen, naja, wir haben ja einen sehr guten Impfstoff. Warum soll man jetzt so tun, als gäbe es den nicht? Denn den gibt es ja auch für viele Leute. Ich kann eine Anekdote erzählen aus dem privaten Bereich, aus einem sehr bekannten deutschen Krankenhaus. Zwei Oberärzte, die Astra bekommen sollten, dann aber herausfanden, dass alle darüber, über ihnen, also Chefärzte und Verwaltungsdoktor, die haben alle Biontech bekommen. Dann wurde nachgefragt und so, naja, gut, also das muss doch jetzt erst mal reichen. Und dann haben die auch gesagt, ne, dann machen wir das jetzt mal gerade nicht. Also da sieht man schon, wer dann den Besseren bekommt. Das sind nämlich nicht dann nur die Gruppen, bei denen man wirklich sagt, okay, wir verhindern da Tode und alles, sondern da sieht man auch wieder eine Zweiklassengesellschaft, die sich dort einschleicht.
Lass mich da mal ein Clip, denn Frank Montgomery, den wir alle kennen als den Weltärztepräsident, wir wissen alle nicht, was das bedeutet, aber wie auch immer, der hat sich ja tatsächlich massenmedial so geäußert.
Wir brauchen hochwirksame Impfstoffe für Menschen mit hohem Risiko, also medizinisches Personal und alte Kranke und Beladende. Lassen Sie uns den anderen Impfstoff für Risikogruppe 2 nehmen, für jüngere, weniger mit Risiko belastete, das wäre besser.
Ja, also er teilt hier ganz klar ein, es gibt die einen, die brauchen den besseren und die anderen, naja, da wird ja der Körper selber so und sagen mithelfen und so weiter. Und er hat dann also nicht nur hier diese Unterscheidung aufgemacht, den jetzt auf Twitter viele schreiben müssen, Herr Montgomery, sind Sie verrückt, Sie können doch hier nicht und so weiter den Impfstoff vielleicht reden, sondern er hat dann auch noch Verständnis gezeigt für den Fall, den du gerade geäußert hast.
Zweifel am Impfstoff vom Vorsitzenden des Weltärztebundes Montgomery. Er habe Verständnis, wenn sich medizinisches Personal nicht damit impfen lassen würde. Massive Kritik vom Spitzenverband der Fachärzte.
Wer so aus Gründen der Selbstdarstellung die Wirksamkeit und den Nutzen dieses Impfstoffs in Zweifel zieht und von einer Impfung des medizinischen Personals damit abrät, der sendet, so meinen wir, ein fatales Signal.
Ja, aber was ist denn das andere Signal? Also das, was du jetzt angesprochen hast. Was ist eigentlich dieses andere Signal? Du hast auch Songbird gesehen, diesen Film, den Michael Bay damit zu verantworten hat, über Covid-23. Das spielt ein bisschen in der Zukunft.
Da sind die Varianten sehr aggressiv.
Genau, die fliegen in der Luft.
Da ist eine Afrikanische gar nichts.
Man darf gar nicht mehr vor die Tür. Die Welt wird auch eingeteilt, in die die schon geimpft sind. Es gibt keine Impfung, sondern die, die immun sind und nicht. Da sieht man, welche krassen Differenzen es ausgeht. Mittlerweile wird das ein bisschen durchgespielt. Wir hören aus Los Angeles und so, dass da für eine komische Mutation rumschwirren. Ich würde auch sagen, wenn wir so ein Phänomen haben wie das Virus, sowas wie Biontech, wo ist die Anstrengung jetzt zu sagen, und wir haben bei Biontech auch einen Impfstoff, den wir so schnell neu designen und dann anpassen können, wo ist die Anstrengung es einfach allen zur Verfügung zu stellen? Wo ist das große Mondlandungsziel zu sagen, bis Jahresende fünf Milliarden Dosen?
Dann würde man jetzt sagen, diese Forderung, dass wir das jetzt hier wollen, das ist doch ein Luxusproblem. Und das habe ich jetzt so häufig gelesen, dass diejenigen, die skeptisch gegenüber Astra sind, als Leute abgestempelt wurden, die Luxusprobleme haben. Man soll doch mal in ärmere Länder gucken, die haben gar keinen Impfstoff. Und ich warne sehr davor, diese Debatte zu führen. Da muss man vorsichtig sein. Nämlich mit dieser Argumentation Luxusproblem, kann man auch den Schutz von sehr Alten ablehnen, indem man sagt, wenn 90-Jährige sterben, ist das ein Luxusproblem. In Nigeria liegt die Lebenserwartung bei 54 Jahren. So kann ich auch mit einer Luxusdebatte anfangen. Und das wollen wir nicht. Deswegen ist es richtig, dass wir die Alten schützen. Aber man kann jetzt nicht plötzlich sagen, wo Leute Zweifel haben, sagen, ich hätte aber schon gerne in den nächsten zwei, drei Monaten den sehr, sehr guten Impfstoff. Da kann man nicht einfach das als Luxusdebatte abtun. Dann können wir eigentlich sofort einpacken und sagen, das ist alles Luxusdebatte gegenüber indischen Wanderarbeitern. Dann geht es auch Hartz-IV-Empfängern prächtig. Aber ist das jetzt unser Maßstab?
Ja, vor allem, was mich auch stört, wir verweigern uns wirklich, wie du es eben schon gesagt hast, wissenschaftlichem Wissen. Zum einen, AstraZeneca ist nur in Deutschland nicht für über 65-Jährige zugelassen, weil die in der Testphase nicht vorkamen und wir deswegen nichts über sie wissen. Wir wissen aber mittlerweile aus Großbritannien, der AstraZeneca-Impfstoff ist auch für die supergut. Wer jetzt die ganze Zeit meint, damit soll mal die 2. Klasse, also die 2. Risiko-Abteilung, die soll sich damit impfen lassen. Klar, ich bin dafür, dass sich jeder mit allem, was zur Verfügung steht, impfen lässt. Aber wenn wir doch wissen, dass es auch für die Alten geht, dann sollten wir auch die Alten jetzt erst mal schützen. Denn das ist die Risikogruppe Nr. 1. Wir hatten bisher kein Wissen, deswegen haben wir sie rausgenommen. Das muss jetzt aber nachgearbeitet werden. Genauso wie mit der 1. Impfung und der 2. Impfung. In Großbritannien hat man wahnsinnig große Erfolge, damit man die 1. Impfung einfach überall verspritzt, wo es nur geht. Und eben nicht in den Kühlschrank legt, weil nach so vielen Stunden muss dann die 2. Impfung erfolgen. Sondern dass man da einfach sagt, wenn das produziert ist, kann man dann verimpfen. Ob das in 3 Wochen ist oder in 3 Monaten, ist erstmal egal. Hauptsache, die 1. Impfung sind weg. Diese Strategien fallen ja in Deutschland alle aus. Das wäre aber viel mehr, dass man da mal nacharbeiten und nachsteuern müsste, als jetzt Risikogruppe 2. Und da ist es auch ein echtes Problem. Wir fangen jetzt an, den AstraZeneca-Impfstoff für die zweite Risikogruppe zu nehmen. In die fallen auch Vorerkrankte. Da ist nicht nur das Alte ausschlaggebend. Jetzt haben wir aber hier ein kleines Problem in Deutschland. Das wurde hier in den Nachrichten mal aufgegriffen. Denn wir haben ja ein kleines Problem in der Organisation. Wenn man zu viel verwaltet, da kommt man mal an Verwaltungsprobleme. Also wie sieht, wie kann Bürokratie der Impfstrategie im Weg stehen?
Immerhin sollen schon bald auch Menschen mit Vorerkrankungen geimpft werden.
Doch diese nachzuweisen, ist aufwendig. Nur mit Attest des Arztes gibt es einen Termin im Impfzentrum. Dieses Prozedere will die AOK Bremen ihren Versicherten ersparen.
Das ist ja vor allem auch ein Aufwand, der dazu führt, dass sich zusätzlich Menschen infizieren, weil sie unnötig zum Arzt gehen.
So, die Risikogruppe 1, Alter 90 plus, die konnte man einfach einladen. Da geht man einfach zum Meldeamt und fragt, wie alt sind sie denn. Oder man fragt bei der Krankenkasse nach Vorerkrankung. Das erinnert mich so ein bisschen an den Behindertensport. Da muss man erst mal gucken, wie gewichtet man die jetzt miteinander. Welche Faktoren rechnet man da rein, damit die Zeiten irgendwie vergleichbar sind usw. Und wer vorerkrankt ist, wird nicht einfach automatisiert eingeladen. Das Verfahren geht hier viel, viel langsamer. Die Leute müssen sich selber erst mal bei ihrem eigenen Arzt einen Attest holen über ihre Vorerkrankung, die eigentlich udokumentiert sein sollte. Man hat ja eine medizinische Akte usw. Und dadurch, und das war wirklich interessant diese Woche, hatten wir einen Tag, an dem es hieß, AstraZeneca bleibt liegen, weil die Leute nicht wollen, weil sie ihre Termine nicht wahrnehmen. Dann haben wir einen Tag später gehört, nachdem dann mal ein bisschen recherchiert wurde, da wurde einfach niemand eingeladen. Es gab einfach keine Einladungsabläufe. Deswegen wusste man gar nicht, wie organisiert man das denn jetzt eigentlich. Also wir haben ja auf so vielen Ebenen Probleme, die Impfung loszuwerden.
Um das gerade noch anekdotisch hinzuzufügen. Mein Vater rief mich an, am 16. Februar, das ist mir extra notiert, am 16. Februar, weißt du, was das war? Da war ein großer Tag. Dann kamen aus der Bundesdruckerei die Gutscheine für die Masken, um sie in der Apotheke abzulehnen. Er las das dann vor, bleiben sie gesund, herzliche Grüße ihrer Bundesregierung und so weiter. Ein langes Schreiben. Und dann diese Gutscheine, die dann ganz prächtig aussehen. Und das Tolle ist, der erste Gutschein, das stand dann drauf, war gültig vom 1.1. Ja, und waren dann bis zum 28.2. gültig. Also, drei Viertel der Gültigkeit wurde sowieso schon vertrödelt, bis dann dieses Schreiben endlich mal reinkam. Nun hatte mein Vater Möglichkeiten, an das an Masken zu kommen. Aber man sieht einfach, wie schwierig das offenbar ist, einfach mal zu sagen, es gibt jetzt diese Masken, wer über 65 oder über 60 ist, kann sie sich abholen, fertig. Und sollte sich irgendwo jemand in zwei Apotheken was abholen, dann ist das halt so, dann sind diese Leute halt auch besser geschützt. An wem liegt es denn jetzt? Da wird ja jetzt kein Reibach mit Masken mehr gemacht. Das ist ja nicht so, dass die Rolex-Uren verschenkt haben.
Ja, also zwei FP2-Masken gibt es bei uns im Supermarkt für mittlerweile 1, 20 Euro oder so. Das heißt, diese große Gefahr, dass es da einen Schwarzmarkt von denjenigen ausgehend gibt, die sich in der Apotheke illegal bereichern an Masken, hätte es aufgrund des niedrigen Preises gar nicht bedurft. Und jetzt haben wir echt das Problem, jetzt können wir mal über die Impfkosten auch reden. Sechs FFP2-Masken, die zum Selbstzahlerpreis für 2 Euro das Stück von der Bundesregierung mit 6 Euro bezuschusst werden, 6 mal 6 sind schon 36 Euro plus diese Aufwand in der Bundesdruckerei usw. Also diese Maskenaktion über die Bundesdruckerei hat 76 Euro pro Fall gekostet. 76 Euro. Und dann kam plötzlich auf Twitter in der Diskussion auf, ob 54, 8 Euro für eine Impfung gegen Covid-19 von BioNTech zu viel gewesen ist. Denn das war der initiale Preis, den BioNTech damals als allererstes in den Ring geworfen hat im Sommer in der EU-Kommission, als sie meinten, wir wissen ehrlich gesagt noch nicht, was das kostet. Aber das ist mal der Preis, bei dem wir auf Nummer sicher gehen wollen, hier betriebswirtschaftlich. Dann hat man sich ein paar Tage später auf 15 Euro geeinigt. Also nähen sich keine große Dramatik. Trotzdem, bei 54, 8 Euro wäre meine Forderung gewesen, wenn man mich demokratisch eingebunden hätte, im Sinne von, wir beteiligen sie, wir wollen einfach nur wissen, wenn sie es noch keinen Preis hätten, ich sage, 54, 8 Euro, hier bitte impfen, bezahle ich selbst. 54, 8 Euro ist kein Preis. Nicht mal für eine Impfung.
Genau, und man hätte das auch so machen können, dass eben alle, die sich das nicht leisten können, bekommen ihn bezahlt, die anderen können ihn zahlen. Ich hätte als Politiker sogar noch Folgendes gemacht, und jetzt kommt hier der Marktwirtschaftler in mir. Jetzt ist aber wirklich ihr IFO-Institut, mach ich jetzt hier. Also der Clemens Fuest, man kann über ihn denken, was man will, aber momentan sagt er kluge Sachen. Das stimmt. Was hätte ich gemacht? IFO-Institut hätte ich gesagt, 54 Euro, guter Preis, machen wir. Aber pass auf, wir zahlen 65 Euro pro Dosis, wenn ihr es zwei Monate schneller herbeibringt.
Fuest-Bonus-Ding. Und da bin ich absolut dafür, das jetzt immer noch zu machen.
Und warum sage ich das jetzt? Jetzt werden wieder Leute denken, na ja, aber eigentlich geht es doch darum, dass die Pharmaindustrie nicht solche Gewinne macht und all das. Ja, und wenn ich könnte, würde ich das auch sehr umstrukturieren. Und ich weiß, wie schlimm da mit Medikamenten weltweit umgegangen wird, dass Leute keinen Zugang zu Medikamenten haben. Bei diesen Impfungen wird das anders sein. Wir haben ja auch Bill Gates erlebt bei der Münchner Sicherheitskonferenz. Das wird sich anders verhalten. Aber grundsätzlich ist das ein sehr, sehr großes Problem. Man muss aber sehen, wie eine sinnvolle Verstaatlichung aussähe. Denn klar ist auch, wir sind hier nicht im geisteswissenschaftlichen Mittelbau. Das sind also keine Leute, die man einfach jetzt anstellen könnte, für 1800 Euro halbe Stelle oder so. Sondern das heißt, man müsste das komplett umstrukturieren, dass es auch einen Anreiz gibt, dass diese Topforscher dann in Deutschland, in Europa bleiben. Darüber kann man diskutieren. Man kann auch darüber diskutieren, ob man gewisse Preise drosselt, dass gewisse Spekulationen nicht möglich sind. All das ist zu tun. Ich glaube, nur jetzt ist der absolut falsche Zeitpunkt für eine Grundsatzdebatte. Denn es geht jetzt nur darum, zu sagen, wie kommen wir möglichst schnell aus dieser Krise raus? Wie haben wir möglichst wenige Tote? Da können wir jetzt nicht sagen, na ja, aber jetzt diskutieren wir mal über die Pharmaindustrie. Und es ist doch schlimm, dass sie sich daran bereichern. Na ja, man kann auch sagen, es gibt eine Lebensmittelindustrie, die bereichert sich daran, dass kleine Kinder schon früh dick werden. Was weiß ich alles? Also da könnte ich jetzt so viel aufzählen. Ich könnte ganz viele Ungerechtigkeiten dieser Welt nennen. Und dass man sich jetzt so sehr darauf kapriziert, ist eigentlich ein sehr, sehr schlichtes Verständnis von Kapitalismus. Und das sage ich jetzt hier aus einer marxistischen Position heraus.
Ich meine, wir haben schon darüber gesprochen, aus wie vielen Millionären und Milliardären während der Corona-Krise Supermillionäre und Supermilliardäre wurden. Warum verweigert man das jetzt angeblich den Forschern, die seit 20 Jahren Krebsmedikamente forschen und jetzt mit Covid-Impfungen Durchbruch haben? Warum sollte man denen jetzt plötzlich verweigern, nach Buchwert, weil ja Unternehmenswert entsprechend steigt, auch Milliardäre zu werden? Also das ist ja schon mal eine völlig verpeilte Nightdebatte. Auf der anderen Seite, wie findet so eine Preisfindung für Impfstoffe statt? Das wissen wir ja alle nicht. Meine Vermutung wäre, und das ist ja auch eine Rechnung von Clemens Fuest, wir gehen in die Verhandlung rein und zwar ganz offen, indem wir sagen, hört mal zu Leute, ihr habt die Impfstoffe und wir haben Schaden von 1500 Euro pro Fall. Eine Impfung ist uns im maximalen 1500 Euro Wert. Das ist wirklich der vom IFO-Institut ausgerechnete Wert einer Impfung. Und jetzt sagt uns mal, was kostet das bei euch? Und wenn die dann sagen, 54, 8 Euro, dann sag ich doch nicht, das ist zu viel. Das passt nicht, weil die Leute bezahlen ja nur 500, 600 Euro für ihre Krankenkasse pro Monat. Da können wir jetzt nicht 10% davon abknapsen, um uns gegen die Covid-Pandemie abzuschirmen. Das ist ja völlig verrückt. Auf der anderen Seite, das ist ein Tweet von Phil Hackemann, dem nach 6.000 Gefällt-mir-Angaben und über 1.000 Retweets auch nicht groß widersprochen wurde, sondern da stiegen dann alle ein. Auch Markus Grill, der den Preis ja durch seine Recherchearbeit herausgefunden hat, das erste Angebot. Vergleich von Impfstoffkosten. Windpocken 56 Euro, Gürtelrose 104 Euro, HPV 163 Euro, Gelbfieber 52 Euro, Hepatitis 60 Euro, Mending-Kocken 108 Euro, Cholera 63 Euro, Tollwood 75 Euro, Pneumokocken 80 Euro. Also Biontech fällt hier völlig unter diese Schwelle von dem, was ich gerade vorgelesen habe. Und das sollte es uns wirklich wert sein. Und wenn danach dieses Geld sich bei Pfizer und Biontech sammelt und in dem Unternehmen ist, das seit 20 Jahren Krebsmedikamente erforscht, wo ist das Problem?
Es gibt Schlimmeres und wir können ja mal das Wissen Privatpatienten, ich habe mir das mal von einem Privatpatienten zeigen lassen, wenn man so Abrechnungen sieht von Arztbesuchen, was dort alles berechnet wird, was man nicht besonders verlangt hat oder so und wo all reibach damit gemacht wird. Es ist sowieso ganz ganz furchtbar. Also da müssen wir uns jetzt nicht an so einem Detail aufhalten. Hören wir vielleicht aber nochmal gerade bei Kikuli rein, weil das war dann etwas, was man besonders kritisierte, dass er das nochmal ganz klar sagt mit dem Impfstoff zweiter Klasse.
Ganz praktisch gesehen ist es so, ein DNA-Impfstoff ist an neue Varianten auch viel schwieriger anzupassen als ein RNA-Impfstoff. Das dauert viel viel länger aus technischen Gründen. Und wir müssen wohl eine Anpassung machen wegen der neuen Varianten, die da sind, sodass so ein bisschen politisch die Frage ist, will man jetzt auf so eine Karte, auf so eine Technologie überhaupt setzen, wenn man jetzt sieht, okay, wir müssen innerhalb der nächsten Monate mit hoher Wahrscheinlichkeit eine Anpassung vornehmen, kaufe ich mir dann sozusagen so ein Impfstoffprodukt ein, wo ich ganz sicher weiß, das kriege ich nicht in einer abgedateten Version rechtzeitig. Und psychologisch vielleicht für die Deutschen zumindest, wenn ich das mal von meinen Kindern nehme. Also AstraZeneca ist halt deutlich billiger. Ja, das ist vielleicht ein Vorteil. Aber es gibt auch Leute, die sagen, naja, das billige Zeug will ich nicht. Das ist halt bei uns einfach so dekadent, das sein mag. Deshalb aus all diesen Gründen, ja, AstraZeneca ist ein Impfstoff zweiter Klasse. Das ist die zweite Wahl.
Um das nochmal aufzugreifen, was er da sagt, das ist bei uns Deutschen so. Ich habe mit einem Bekannten in England gesprochen. Der sagt, ja, ich glaube, ihr führt diese Debatte ein bisschen erbitterter in Deutschland. Aber bei uns gibt es das auch. Und er erzählte dann von seinen Schwiegereltern. Die hatten einen Impftermin oder oder besorgten sich einen und versuchten, über Bekannte rauszufinden, in welchem Impfzentrum wird dann Astra und in welchem wird, ich glaube, Moderna haben die da verimpft. Und dann haben sie versucht, in das RNA-Impfzentrum zu kommen und nicht zu Astra. Was sie nicht wussten, ist, dass das wohl immer wieder wechselt. Und dadurch haben sie auch dann doch Astra bekommen und haben es auch genommen. Nur auch dort gibt es die Überlegung, also das ist auch so ein doch sehr eigenartiger Mechanismus bei Twitter, dass egal, was kommt, man immer gleich sagt, ja, das ist typisch deutsch, das ist Allmann. Steht dann ja immer da und dann sagt man, nee, auch andere Leute denken über Qualität nach. Und ich finde dann sehr, sehr gut, was er nochmal sagt, Kekulé, über diese Sache, dass Lauterbach und Spahn sich öffentlich mit Astra impfen lassen wollen. Ob das denn jetzt sehr sinnvoll sei?
Ich sage mal vielleicht so, also wenn jetzt die zwei Leute, die ja sofort gestern in den Medien gesagt haben, ich würde mich damit impfen lassen, also der eine von beiden ist der Bundesgesundheitsminister selbst, von dem jeder weiß, dass er schon Covid hatte und der andere ist Herr Lauterbach, der sich glaube ich sogar öffentlich mit dem AstraZeneca Impfstoff impfen lassen will. Also wenn jetzt Politiker anfangen, so demonstrativ vorzubreschen und sich quasi, sich quasi da ins Zeug zu legen, persönlich, ich habe dann immer so den Verdacht, dass die Argumente alle sind und dass man mehr Gesten braucht statt Argumente. Und ich glaube aber, da unterschätzen die Politiker, die Deutschen, die sind da, die sind also jetzt mal die ganzen Aluhüte ausgenommen, aber der normale Deutsche guckt sich das ganz rational an, schaut sich die Wirksamkeit an, liest die Daten dazu und sagt dann, mach ich es oder warte ich lieber auf, bis ich das andere Zeug kriege.
Vor allem, wenn das bei Jens Spahn so komisch klingt. Ich habe hier zufällig diesen Ausschnitt mal.
Auch der Bundesgesundheitsminister würde sich mit AstraZeneca impfen lassen.
Ich werde jedenfalls sofort bereit dazu, weil ich einfach auch an die EU-Zulassungsprozesse und ihre Prüfungen im ordentlichen Verfahren davon sehr überzeugt bin. Und deswegen werde ich mich zu gegebenen Zeit sicherlich auch damit impfen lassen.
Klang das überzeugend? Das ist doch erwärmlich.
Nein, und es klang eher, ich mache das, weil ich die EU liebe. Und da muss ich sagen, das ist dann doch ein bisschen zu viel. Ich kann mir noch so einen blauen Poli anziehen gerne mit EU-Sternchen, wenn es denn sein muss. Aber das ist jetzt zu viel, das Patriotismus. Und auch zu albern, da gibt es bessere Argumente. Zum Beispiel das Argument, wir haben jetzt gerade nichts anderes, das hat man versäumt. Das ist auch jetzt nicht innerhalb von drei Wochen zu ändern. Deswegen kommt man schnell dran, ist es gut. Noch ist nicht so ganz klar, inwieweit es vielleicht irgendwelche Komplikationen gibt, wenn man erst den einen Impfstoff dann den anderen hat. Da ist man noch ein bisschen sich am Streiten. Naja, ich bin da mal hoffnungsfroh, dass das alles funktioniert. Nur glaube ich, dass es sehr wichtig ist, auch diesen Druck jetzt gerade zu machen, den Kekule und andere machen. Warum? Es ist nur der Druck, der wirklich auch politisch dazu führt, dass man sagt, gut, wir bauen jetzt noch mal Kapazitäten für Biontech aus. Wir sehen zu, dass wir im September so viel wie wir wollen davon haben. Wenn dieser Druck nicht da ist, dann passiert nichts. Man muss sich das ein bisschen so vorstellen, es ist nicht wie, wenn man zu Hause sitzt und fragt sich, was soll ich denn heute kochen? So ist nicht Regierung. Das ist nicht, ich gehe mal in den Supermarkt, gucke, was sie da haben. Und dann baue ich mir mal irgendwas zusammen und schmeiße es in den Topf. So funktioniert Regieren nicht, sondern Regieren ist meist reagieren auf irgendeinen Druck, was man jetzt bei den Schnelltests ja auch sieht. Es gibt einen so hohen Druck jetzt, dass sie jetzt in irgendeiner Weise etwas machen müssen. Und so ist es jetzt auch bei dem Impfstoff. Und ich habe sonst große Sorge, dass gerade jüngere Menschen abgespeist werden mit diesem Astra. Und man gibt denen das dann erst, ja, irgendwann 2022, wenn dann mal Biontech auch genügend da sein sollte, könnt ihr euch auch damit impfen lassen. Und dann würde ich ganz klar nochmal sagen, an die jungen Menschen, lasst euch nicht abspeisen. Eure Entbehrungen waren größer eigentlich als die der Senioren. Ich will jetzt nicht über die verstorbenen Senioren sprechen, aber jetzt die Senioren, die sich zurücknehmen mussten aus dem öffentlichen Leben. Ja, die haben an Weihnachten nicht die gesamte Familie empfangen. Aber ihr jungen Menschen, ihr konntet nicht reisen, was ihr sonst gerne tut. Ihr konntet nicht küssen, nicht feiern, nicht ins Kino gehen, nicht aufs Festival gehen und so weiter. Ihr seid nicht diejenigen, die einfach abends sagen, ach, ist ja schon acht Uhr, da kommt doch gleich der Krimi. Und da wurden ganz viele Entbehrungen hingenommen. Und deswegen finde ich, haben jüngere Menschen nun auch das Recht zu sagen, ja, wir wollen aber jetzt auch mal hier First Class bedient werden.
Genau, ich bin für eine ganz große Anstrengung. CureVac kommt wohl im Mai. Die Zulassungsverbande terminiert so auf Mai. Das ist dann in der Hoffnung, dass sie jetzt schon mit Bayer, ich hab vorhin so ein bisschen gelesen, ich konnte es noch nicht nachlesen, Bayer hat wohl 10 Milliarden Verlust gemacht in einem Jahr. Die könnten also auch mal so einen neuen Antrieb erwarten, wenn sie da mit CureVac zusammenarbeiten und die Produktion hochfahren, dass es im Mai dann relativ viel RNA-Impfstoff gibt. Wir kommen nachher noch mal auf Bill Gates zu sprechen. Der sieht ja, das fehlt in Deutschland ja komplett, der sieht ja so eine Chance in der Krise. Was könnte man jetzt eigentlich volksgesundheitlich so insgesamt damit machen? Und mit Astra, also mit Astra können wir jetzt Covid besiegen. Mit diesen RNA-Impfstoffen können wir die ganze Welt einmal umkrempeln. Zum einen haben wir noch ein völlig unausgebeutetes, also wir wissen noch gar nicht, was man damit alles machen kann. Bisher war es ja Krebsforschung, jetzt versucht man das mit der Impfung. Das hat im ersten Anlauf wunderbar geklappt. Was kann man eigentlich noch alles damit machen? Also schon allein um diese Forschungsanstrengungen, diese Richtung weitergehen zu lassen, muss man da jetzt Geld reinpumpen, wobei mittlerweile die Motivation sehr hoch ist, diesen RNA-Ding nachzugehen. Und wir können das Zeug halt super schnell updaten, also sehr viel schneller. Wir haben das ja gelesen bei David Wallace-Wales, dass man jetzt einfach eine Grundlage schafft mit dem RNA-Dings. Und dann fügt man einfach eine neue Sequenz ein und muss eben nicht nochmal die ganzen Phase 1, 2, 3, sondern rafft das dann zusammen auf zwei Monate und dann hätte man innerhalb von einem Quartal abgedatet. Und wenn man dann, und das ist jetzt die Aufgabe, die Kapazität so hoch hält, dass man es dann auch wirklich schafft, Milliarden und Milliarden pro Monat zu impfen, also dass man so eine Pandemie einfach, bevor sie ausbricht, schon mal einfängt, indem man in einem halben Jahr Herden immunitär herstellt, weil wir wissen ja, diese Impfungen können sich ja im Körper einfach ansammeln. Da sind dann Gedächtniszellen, die liegen da so rum. Man läuft nicht irgendwann mal über an Impfstoffen oder so was körperlich, deswegen kann man da einfach alles mitmachen. Und in der Ansicht ist das doch eine Richtung, in die man gehen sollte. So, jetzt haben wir nicht genug Impfstoffe, weshalb wir noch mal schnell über die Antigen-Tests sprechen. Da gab es auch Erleuchtendes.
Ja, es war doch so, dass wir darüber sprachen. Und ich mehrmals, dann sagte ich, aber Stefan, warum wird das dann nicht einfach genehmigt? Wer verhindert das denn? Wer profitiert davon, dass es verhindert wird? Und dann gab es jetzt dann eine Antwort.
Es gab jetzt die Antwort auf die Frage, warum ist das mit den Antigen-Tests, von denen wir erstens wissen, wie wirksam sie sind, nämlich noch erstaunlich wirksamer als eine Impfung. Eine Impfung bringt selbst bei BioNTech 95% Sicherheit vor Erkrankungen. Ein Antigen-Test ist zu 99% spezifisch und aussagekräftig. Bei dem, was er aussagt. Wenn wir doch nur alle Antigen-Tests hatten, dann könnten wir genauso den Wert, den R-Wert auf 0, 001 drücken und hätten damit innerhalb von einem Monat alles besiegt. Das hören wir nachher auch bei Bill Gates. Bill Gates Vorstellung ist, Diagnosemöglichkeit, sodass wir ein Fünftel der Welt innerhalb einer Woche testen. Das ist so, wie Bill Gates denkt. Eine Milliarde Tests pro Woche, was ist denn das für eine Idee?
Was ist, wenn da ein falscher Tester ist?
Oh ja, was ist, wenn da ein falscher Tester ist? Dann garantiert sich der Falsche statt alle, die dann garantieren. Statt Lockdown musste sich einer garantieren, der es gar nicht nötig gehabt hätte. Na ja, Karl Lauterbach sitzt jedenfalls bei Markus Lanz und wirft mal diesen kleinen Spruch hier ein.
Aber es hat natürlich auch von Seiten der Laborärzte die Befürchtung gegeben, also wenn hier die Selbsttests oder die Antigen-Tests massenhaft gemacht werden, dann geht die Zahl der PCR-Tests runter. Das ist ja übrigens auch passiert.
Die verdienen ja kein Geld mehr.
Ja, verdienen noch immer genug Geld. Aber die Zahl der PCR-Tests ist ja ungefähr um 50% zurückgegangen. Die Idee war, wenn wir jetzt sehr viele Antigen-Tests machen, dann wird der ein oder andere PCR-Test überflüssig. Denn wenn ich einen negativen Antigen-Test habe, dann muss ich nicht mehr zum PCR. Daher gab es dann natürlich auch Lobby-Arbeit. Aber lange in kurzer Sinn, dass es nichts Ungewöhnliches ist.
Heißt das, die Lobby verhindert?
Nein, jetzt nicht mehr. Das wird kommen, dass es alles zulassen.
Das landet übrigens sehr gut bei so was. Dass man nachpiekst und sagt, wie nicht mehr? Ja, jetzt nicht mehr. Da gab es doch auch Zahlen, dass man sagte, da springt jede Woche mal ein Ferrari bei raus.
Genau, das hat der Spiegel mal in eine Überschrift gepackt. Pro Labor verdient man sich jeden Tag einen Ferrari. Jeden Tag sogar? Jonas Schmidt-Ranassit hat ja schon vor... Damals noch im Sommer, August, eine Ilgnat-Sendung im August, da hat er schon gesagt, diese Labore sind derzeit nur mit Covid beschäftigt. Und zwar sehr viel mehr als jemals zuvor. Und da findet ja auch eine Preisfindung statt, im Sinne von, die Unikliniken können keine Tests mehr machen, weil die privaten Labore schon die ganzen Sachen, die man so braucht, vom Markt weggekauft haben. Und dann selber dem Staat sagen, also wir können für euch PTA-Tests machen, kosten aber 140 Euro pro Test. Und dann meinte der Schmidt-Ranassit schon, da kann man auch als Staat einfach sagen, wir zahlen euch nur 35 Euro. Und wenn ihr dagegen seid, dann kommt halt irgendein süddeutscher Text, der das mal aufbereitet, wie ihr euch da verhaltet. Aber man könnte diesen Preis auch einfach mal diktieren und sagen, wir wissen, was das bei euch kostet. Und das ist jetzt unser Preis, den wir machen. Also in der Ansicht, wurden da...
Da könnte man es mal umgekehrt machen. Nicht wie bei den Impfstoffen, sondern hier könnte man ganz klar auch staatliche Macht ausspielen.
Genau, und Kikole hat ja in seinem Podcast damals auch schon gesagt, die verdienen da nicht Millionen, sondern Milliarden. Also er wird richtig viel Geld verdienen. Und jetzt, dass wir das im Februar 2020 so als Nebenbeisatz hören. Die Laborärzte opponieren nicht mehr alle so sehr dagegen. Wir könnten jetzt mal Antigentests machen, wenn wir gleichzeitig wissen, was Antigentests eigentlich bedeuten. Nämlich, dass wir gesagt hätten, im März, na, Roche kommt auf den Markt mit dem Ding, mit dem südkoreanischen Ding, im Mai stellt sich heraus, ja, die sind echt so gut, also die könnte man echt benutzen. Und dass danach nicht eine große Lobbyaktion losgeht, nein, wir brauchen den Goldstandard PCR. Da könnte man die Debatte auch nochmal nachbereiten. Wann immer das Wort Goldstandard PCR fiel oder die Gefahr des Freitestens im Selbsttest, diese komischen Sachen, die da immer eingestreut wurden als Argumente, das ist alles Spin, der wirklich gezielt gemacht wurde. Die Leute testen sich ja nur frei und dann haben wir die Misere. Nein, das ist alles Lobbyarbeit gewesen und Kekule hat es jetzt eingeführt. Und ich würde sagen, wir vergleichen mal. Im Oktober gab es in Deutschland 10.000 Tote, danach kam die zweite Welle und es ist hochgeschnellt auf 60.000 Tote. Also da haben wir 50.000 Tote in der zweiten Welle, von der wir wissen eigentlich, die hätten wir mit einer klugen Teststrategie abfangen können. So wie in Österreich, da gibt es einfach den Wohnzimmertest, der heißt genau so und der ist ausdrücklich dafür da, wenn du Gäste empfängst, du machst das ja eh. Wenn man zum Friseur geht, teste doch vorher. Genau, teste dich doch einfach vorher. Alle vier Leute, die sich da abends treffen, testen sich einfach mal.
Ich habe mit einem Bekannten in Österreich gesprochen, der sagt, ich weiß gar nicht, was ihr da macht, was ist denn da bei euch los? Also er würde laufend diese Tests machen. Es ist so eine Teststraße, die sucht man dann, meldet sich vorher mit dem Smartphone an und danach geht man zum Friseur oder macht sonst irgendetwas. Er sagt, das sei doch alles gar kein Problem. Und da frage ich mich schon auch, jetzt wissen wir, wer da lobbyiert hat, aber wer da politisch auch ein Interesse dran hatte, bzw. irgendwie vielleicht mitverdient hat. Ich bin mal gespannt, ob wir in ein, zwei Jahren dann auch eine große Story da zum Thema PCR und politische Korruption erleben, ob da der eine oder andere wieder irgendeine Immobilie in Berlin und so. Ich will hier mal, ich lasse es mal so stehen. Aber vielleicht kommt es ja so.
Ich stimme dir da voll zu. Es gibt hier strukturelle Argumente, Klammer auf Geld, Klammer zu, die das so bewerkstelligt haben, dass es dazu kam, wie es jetzt ist. Wenn die inhaltlichen Argumente, die in der Politik so umhergingen, die gelten nicht. Wir hören das hier mal von Lauterbach. Er stellt mal eins vor.
Es gab Vorbehalte, die gingen in die folgende Richtung. Die sind so nicht voll artikuliert worden. Aber die Idee war, die dort testen sich. Und wenn die sich getestet haben, sind positiv, gehen die trotzdem zur Arbeit und warnen niemanden. Und das Gesundheitsamt bekommt nie sozusagen den Überblick. Also haben wir dann sozusagen zero Covid, weil sich niemand mehr testen lässt.
Die Wahrheit ist eine ganz andere. Menschen hatten nicht die Möglichkeit, sich zu testen. Und haben dann später festgestellt, krass ich war es, der meinen Großeltern das zugefügt hat. Ich hätte es gern verhindert. Und mir wurden keine Möglichkeiten eingeräumt. Denn die Teststrategie ist ja bis heute ohne Symptome kein Test. Nicht mal in privaten Testzentren. Ohne Symptome kein Test. Und wir wissen, dass es hier um 50-60% asymptomatische oder präsymptomatische Fälle geht. Man liegt also zu Hause, entwickelt einen Fieber und denkt, krass ich war doch am Wochenende noch bei meinen Großeltern. Und das führt zu einem Trauma, dass man sein Leben lang vielleicht nicht überwindet. Und das wurde hier verhindert. Und das in der Politik tatsächlich ernsthaft so diskutiert wurde, im Sinne von, die Leute testen sich dann positiv und gehen dann trotzdem zur Arbeit.
Da gibt es übrigens, falls das wirklich stimmt, auch ein Versagen von Journalisten. Es ist auch ein Versagen von Journalisten, dass ZDF, ARD und so weiter und so fort ständig wieder gesagt haben, na ja, aber das ist ja auch so fraglich mit den Schnelltesten. Wird das dann gemeldet und können die Leute das? Das heißt, die haben ja diese Lobbyideologie oder was heißt diese Lobbystrategie vollkommen übernommen. Und die Politik, die ohnehin gern autoritär auftritt, das hat man ja gerade bei der CDU erlebt, aber dann auch bei allen aus der Opposition, die sich dem so unterworfen haben. Also die Grünen waren ja zum Teil schien es angedockt, an die CDU zu sein und nicht mehr von ihr unterscheidbar. Bei denen konnte man all das merken, was man eigentlich als autoritär verstehen muss, nämlich dass man glaubt, nur wenn man selbst der große Macher als Politiker ist, dann geht es dem Volk gut. Es ist ein bisschen wie die Anekdote von einem Chefredakteur der New York Times, der nie in den Urlaub gefahren ist, weil er sagt, ich kann meine Zeitung nicht alleine lassen. Was passiert mit der Zeitung? In Wahrheit ist er natürlich nie in den Urlaub gefahren, damit er nicht erleben muss, dass es auch ohne ihn funktioniert. Ich glaube, auch das ist furchtbar für Politiker zu sehen, ach, die Bürger hätten das auch alleine gekonnt.
Genau, und das ist vielleicht der wichtigste Punkt überhaupt. Für die Politik steht hier wirklich in Gefahr, festzustellen, dass es ohne sie besser funktioniert. Dass die freien Marktkräfte, und wir haben 300 verschiedene Produkte von über 200 Anbietern, was Schnelltests angeht, dass die das besser in den Griff bekommen als, wenn du eine Impfung brauchst, musst du erst einen Attest beim Arzt holen, die Impfung muss dann so dokumentiert werden, dass es eine halbe Stunde dauert, jemanden zu impfen, damit das RKI auch das Häkchen setzen kann, wieder einer geimpft usw. Das reicht nämlich nicht, dann einfach in die eigene Krankheitsakte zu schreiben oder ein Impfpass. Nein, das muss alles kreuz und quer gemeldet werden. Alle müssen Bescheid wissen. Und Sascha Lobo ist letztens übers Tempelhofer Feld gerannt und hat so einen kleinen Instagram-Film gemacht, in dem man das auch noch mal beschreibt. In Deutschland haben wir eine Diskussion über Inzidenz. Und die wird dann hochgerechnet auf diese 7 Tage usw. Da kennen wir alles mittlerweile. Und dann schwenkt man plötzlich um von 35 auf 50, wieder auf 35, irgendwas ist mit 100, irgendwas ist mit 200. Man vertröstet die Leute, indem man dann jetzt wieder von 50 auf 35 runtergeht. Immer mit dem Argument, danach können die Gesundheitsämter. Danach kann der Staat wieder walten. Und Sascha Lobo weist darauf hin, ne, wir hatten letztes Jahr im Sommer eine Inzidenz von 2, 5 oder so. Hat der Staat das irgendwie einfangen können? Ne, hat er nicht. Wir sollten mal nicht. Die Politik soll nicht immer, ich übertreibe jetzt ein bisschen, wie er das sagte, die soll nicht einfach die Bürger anlügen mit diesem, lasst uns mal an den Steuerhebeln, wir machen das schon für euch, ab 35 trauen wir das Ding Gesundheitsämtern wieder zu und so weiter. Und vielleicht ist jetzt wirklich der Zeitpunkt, in dem man einfach mal sagen muss, Leute, jeder in Deutschland hat einen Hausarzt und wenn nicht, muss man das nochmal schnell organisieren. Jeder hat eine Krankenkasse, jeder kriegt Antigen-Tests. So wie in England, die liegen einfach morgens vor der Tür. Da ist abends jemand rumgegangen und hat die einfach überall verteilt. Die werden dann auch nicht geklaut, weil jeder weiß, der Nachbar braucht auch welche, sonst ist das auch eine Gefahr für mich. Das hat einfach jeder Schnelltest. Und wenn jemand positiv getestet ist, kriegt er einen Anreiz, das zu sagen, indem man ihm einfach 500 Pfund zahlt. So wird das in England gemacht. Junge Leute, die nicht für sich selber eine Woche in Quarantäne gehen, sondern um ihr Arbeitsleben, ihre Nachbarschaften zu schützen, wird einfach gesagt, hier, mach dir eine schöne Woche, 500 Euro, wir geben da aber davon aus, dass du es mit einem leichten Fieber rumkriegst, buch dir 20 Netflix-Amazon-Filme oder sowas, mach dir einen schönen Tag. Und nicht dieses, das muss aber gemeldet werden, und wir können die Schnelltests nicht zulassen, weil würden die Leute wirklich beim Gesundheitsamt anrufen und die meldepflichtige Krankheit weitergeben. Wenn nicht, ne, halt nicht, wenn das so in... Mir ist das jetzt auch wieder aufgefallen. Ich hab zum Beispiel, als Familie haben wir hier drei Kinder, die haben keine Impfungschance und nichts, sie sind alle unter 12. Gleichzeitig sind wir in der Familie, wo die Großeltern hunderte Kilometer weit weg wohnen. Wenn bei uns jetzt ein Corona-Fall auftrete, dann würden wir halt in der Schule anrufen und sagen, Leute, wir als Familie melden uns jetzt mal in die Corona-Ferien ab. Ja, wir haben jetzt hier einfach mal Corona. So, dann hoffen wir irgendwie, dass es mit dem Geruchssinn nicht allzu lange auf sich, weil das wäre dann irgendwie blöd, auch für die Lebensqualität. Aber wir wissen doch genau, was zu tun ist. Wir müssen doch nicht das Gesundheitsamt anrufen, damit die unseren Freunden Bescheid sagen, dass hier ein Corona-Fall in ihrer Nähe ist.
Die Briefe kommen ja dann eh 14 Tage später an. Das ist ja sehr, sehr eigenartig.
Genau, also in der letzten Zeit kann man den Start da ruhig mal rausnehmen. Und dann will ich noch so ein kleines Paradox ansprechen. Ich finde das wahnsinnig interessant, dass auch in wirklich guten deutschen Podcasts, die sagen, wir sind unzufrieden mit der Aufarbeitung, von UKW, von Pavel und Tim, die gestalten ihren ganzen Podcast darum, und das nehme ich jetzt stellvertretend für ganz viele, die in der Diskussion teilnehmen, die gestalten ihr ganzes Nachdenken über Corona anhand der offiziell ermittelten Inzidenzen. Da werden dann große Tabellen gemacht, Rechnungen, die Zahlen, wie viel sind es heute wieder, wie groß ist die Dunkelziffer, alles wird durchkalkuliert. Das heißt, die ganze Diskussion hängt sich auf an die Diagnosen, die stattfinden. Und gleichzeitig finden dort Schnelltests, Antigen-Tests überhaupt gar keine Rolle in der Diskussion. Also Pavel hat das nie aufgegriffen in seiner Besprechung. Ja, mal so zwischendurch irgendwie so ein Halbsatz, so könnte 9 von 10 Infektionen finden, aber dann wieder zurück zu den Zahlen, zu den Tabellen und zu dem ganzen großen Kram. Und das finde ich interessant, dass man auf der einen Seite das ganze Denken auf diagnostizierte Zahlen wünscht, aber dann die andere, also eine parallele Möglichkeit, genau die gleichen Diagnosen zu machen, überhaupt nicht anerkennt.
Weil man dann das Individuum auch denken müsste. Man müsste das Individuum denken. Und wir sind gerade in einer sehr heiklen Lage, dass immer nur Gruppe gedacht wird. Und Gruppe ist dann auch alle, die in Deutschland leben. Und da müssen wir schauen runter, runter, runter. Und wir sehen nicht mehr das Individuelle. Also wir sehen damit nicht Einzelschicksals. Hat mir ja schon ganz früh thematisiert. Sterben allein im Krankenhaus, Angehörige können nicht kommen. Und das fügte aber auch dazu, dass man sagt, ja, für die Gruppe ist es gut, wenn alle geimpft werden. Auch mal mit dem nicht so guten statistisch gesehen. Also so kann man dann auch wieder nur auf Zahlen gucken. Und das sieht man dann auch da, wo man eigentlich auf eine Eigenverantwortlichkeit setzen könnte, um dann am Ende auch in der Gruppe besser dazustehen. Aber dafür müsste man vom Individuum ausgehen. Und das wird dann als eines eigentlich begriffen, das regiert beherrscht werden muss. Also Subjekt heißt ja auch Unterwerfung. Und dann muss man es einer Logik unterwerfen, die eigentlich nur kennt Politik als Wasserhahn. So nenne ich das ja gern. Wir machen den auf oder zu und alles dazwischen gilt nicht. Und das ist das große Problem. Und das ist auch das Problem einiger Virologen, die nur in dieser Gruppe denken. Und bei Twitter ist dieses Gruppendenken ohnehin sehr beliebt. Und das äußert sich dann auch nochmal im Detail mit Team so und so, Team so und so.
Genau. Man versteckt sich wirklich hinter dieser quantitativen Möglichkeit, das aufzubereiten. Und traut sich kein qualitativen Gedanken mehr zu. Das ist ein ganz merkwürdiges Paradox, finde ich. Obwohl es bei beiden ums Gleiche geht. Diagnosen und Zahlen über Antigen-Tests über richtige PCR-Tests. Und da steht das eine dem anderen nicht nach. Naja, es ist dramatisch. Ich hoffe allerdings, dass wir, wenn wir Ende März darüber reden, dass es dann schon wieder sich doch sehr entspannt hat, wenn dann Antigen-Tests plötzlich bei Lidl an der Kasse rumliegen und so.
Ich muss dich fragen, Stefan, ist Amerika back?
Oh ja, Amerika ist back. Ich habe dir geschrieben, ich will Clips zur Münchner Sicherheitskonferenz mitbringen. Du hast gesagt, oh, ich auch.
Das hatten wir noch nie, dass wir eine Überschneidung hatten.
Aber wir kommen gut aneinander vorbei. Genau, ich hatte es mir schon gedacht. Deswegen habe ich dir vorher, sonst sagen wir uns ja vorher nicht, was wir hier besprechen. Aber das wollte ich dann doch. Genau, also die Münchner Sicherheitskonferenz fand statt. Allerdings als YouTube-Show oder so, wo niemand zugeschaut hat. Ich glaube, das Video hat 1000 Views.
Es waren doch dann ein paar, also 50.000, 60.000 gab es dann doch.
Gut, denn es war hochkarätig besetzt, das muss man einfach sagen. Und bevor wir auf Joe Biden zu sprechen kommen, denn Joe Biden hat das allererste Mal als amerikanischer Präsident auf der Münchner Sicherheitskonferenz gesprochen. Wahrscheinlich, weil man nicht hinreisen musste oder so. Zuschalten geht natürlich. Und klar, er will jetzt auch die große Runde machen. Über die reden wir dann gleich. Schlagen wir doch eine kleine Brücke mit Bill Gates. Ich fand, was Bill Gates gesagt hat, war doch ziemlich, ziemlich interessant. Er schließt sozusagen da an, wo wir auch so ein bisschen aufgehört hatten, eben die paar Milliarden.
Wenn er so sagt, die paar.
Milliarden, dann schwingt er eigentlich mit so, Leute, ich könnte es selber bezahlen, ja? Könnt ihr es bitte mal gemeinsam organisieren? Das fand ich irgendwie ganz witzig. Naja, jedenfalls, welche Chance sieht ihr jetzt in Corona, ja? Und das muss man echt mal... Bill Gates denkt da einfach anders und vielleicht sollten wir uns da auch ein bisschen vorbildmäßig dranhängen, zumindest das politische Denken da mal umstellen. Denn es steht auch die eine oder andere Chance, jetzt einfach mal universale Lösungen und so weiter zu finden.
Ein Pan-Coronavirus-Universal-Vaccine, und ebenfalls ein Universale-Pflug-Vaccine, die Möglichkeit, Drogen zu machen, die eine Zerstörung blockieren, und eine Diagnostik-Aprache, die 20% der Bevölkerung pro Woche auf sehr hohe Kosten ist. Die Ziele, die an der D-Seite sind, müssen finanziert werden, und die Umgebung im Bereich der Fakten, die Überlebung, das Team von 3000. Aber diese Investitionen werden fantastische Rückgänge haben, auch wenn es keine Pandemie gibt.
Ja, ein Fünftel der Welt pro Woche auf Corona testen, wenn ein Corona-Problem ist. Und wenn es ein anderes Problem gibt, testen wir auch was anderes. Das ist einfach mal die Angehensweise. Universelle Impfung.
Denken in Schnelligkeit. Wir werden sehen, das ist eigentlich das große Thema, das die Wirtschaft erkannt hat. Die Wirtschaft hat es erkannt. Bei den Politikern, na ja, das werden wir ja mal sehen.
Ja, aber Pandemie ist echt so ein geringes Problem eigentlich, weil man eben so zuhört. Müssen nur Milliarden Menschen pro Woche testen und brauchen halt eine universelle Impfung. Ja, das würde ich sagen. Dann werden wir einfach mal durchgeimpft hier schnell. RNA wird schnell aktualisiert. Wir wissen, da wird nichts weiterer verimpft, außer diese kleine Fetthülle. Da kann man einmal testen, wie sie so wirkt. Und danach ist es egal, was in dem Umschlag drinsteckt. Das Zeug geht nach zwei Tagen im Körper. Antikörper bleiben. Mist man mal stichprobenmäßig nach, ob es geklappt hat. Und dann ist es gut. Also in der Ansicht auch, dieses AstraZeneca muss jetzt auch der Geschichte angehören. Wir haben jetzt RNA. Wir können jetzt eine Stufe weitergehen. Wir haben jetzt diesen technischen Schritt vollzogen. Ganz interessant, er kommt auf COVAX zu sprechen. Diese Initiative, dann auch die ganze Welt. Das ist ja auch noch so ein Argument, dass in Deutschland so richtig... Ach so, ja stimmt, wir müssen ja auch mal, um zum Beispiel die Mutationsgefahr einzufangen, auch mal an den Rest der Welt denken oder so.
Und um das Finanzieren zu bekommen. Und da müssen wir uns dankbar sein, dass Deutschland, die die Forderungen für den COVAX verleihen hat, die USA ein paar Monate vorgekommen sind, in einem sehr wichtigen Weg.
So, er nennt hier die G7, das fand ich ja hochinteressant, denn bisher war ja G7, G20 und so einfach immer so ein, ja da trifft man sich halt mal, das ist so der Club, wo man so miteinander spricht, das ist immer die Gelegenheit, einen Flurfunk ein bisschen zu machen. Und am Anfang dieser kleinen Runde, bevor Bill Gates sprach, hat Antonio Guterres sich zuschalten lassen aus New York, also der UN-Generalsekretär, der dann auch ein kleines Frage-Antwort-Spiel, da haben wir so die Young Leader der Münchner Sicherheitskonferenz haben so Fragen eingeschickt, die dann die Großen beantwortet haben. Und das fand ich hochinteressant. Also wir haben hier von Bill Gates schon G7. Die Impfung der Welt wird über G7 organisiert. Und Antonio Guterres wird ja mal von einer jungen Chinesin gefragt, welche Rolle die UN eigentlich zu spielen könnte in der Pandemie.
Kann die UN, z.B.
In meiner Meinung nach ist die Entity, die den besten Ort hat, die die besten Entitys, die besten Unternehmen, die besten Unternehmen, die besten Unternehmen, die besten Unternehmen, die besten Unternehmen, die besten Unternehmen.
Ja, während man in Frankreich selbst Atomkraftwerke jetzt nochmal verlängert hat, man darf sie jetzt 60 Jahre treiben statt 50. Aber naja, Bill Gates jedenfalls zum Thema Klimawandel als das eigentliche Problem im Vergleich zur Pandemie. Ja, da können wir ja schon mal damit anfangen zu sagen, This World in Data heißt sie, glaube ich, oder World O-Mita. Es gibt sehr viele Webseiten, die uns darüber aufklären, wie steht es eigentlich um die Pandemie. Vielleicht sollten wir da die Klima-Toten und die Klimaprobleme einfach auch mal so, so wie wir uns jetzt immer die Inzidenzen von Corona aufschlüsseln, dass wir uns einfach jetzt sagen...
Genau, die Hitze-Toten, die auf den Feldern in Indien, in Afrika sterben, die in Heimen sterben, keine Klimaanlagen, und dann haben wir so einen Sommer, sechs Wochen, 35 Grad.
Genau, wir hatten in Göttingen jetzt innerhalb von einer Woche einen Temperatursprung von 41, 8 Grad, deutscher Rekord. Wir haben deutsche Orte, in denen wurde es 19 Grad, womit sie ihren eigenen Rekord eingestellt hatten, während noch 23 Zentimeter Schnee lag. Alle solche Phänomene, und das ist jetzt im Februar. Wir können also sagen, es rauscht gerade eine richtige Hitzewelle über Deutschland hinweg, nur es ist noch Februar, es ist noch Winter, deswegen merken wir es nicht so richtig. Was ist eigentlich bei so einer Wetterlage im August? Wenn es hier einfach mal zwei Wochen lang dann wirklich mal 43 Grad sind, könnte man ja auch alles mal ein bisschen statistisch auffangen und dann mal Podcasts darüber machen und jeden Morgen darüber informieren. Wirklich wochenlang, das sollte schon mal mit der Zahl eröffnen lassen, wie viel Hitze, Tode und wie viel Übersterblichkeit haben wir denn eigentlich gerade. Naja, aber da gucken wir mal im Sommer, wie es sich entfaltet. Ischinger, als der große Zampano der Veranstaltung, begrüßt hier seine drei Ehrengäste.
Guten Morgen in Washington DC. Hallo nach Berlin. Und guten Tag in Paris. Herr Präsident, Herr Präsident, Frau Bundeskanzlerin, wir sind so gespannt, euch hier zusammen zu haben und euch über eine neue transatlantische Agenda zu sprechen. Und ich bin mir sicher, dass ihr bemerkt, Boris Johnson wird ein bisschen später in dieses Programm teilnehmen. Er war noch beschäftigt mit dem G7-Meeting, in dem ihr alle vorhin teilnehmt.
Ich schicke eine Video-Botschaften, da sagen die vom Team MSC, ne, keine Video-Botschaften, wir hätten sie gerne live, wir möchten ihr auch Fragen stellen, wir möchten sie in den rechten Dialog. Und nicht nur das, sondern er hat es tatsächlich hinbekommen. Ich weiß nicht wie, dass alle drei gleichzeitig da sind und sich auch wirklich die Rede des jeweils anderen anhören. Also es ist wirklich ganz erstaunlich, während sie gleichzeitig am Vormittag noch bei G7 auch so zugeschaltet zusammensaßen. Also in der Hinsicht eine ganz crazy Veranstaltung eigentlich, dafür, dass es so, ja gut, fand halt statt. Also inhaltlich ist es ja jetzt nicht so mega. Aber naja, Joe Biden jedenfalls. Und das hatte ich schon mal angesprochen hier im Podcast. Man sollte jetzt nicht nach Trump einfach sagen, ah gut, dass du zurück bist in Amerika. Wir nehmen dich hier wieder auf. Wir tun so, als wäre nichts geschehen und machen so weiter wie bisher. Und genau das ist hier passiert. Und deswegen hören wir uns das hier ein bisschen ausführlicher an. Also Joe Biden beginnt wie folgt.
Und dafür sollen wir jetzt alle sehr dankbar sein und das tun dann auch die anderen. Du hast da ja Clips zusammengesucht. Mir ist es dann nochmal in dieser geballten Form, als ich deine Clips jetzt mir kurz vorher nochmal angesehen habe, um keine Doppler zu produzieren, wirklich so klar, dass die sich ja fast vorher abgesprochen haben müssen, dass sie dieses America is back reproduzieren. Und das ist eigentlich schon fast ein Kotau vor Amerika, dass man sagt, ja, also diese vier Jahre, wir wollen gar nicht mehr drüber reden. Aber jetzt machen wir es noch, noch, noch mehr wieder zusammen als schon früher.
Genau, und bevor wir zwei inhaltliche Clips von Joe Biden hören, frühstücken wir das Thema mal ab, denn es ist wirklich dramatisch und auch peinlich, möchte ich sagen. Also Joe Biden hält seine kleine Rede auf, die kommen wir gleich nochmal zu sprechen und endet dann wie folgt. Und dann hört euch mal Wolfgang Ischinger an, wie er darauf reagiert.
Also, wir gehen zusammen und zeigen unseren großen, großen Kinder, wenn sie uns überreden, dass Demokratie, Demokratie, Demokratie funktioniert und arbeitet zusammen.
Vielen Dank, Herr Präsident, für dieses sehr wichtige Statement.
Danke, Wolfgang, dass du mir die Gelegenheit gegeben hast, in Europa den großen Kniefall zu machen. Nehmt uns einfach wieder auf. Es ist nichts passiert. Wir wollten die NATO nicht zertrümmern, wir haben das Klima nicht und so weiter. Einfach nur, wir sind wieder da und alle haben sich darüber gefreut. Und hier Ursula von der Leyen.
Wir haben es gerade gehört, die USA ist zurück.
Vielleicht vier Jahre früher oder so?
Sie strahlt richtig.
Ja, Charles Michel, ihr Counterpart aus dem EU-Rat, genau so.
Willkommen zurück in Amerika.
Man bedankt sich jetzt immer bei Amerika, das muss man sich jetzt mal vorstellen. Also man hat da sehr viel angerichtet, ja auch schon vor Trump viel angerichtet. Und jetzt sagt man die ganze Zeit, ach danke, dass ihr wieder zurück seid. Also das ist natürlich toll, wenn man erstmal alle Erwartungen runtergeschraubt hat, dann ist irgendwann schon, dass man einfach mal wieder da ist, das große Ereignis, dass man dankbar sein muss. Eher müsste man es ja andersherum formulieren. Biden müsste sich bedanken, dass Europa nach wie vor noch Interesse hat, mit den USA zu sprechen.
Ja, also in Amerika gibt es 74 Millionen Wähler, die sagen, ich weiß genau, wer Donald Trump ist und ich wollte den eigentlich weiter als Präsident haben. Und die sehen jetzt, so ist das mit den Demokraten, gefällt mir nicht. Also die nehmen jetzt auch gerade ein bisschen Anlauf vielleicht. Vielleicht sollte man diese Gefahr mal sehen irgendwie. Außerdem, was ist denn das für ein Präzedenzfall, wenn dann wirklich mal Le Pen in Frankreich gewinnt? Sagen wir dann auch, ach Scheiße, jetzt ist vier Jahre blöd und danach alles wieder wie bisher oder was? Also das ist doch wirklich Boris Johnson, der dann am Ende noch dazu kam.
Genauso.
Ja, ganz fantastisch. Dann müssen wir nicht mehr Ihr Führer der freien Welt sein. Also der hält sich das wirklich bad an. Interessanterweise war John Kerry dann noch zugeschaltet, der ja gerade so eine Rolle als Klimaminister, informeller Klimaminister, und extrem jung aussieht.
Der ist ja auch nicht mehr der Jüngste. Der ist 77, 78 und der scheint gar nicht gealtert zu sein, während Biden ja festgetackert ist, glaube ich, an dem Pult.
Vielleicht hat er viel Ketchup gegessen.
Kerry ist immer noch derselbe.
Kommt ja aus der Ketchup-Familie, wer weiß. Wir hören mal John Kerry, der selber doch dann so ein bisschen auch zeigt, dass man es auch hätte anders thematisieren können.
Um 20.30 Uhr ist die Zeit, in der wir jetzt die Welt auf der richtigen Art und Weise haben, um die Wärme zu verhindern.
Ja, traurigerweise haben wir selber drei Jahre uns ja auf den Füßen gestanden. Das hätten die anderen auch ruhig mal öffentlich sagen können. Das ist irgendwie, ich weiß auch nicht, diese Unterwürfigkeit gefällt mir gar nicht. Joe Biden hat, wie wir es eben schon im Sing-Sang gehört haben, so eine komische Präampelrede gehalten, in der er einfach noch mal die Werte hochhält und so weiter. Und wir hören uns das in drei Ausschnitten noch mal. Finde ich ehrlich gesagt einen ganz interessanten Hinweis. Wir können nicht immer erst auf Krisen warten, bis wir dann sagen, als müssen wir zusammenarbeiten. Wir können auch voll mal zusammenarbeiten. Wo ist denn eigentlich das Problem? Also in der Sicht vielleicht nicht schlecht. Jetzt allerdings kommt die große Lüge. Denn er ist in Europa zugeschaltet. Also er ist nicht mehr in Europa, er ist in Washington, er redet mit Europäern. Und ich möchte aufgrund reichhaltiger Erfahrung aus dem Wahlkampf, ich glaube, ich habe fast alles geguckt, was irgendwie relevant ist an öffentlichen Reden, Debatten oder sonst irgendwie, möchte ich hier gerne anmerken, Europa war niemals Thema bei Joe Biden in den letzten zwei Jahren. Nicht ein Wort, das Wort Europa gibt es überhaupt gar nicht bei Joe Biden. Jetzt ist er hier zugeschaltet, da ist das natürlich alles ganz anders. Bla, bla, bla, also das ist echt bla, bla, bla.
Ja, glauben wir überhaupt nicht und wir werden es noch weniger glauben, wenn wir uns im Salon wiedersehen. Wir sprechen ja über History has begun. Und ich habe angefangen zu lesen, sehr, sehr provokant, interessant. Und da sagt man, ja, es könnte da ein ganz neues Amerika aufblühen. Und das ist aber dann eines, das ich um Europa eigentlich nicht mehr sage.
Europa ist vorbei. Und Macron, ehrlicherweise, hat es kurz eingestanden.
Trauriger Auftritt, fand ich, weil Macron ja wirklich eine sehr interessante Vision für Europa hat. Wir hatten noch mal im Salon über dieses große Interview gesprochen. Und er sieht jetzt gerade, na die machen alle den Kniefall vor den USA, sagen, ach wir machen jetzt wieder diese transatlantische Partnerschaft, war doch auch immer toll, knüpfen wir einfach dran an. Und man lässt sein Konzept jetzt gänzlich im Regen stehen, was wirklich eines wäre, mit dem man sagen kann, ja wir setzen da auch noch mal selbst eine Duftmarke in der Welt und können noch mal schauen, wie wir als Europäer für unsere Werte einstehen, aber auch davon profitieren, dass alles so global geworden ist. Und das ist, glaube ich, ein Großversäumnis. Er ist ja auch der Einzige, der in dieser Rede mal anspricht, dass man schon auch mit Russland reden muss, während andere dort ja eher auf starke Konfrontation aus sind, der dann sicherlich auch strategisch denkt und sagt, na ja, wir haben den Krieg sonst vor der Haustür. Das wollen wir nicht. Also ich finde, das ist eigentlich ein sehr trauriger Auftritt. Also er muss sich natürlich auch freuen, dass das jetzt so alles stattfindet. Aber ich habe noch so zwischen den Zeilen gemerkt und so wie er das Ganze betont, na ja, ihm wäre lieber, es würde ein bisschen mehr abrücken von dieser Berliner Washington-Linie. Und er könnte da eher mit seiner Idee glänzen. Aber da ist ja überhaupt gar kein Weg für leider da.
Amerika ist jetzt eine Pacific Power, denn da gibt es halt was zu gewinnen und zu verlieren. Ja, bei Europa nicht. Bei Europa gibt es nur zu gewinnen. Und wenn man dann Europa mal hintergeht und so, dann ist halt auch egal, weil die Europäer wehren sich ja nicht gegen irgendwas. Angela Merkel hat es hier kurz aufgegriffen. Sie stimmt übrigens nicht so. Also da gab es von ihr jetzt kein Zitat im Sinne von Nordtoll, dass du zurück bist in Amerika, denn sie ist einfach richtig schnurrstrags wie so eine Referatsleiterin durchgegangen. Außenpolitik, Sicherheitskonferenz, Afrika, Dinge hier, Dinge da. Also die Dinge abgehakt, als würde man jetzt hier wirklich mal so Pläne schmieden. Und sie kann auch auf China zu sprechen.
Das zweite und vielleicht noch kompliziertere ist, dass wir eine gemeinsame Agenda gegenüber China entwickeln. China ist auf der einen Seite systemischer Wettbewerber, auf der anderen Seite brauchen wir China für die Lösung globaler Probleme, wie das Thema Artenvielfalt, wie das Thema Klimaschutz. Und China hat in den letzten Jahren eben auch an globaler Schlagkraft gewonnen. Und dem müssen wir als transatlantisches Bündnis und als Demokratien der Welt dann auch etwas an Taten entgegensetzen. Deshalb ist zum Beispiel die Frage der Impfstofflieferung jetzt nicht nur aus China und Russland an Länder, die Entwicklungsländer sind wichtig, sondern eben auch die Frage, was können wir über Covax und was können wir auch als multilaterale Gemeinschaft wie GE7 zum Beispiel einsetzen, um das Impfen für Entwicklungsländer gerade auch in Afrika voranzubringen.
China hat auch Impfstoffe und verkauft die gerade zum Selbstkostenpreis nach Afrika, während in Deutschland und in Europa noch gar nichts groß exportiert wird. Stichwort China und Münchner Sicherheitskonferenz. Fehlt da nicht irgendwas? Wolfgang Ischinger war abends noch mal im Fernsehen zugeschaltet.
Sie hat ja gerade Ihre Arbeit bei der Sicherheitskonferenz ausgezeichnet, dass sie die Türen geöffnet hat, dass vielmehr kontroverse Themen auch mit Russland, mit China und so weiter offen besprochen worden sind.
Wo waren die denn heute?
Hatten sie die gar nicht eingeladen?
In der Tat, die haben wir nicht eingeladen.
Ja, sehr schön. Nämlich, im vergangenen Jahr war es noch so, dass dort China selbstverständlich vertreten war. Und sie sprachen damals, was sie doch zu leiden haben unter Covid. Aber dass sie es jetzt schon ziemlich gut im Griff haben und dass sie sich freuen, dass die Europäer so viel Anteil daran nehmen. Und dann saßen dort die Leute noch, haben sich das so angehört. Ach ja, interessanter mit dem Virus, dann ist ja weit weg. Aber das kam ja dann drei, vier Wochen später zu uns. Und da war das sehr wichtig. Es war für Russland auch immer sehr wichtig, dort zu sein. Ja, und da kann man natürlich an dieser Einladungspolitik doch schon etwas ganz klar ablesen, was dann sich hier auch dokumentierte in den Clips.
Man konnte damals gerade noch Davos und Münchner Sicherheitskonferenz machen. Und danach war hier auch Zappenduse. Und Merkel hat jetzt auch nochmal darauf hingewiesen. Das ist ganz blöd. Für alles, was wir nicht mehr veranstalten, veranstalten die Chinesen plötzlich was. Also wenn irgendwer einen Kredit braucht, wenn irgendwer eine Sicherheitskonferenz braucht, wenn irgendwer ein Impfprogramm braucht für die Welt und so. Wenn wir das in Europa und Amerika nicht machen, machen es plötzlich die Chinesen. Und da müssen wir doch mal sehr aufpassen. Joe Biden hat dann in seiner Rede nochmal betont, warum es eigentlich ging, jetzt bei dieser Münchner Sicherheitskonferenz. Ja, es ist die große Wiedereinfädelungsmasche, die hier läuft. Und Merkel entsprechend, das ist so ein kleiner Spruch, den sie so gemacht hat.
In Deutschland gibt es ein Sprichwort, es gibt nichts Gutes, außer man tut es.
Also reden wir mal darüber, was wir hier gerade tun, nämlich, naja, Boris Johnson, letzter Clip aus der Reihe von meiner Seite, war der Einzige und das ist bei Bill Gates, ist mir richtig aufgefallen. Man muss Merkels Mantra, wir müssen stärker aus der Krise raus, als wir in die Krise rein und so weiter. Das muss man doch jetzt bei so Sachen wie der Pandemie wirklich mal ernsthaft. Und da ist Boris Johnson ja eh gerade einen Höhenflug hat, weil nachdem er es komplett versaut hat, zumindest das Impfen, da es ziemlich gut läuft in Großbritannien, diesen kleinen Spruch nochmal gemacht hat.
Ja, sehr beachtlich, dass er das sagt. Er versteht vielleicht doch, was es bedeutet, einen Ausnahmezustand zu erleben. Und ich will einen Rahmen setzen. Wir steigen ein mit Karl Schmidt. Wir werden enden mit Lavoj Zizek. Und dazwischen, dazwischen aber, kommt jetzt die Münchner Sicherheitskonferenz. Und wir hören aber dann andere, wie man so sagt, Decision Maker. Wir sagen in Deutschland ja gerne Entscheidungsträger. Und bei den Deutschen hat man auch den Eindruck, die tragen die Entscheidung vor allem vor sich her. Aber dass Entscheidungen machen, die Dezision, die ist doch etwas sehr Wichtiges. Und das sagt Karl Schmidt in seiner Politischen Theologie. Da geht es um den Ausnahmezustand. Ich habe da mal zwei Parts eingelesen. Souverän ist, wer über den Ausnahmezustand entscheidet. Diese Definition kann dem Begriff der Souveränität als einem Grenzbegriff allein gerecht werden. Denn Grenzbegriff bedeutet nicht einen konfusen Begriff, wie in der unsaubern Terminologie populärer Literatur, sondern einen Begriff der äußersten Sphäre. Dem entspricht es, dass seine Definition nicht anknüpfen kann an den Normalfall, sondern an einen Grenzfall. Denn jede Ordnung beruht auf einer Entscheidung. Und auch der Begriff der Rechtsordnung, der gedankenlos als etwas Selbstverständliches angewandt wird, enthält den Gegensatz der zwei verschiedenen Elemente des Juristischen in sich. Auch die Rechtsordnung, wie jede Ordnung, beruht auf einer Entscheidung, nicht auf einer Norm. Ob nur Gott souverän ist, das heißt derjenige, der in der irrtischen Wirklichkeit widerspruchlos als sein Vertreter handelt, oder der Kaiser, oder der Landesheer, oder das Volk, immer ist die Frage auf das Subjekt der Souveränität gerichtet, das heißt die Anwendung des Begriffs auf einen konkreten Tatbestand. Wer ist denn jetzt gerade der Souverän in der Krise? Wir haben eben schon in Bezug auf die Schnelltests, auf die Impfung gesagt, naja, die Wirtschaft, die hat ja sehr schnell geliefert, die reagiert, sie wird eigentlich von der Politik ausgebremst. Und im Karl-Schmidt-Verständnis von Politik und vom Politischen meint das selbstverständlich, dass die Politik das eigentlich machen muss. Und die Frage ist doch, wo macht sie das gerade nicht oder wo erkennt sie nicht, wie im Ausnahmezustand über den Ausnahmezustand zu entscheiden ist. Man hat ein bisschen diesen Modus, wenn man sagt Lockdown, das ist ein Agieren im Ausnahmezustand und den Ausnahmezustand auch herstellen, zu sagen, wir verkürzen jetzt Prozesse, wir binden jetzt da das Parlament nicht mit ein. Aber die Frage ist, ob das so klug alles umgesetzt wurde und ob es weit genug gegangen ist und ob man wirklich sich als souverän erweist. Und wir hören noch mal weiter, warum für Karl Schmidt dieser Ausnahmezustand so entscheidend ist. Denn man könnte ja sagen, Na ja, Ausnahmen gibt es immer. Jetzt lass uns doch mal über die Normalfälle sprechen, über die Regel. Das ist ja auch das, in dem sich Politiker wohlfühlen. Ja, das ist irgendetwas zwischen kleine Parlamentsanhörungen. Dann hat man noch ein Weinfest zu besuchen. Und dann zappelt man sich noch ein bisschen vielleicht in der Talkshow. Aber was ist denn eigentlich dann wirklich das Entscheidende? Die Ausnahme ist das nicht subsumierbare. Sie entzieht sich der generellen Fassung. Aber gleichzeitig offenbart sie ein spezifisch juristisches Formelement. Die Dezision in absoluter Reinheit. Es gibt keine Norm, die auf ein Chaos anwendbar wäre. Die Ordnung muss hergestellt sein, damit die Rechtsordnung einen Sinn hat. Es muss eine normale Situation geschaffen werden. Und souverän ist derjenige, der definitiv darüber entscheidet, ob dieser normale Zustand wirklich herrscht. Alles Recht ist Situationsrecht. Das Normale beweist nichts. Die Ausnahme beweist alles. Sie bestätigt nicht nur die Regel. Die Regel lebt überhaupt nur von der Ausnahme. In der Ausnahme durchbricht die Kraft des wirklichen Lebens die Kruste einer in Wiederholung erstaaten Mechanik.
So, darf ich hier mal eine kleine Paranthese versuchen?
Sehr gern.
Thomas de Maizière, du kennst ihn als Juristen und als ehemaligen Innenminister. Wurde von Markus Lanz gefragt, macht Krise eigentlich Spaß? Und er hat Folgendes gesagt.
Okay, eine allerletzte Frage habe ich an Sie, Herr de Maizière. Macht Krise eigentlich Spaß, um das Wort mal zu benutzen?
Spaß nicht, aber Freude schon. In der Krise zeigt sich, wer was kann. Die Krise sucht sich die Mächtigen, nicht die Zuständigkeiten. Und die Krise stärkt die Seriösen und nicht die Lauten. Und in der Krise ist eben Schluss mit Firlefanz und Inszenierung. Da kommt es auf die Substanz an. Und wer das gerne macht, dem macht doch Krise Freude. Auch wenn es natürlich unangenehm ist und hart ist, und es um Leben und Tod geht und um Insolvenzen und all das, will ich nicht in Abrede stellen. Aber das Agieren selbst in der Krise macht denen, die Verantwortung tragen, Freude. Und sie sollten das auch zeigen.
Ja, das ist eins zu eins Karl Schmidt. Dichter kann man gar nicht dran sein an der Geschichte. Das ist wirklich auf den Punkt gebracht. Und man sieht ja gerade jetzt beim Gesundheitsminister, wie viel Inszenierung dabei war. Und dass einem das dann genau auf die Füße fällt. Und wenn diese Wirklichkeit die Kruste der Wiederholung durchbricht, also nicht, dass man noch sagen kann, naja, da müssen wir aber erst mal prüfen. Und dann müssen wir noch mal schauen. Und in drei Wochen können wir vielleicht die Schnelltests zulassen, wenn das ist dann die Realität, die es durchbricht, die sagt, hier gehen die Fallzahlen nach oben, jetzt muss gehandelt werden. Und das zeig ich sehr schön. Wie sieht das jetzt ein Bill Gates? Da könnte man sagen, das ist doch jetzt alles, was die Wirtschaft allein kann. Und da äußert er sich auch auf der Sicherheitskonferenz zu. Sagt er nochmal deutlich hier, ihr müsst eigentlich auch ein bisschen was da tun. Ist es auch eine Aufforderung? Also mir schien das sowieso ein bisschen so, dass hier einer aus der Wirtschaft kommt und sagt hier, ihr müsst auch mal Politiker sein. Das erlebt man ja jetzt immer häufiger.
Also die Virologen in Deutschland haben ja ganz früh Drossen, Kikuli und so weiter. Da müssen die Politiker jetzt mal entscheiden. Wir können die immer nur informieren, aber die müssen doch mal entscheiden. Und der Georg Maskelo saß ja auch nochmal bei Anne Will und hat gesagt, also die WHO hat ganz früh gesagt, die Unternehmen können das mit dieser Forschung ganz wunderbar machen, aber Produktion muss staatlich organisiert werden. Die Unternehmen werden niemals in eine Vorleistung von Billionen oder so was gehen, um dann irgendwie zu sagen, wir impfen jetzt die ganze Welt. Sondern die werden euch einfach nur sagen, wir haben halt eine Impfung. Und ihr müsst das vorbereiten, so dass auch die ganze Welt geimpft werden kann. Es geht hier darum, sieben, acht Milliarden Menschen zu impfen. Und das kann nur der Staat organisieren. Da hat man verpennt.
Ja, und wie sehr man verpennt hat, das betont hier nochmal der UN-Generalsekretär Antonio Guterres, der war ja auch eingeladen und der war aber auch schon vor einem Jahr dort in München.
Mehr als ein Jahr zurück war Europa multipolar, aber es gab keine multilaterale Regierungsmechanismen, und das Ergebnis war die erste Weltkrieg. Jetzt ist es Zeit für Solidarität und internationale Kooperation, um unsere größten und komplexen Herausforderungen zu beherrschen.
Vielleicht deswegen sein Verweis auf G7 und G20 und so.
Ja, wahrscheinlich. Er war übrigens nicht im letzten Jahr da. Das war Ted Ross von der WHO, aber Guterres macht da, glaube ich, auch einen sehr, sehr guten Punkt, insofern als einfach nur Verflechtungen auch nicht weiterhelfen. Das kann dann auch sehr schnell wieder neue Konflikte produzieren. Er verweist da auf den ersten Weltkrieg. Aber hören wir uns doch noch an, was Ted Ross sagt von der WHO. Der war nämlich vor einem Jahr dort und hatte über Corona gesprochen. Da wurde er nicht so ganz ernst genommen.
Wenn ich vor einem Jahr an der Münchner Sicherheitskonferenz gesprochen habe, habe ich gesagt, dass Covid-19 gefährlich ist. Sehr gefährlich und das Publikum ist Nummer eins. Und ich erinnere mich an das Zeitpunkt, die Leute waren ein bisschen eigentlich beschäftigt und Sam folgte mich und sagte, Tedros, wenn du sagst, dass es sehr gefährlich ist und das Publikum ist Nummer eins, sagten sie, dass du es nicht zuvielst? Leider haben wir in den letzten Jahren alle ein paar schmerzvolle Lehren gelernt.
Aber ist doch interessant, angenommen, man hätte ihn ernst genommen, dann hätte man heute gesagt, der ist damals übertrieben.
Ja, genau.
Das ist wieder dieses Präventionsparadox.
Und das ist das Präventionsparadox und ist sicherlich auch ein ganz großes Problem generell für Demokratien. Wir haben ja ein System, das eigentlich politische Erfolge immer nach Sichtbarkeit bemisst. Das heißt, wenn jetzt ganz viele Impfungen kommen, und das könnten wir jetzt Angela Merkel zuschreiben oder der CDU, dann gewinnt die CDU eine Wahl. Aber wenn sie verhindert, dass überhaupt eine Infektion entsteht, dann gewinnt sie damit eigentlich keine Wahl. Das ist so wie beim Hochwasserschutz. Also wenn man Ministerpräsident ist, wir hatten jetzt ein bisschen Hochwasser am Rhein, und man ist als Ministerpräsident da, zieht sich die Gummistiefel an, schleppt noch ein paar Sandsäcke und sagt, wir versprechen allen zu helfen, deren Keller jetzt unter Wasser steht, dann gewinnt man eine Wahl. Wenn man vor drei Jahren dafür gesorgt hat, dass es Hochwasseraufhangbecken gibt, dann kommt nach drei Jahren Hochwasser und dann sagen alle, oh, ist ja gar nicht so hoch geworden. Und das ist aber nicht etwas, was dann der Ministerpräsident für sich verbuchen kann.
Ich meine, wenn die CDU Corona ordentlich beseitigt hätte, wäre das Top-One-Wahlkampf-Thema Klima gewesen. Und das wäre nicht gut für die CDU.
Nein.
Um es mal ganz spekulativ zu sagen.
Keineswegs. Wir haben jetzt schon über Entscheidungen bei Karl Schmidt etwas gehört. Und Joe Biden sieht hier auch eine historische Entscheidung weltweit.
We are in the midst of a fundamental debate about the future and direction of our world. We're at an inflection point between those who argue that given all the challenges we face from the fourth Industrial Revolution to a global pandemic, that autocracy is the best way forward, they argue. And those who understand that democracy is essential, essential to meeting these challenges. Historians are going to examine and write about this moment as an inflection point, as I said.
Ja, er ist ja ganz historisch, ne? Er macht ja auch so eine spontane Historisierung und sieht sich gleich so in so Jahrhunderten eingebettet. Das war ja in seiner Antrittsrede auch, da hat er auch den ganzen Bogen gespannt von der Gründung Amerikas bis jetzt und so. Der in sich vielleicht nicht schlecht, so einen super alten Präsidenten zu haben, der weiß, ich muss ja nicht mehr meine Biografie gestalten, sondern nur noch das Geschichtsbuch schreiben, der dann so ein bisschen anders an die Sachen rangeht.
Ja, du hattest das eben schon angesprochen mit Merkel, die sagte, na ja, da, wo Deutschland, wo die EU, wo der Westen zu lahm ist, da springt sofort China ein und kann was tun und jetzt sieht von der Leyen aber eine Chance, dass wir der globale Regulator sind.
Und wir sind übrigens der Nummer eins globalen Regulatoren. Just recently we have proposed to set up indeed an EU, US Trade and Technology Council, because we know that those who write global rules are the ones who are shaping the future of their societies. And you heard the president, none of us wants China to do this for us.
Ja, das ist so ein ganz wichtiger Punkt, glaube ich. Bisher haben wir ja dieses ganze Digitalisierungsteuisch so durchlaufen lassen. Die Politik hat sich, wenn, also fünf Jahre zu spät dafür interessiert. Und man sieht an China, wie krass man da eigentlich eingreifen kann politisch und mitgestalten kann und welche politischen Vorteile das für das eigene Land dann bringt, zum Nachteile vieler persönlichen Freiheiten und so weiter. Gar keine Frage. Aber ich glaube, sie brauchen tatsächlich vorbildhaft jemanden, der ihnen mal zeigt, wie die Handlungsmöglichkeiten so sind. Wir kommen noch her, auf Facebook gegen Australien zu sprechen, wo ja auch der Westen mal so wieder aufatmet und sozusagen zurückfindet an das Steuerpult, Wasserhahn auf, Wasserhahn zu und so weiter. In deren Sicht hat sie diese Lehrstelle da ganz gut mal zumindest begriffen. Also begriffen im Sinne von umgriffen in ihrer Rede.
Wenn gleich ihr ein winziger Fauxpas passiert, sie sagt, ihr habt gehört, was der Präsident gesagt hat und vorher hat auch schon Macron gesprochen, aber der Präsident kann natürlich immer nur der US-Präsident sein. Das ist sehr, sehr schön, aber sehr verräterisch.
Das bestätigt noch mal alles.
Ja, ja, das ist wie, wenn man sagt, die Königin. Na ja, es gibt noch eine andere außer die Elisabeth. Wir hören ganz kurz Jens Stoltenberg noch zu China.
Die Reise von China ist ein definierter Anreiz für die transatlantische Gemeinschaft.
Das ist warum NATO unsere Beziehungen mit nahe Partnern wie Australien und Japan und neue Waffen um die Welt verbreiten.
Er wird auch schon pazifisiert. Und damit ist der Pazifik gemeint und nicht der Pazifismus.
Genau, ganz genau. Das könnte eher ganz neue Scharmütze bedeuten. Und das ist sehr interessant, wenn man hört, wie oft jetzt Politiker auch hier in Deutschland von Australien und Japan reden. Da hat man vorher nie gehört. Also das war irgendwo da sonst wo. Aber das hat nicht interessiert geopolitisch, kommt aber immer häufiger jetzt vor. Und Merkel macht jetzt auch einen Knicks vor Joe Biden und spricht über das 2%-Ziel.
Und wir müssen auch da handeln, wo man sich anstrengen muss.
Was für ein verräterischer Halbsatz. Wir müssen auch da handeln, wo man sich anstrengen muss.
Das heißt manchmal auch über den eigenen Schatten springen. Und ich glaube, da sind wir auch in den letzten Jahren einige gute Schritte vorangekommen. 2014 in Wales, als wir über das 2% für die Verteidigungsausgaben gesprochen haben, da haben wir uns ja verpflichtet, in diese Richtung zu arbeiten. Und ich kann heute sagen, dass wir in diesem Jahr jetzt bei 1, 5% angekommen sind, nachdem wir 2040 1, 1% Verteidigungsausgaben hatten. Und wir fühlen uns natürlich diesem 2%-Ziel weiter verpflichtet und werden auch weiter daran arbeiten.
Ja, Bruce Johnson hat ja freudig verkündet, wir liegen weit über dem Ziel, wir sind die besten Freunde Amerikas.
Also die Aufrüstung des Westens ist im vollen Gange. Und Deutschland wird da auch sein Schärflein zu beitragen. Wir überspringen jetzt mal die beiden Merkel-Abschnitte und gehen jetzt mit einem großen Schritt raus aus München. Denn wir haben jetzt hier Entscheidungsträger gehört, die Politiker sind, bis auf Bill Gates. Bill Gates sagt ja, aber ihr müsst auch Politiker sein. Und dann gibt es aber auch noch Entscheidungsträger, Decision-Maker in der Wirtschaft. Und wenn man sich einmal dieser Macht ein bisschen bewusst wird, dann wird einem ganz anders. Und man fragt sich, ist das nicht auch so ein bisschen so eine Seniorenveranstaltung, der wir jetzt da bei der Münchner Sicherheitskonferenz beigewohnt haben, da geht alles noch gemächtig zu. Und ja, man möchte sich auch anstrengen. Oder wie war das jetzt gerade? Man will auch die Dinge tun, die anstrengend sind. Ja, da wollen wir mal schauen, ob wir uns das noch gönnen oder ob wir morgen erst den Spaziergang machen. Das geht vielleicht alles ein bisschen schneller, wenn man sich zum Beispiel den norwegischen Staatsfonds ansieht. Das ist der größte Staatsfonds der Welt. Der wird geleitet von Nicolai Tangen. Er ist 54 Jahre alt und war vorher sehr erfolgreicher Hedgefondsmanager. Sein Hedgefonds war 18 Milliarden Euro schwer. Den hat er dann abstoßen müssen, um jetzt diese Posten anzunehmen. Und jetzt verwaltet er über 1.000 Milliarden Euro. Und dieser staatliche Pensionsfonds hat gut Gewinn gemacht. Es ging 10, 9 Prozent nach oben während 2020. Wir wissen ja, die Märkte boomten. Und die Norweger sind großaktionär durch diesen Pensionsfonds bei 9.200 Aktienunternehmen. 9.200. Und dieser Staatsfonds hält im Schnitt 1, 5 Prozent der Aktien von allen Großunternehmen weltweit. Und dann noch ein bisschen mehr, wenn man es nur auf Europa ausrichtet. Das heißt, die haben auch eine große Möglichkeit, die Kurse zu verschieben. Also wenn die jetzt sagen, BASF oder VW, das gefällt uns nicht, wir steigen jetzt sofort heraus, dann passiert da was. Das hat einen Effekt. Das ist also etwas, was man nicht unterschätzen darf. Die haben auch eine Pressekonferenz gegeben und blicken auf das Jahr zurück. Und diese Pressekonferenz, da hören wir jetzt mal rein, was Nikolai Tangen dort zu berichten hat. Denn es war ja ein gutes Jahr.
Wenn du den besten Wettbewerb herstellt, welches der Technologiesektor war, hat es einen guten Anfang zum Jahr, es ist weniger verletzt als der Markt und dann hat es eine sehr starke Recoverie.
Natürlich wird es durch die erhöhte Arbeit von Heim, erhöhte Gaming und den ganzen Technologie-Leap, den ganzen Gesellschaften während dieser Zeit erzeugt.
Ja, das sind wirklich diese Profiteure da immer, weil jetzt gerade Gaming ansprach. Ich finde ja, Gaming ist in diesem Maße nichts Gutes. Sondern das zeigt einfach nur, wir haben ein großes Problem. Die Leute haben langeweilig nichts zu tun, die verschönten ihre Zeit. Also boomt Gaming und davon profitiert man dann. Bei diesem norwegischen Staatsfonds, die haben ja auch irgendwann mal entschieden, wir machen nichts mehr mit Kohle und Öl und so weiter. Während sie gleichzeitig natürlich nur vom Ölverkauf des Norwegischen da ihre ersten Gelder bekamen. Also in der Ansicht, das ist auch so ein bisschen verlogen, denn die Norweger fördern Öl, als gäbe es keinen Morgen, um diesen Staatsfonds aufzupumpen. Und dann aber, wir machen ja ganz klimaneutrale Investments.
Warum machen sie das? Weil sich das lohnt. Und er äußert sich hier zur grünen Wirtschaft.
Wie du gesehen hast, waren auch große Entwicklungen in den grünen Stöcken. Wir haben grüne Unternehmen in vielen anderen Sektoren. Aber wir haben einige Indizien, wie der FUZI, das Umweltwahrheitsverfahrensindex, der zwischen 40 und 50% erhöht ist. Wir haben große Expositen in den grünen Sektoren. Am Ende des Jahres haben wir ungefähr 100 Billionen Kronen investiert.
40 bis 50 Prozent Rendite oder was? Im Jahresvergleich. Über diesen grünen FDSI, das ist doch der Englische, ne?
Ich glaube schon.
Krass.
Siehste, das lohnt sich. Dieses grüne Zeug lohnt sich. Die EU geht da die richtigen Wege.
Ja, ja und das muss man ganz klar erkennen, wie ausschlaggebend hier so ein Entscheider ist. Also Nikolaj Tangen, der wird dann rekrutiert. Da sagt man, der hat einen Hedgefonds geleitet. Das ist richtig gut, wie der das gemacht hat. Der ist jetzt hier der Decision Maker. Der ist nicht gewählt. Der hat auch nicht einen Wahlkampf, sondern der muss sehen, dass sein Fonds überperformt, also dass er ein bisschen besser als der Durchschnitt ist. Das ist er auch im vergangenen Jahr gewesen. Und das sind die ganz großen Entscheidungen, die nur Investitionsentscheidungen sind, die aber politisch extrem viel verändern. Und auch Tangen blickt nach China.
China war auch ein Standout. Wiederum keine einzigen Indexmessungen, das in einem einfachen Weg. Aber es war zwischen 30 und 40 Prozent, je nachdem, wie du es measuren kannst.
Auch nicht ganz schlecht. Und jetzt macht er noch mal einen Ländervergleich. Wo hat man denn gut abgeschnitten? Und da ist interessant, dass Großbritannien nicht gut wegkommt. Das hängt wohl mit dem Brexit zusammen, anders kann man das nicht erklären, sonst müsste es für Großbritannien mit der City of London eigentlich auch gut laufen, ist aber nicht. China ist ja die einzige große Volkswirtschaft, die gewachsen ist und das haben auch sehr positiv deutsche Unternehmen zu spielen bekommen. Infineon ist gewachsen 25 Prozent gegenüber dem Vorjahr, Daimler, BASF, Adidas, VW profitieren alle extrem von China. Volkswagen verkauft jetzt inzwischen 41 Prozent der Fahrzeuge nach China. Also da müsste man auch mal darüber nachdenken, wenn hier so über Regeln, Regularien für die Autoindustrie gesprochen wird, dann sagen wir mal, uwe, werden die dann noch im nächsten Jahr produzieren können. Da sind wir ja längst nicht mehr die, die den Ton angeben. Die sagen, ja, wenn hier noch ein paar Leute mit Verbrennern länger rumfahren wollen, dann bitteschön, aber das irritiert uns gar nicht, unser Markt ist woanders. Und ich dachte, wir blicken doch mal auf einen anderen Decision-Maker noch, auf jemand, der für Deutschland sehr wichtig ist, selbst kein Deutscher ist, sondern ein Schwede ist, Ola Kelenius, das ist der Nachfolger von Dieter Setsche bei Daimler. Und Daimler macht in diesem Jahr was hochinteressantes, die trennen sich nämlich, die sagen, wir brauchen zwei Aktien, wir brauchen zwei Geschäfte. Wir haben auf der einen Seite die teuren Limousinen, die SUVs, diese hochpreisigen Superklassewagen, die müssen wir als Aktie haben. Und dann müssen wir auf der anderen Seite bündeln unsere Nutzfahrzeuge, LKW und Co. Und damit können wir dann uns erstmal umbenennen, Mercedes-Benz AG soll das, glaube ich, dann alles heißen. Und dann können wir mit diesen beiden Aktien ganz anders nochmal performen, als wir das jetzt gerade tun. Man muss sagen, Daimler hat sehr gut im vergangenen Jahr performt, aber wenn man sich mal die Marktkapitalisierung ansieht, Daimlers Marktkapitalisierung liegt bei 71 Milliarden Euro. Verglichen mit Tesla jetzt, Tesla 640 Milliarden Euro. Und dann denken die bei Daimler, was ist denn das da eigentlich? Wie können wir dann vielleicht auch da mal hinkommen? Jetzt haben wir 2020 einen Daimler-Zuwachs gehabt von 3, 50 Prozent. Das muss man sich vorstellen, 3, 50 Prozent, das ist richtig viel. Und der Z-Shirt dümpelt ja die Aktie sowieso da rum. Der hat halt Autos verkauft, kann man sagen. Aber das war jetzt nicht mehr der große Innovator. Bei Ola Kelenius ist das alles vollkommen anders. Und der sagt jetzt auch, was denn eigentlich Entscheidung bedeutet und wie man heute zu entscheiden hat.
Das ist eine Zeit, in der Agilität, Geschwindigkeit und Entscheidungsmöglichkeit noch mehr wichtig sind als in der Vergangenheit.
Das hat er sich von Elon Musk abgeguckt. Die Rakete muss im Mai fliegen, egal aus welchem Material wir sie bauen. Wir brauchen das Material, damit sie im Mai fliegt.
Und man wünschte sich bei Schnelltests, wäre das auch so gegangen, dass man da sagt, jetzt dynamisch agil sein. Und er findet auch, man kann eine ganz tolle Lehre aus dieser Krise ziehen.
Und es geht um Agilität und Flexibilität, die Geschwindigkeit des Entscheidens, was in dem Jahr 2020 erläutert wurde.
Also, ob man das schafft, ist immer eine schwierige Frage mit deutschen Unternehmen. Denn es gibt eine unglaubliche Trägheit in diesen deutschen Ingenieursberufen. Und zwar, und das ist vielleicht so ein Argument, das muss man sich auch mal über langfristig, also das muss man sich einfach mal bewusst werden, glaube ich auch, über die Organisiertheit, über den Organisationsgrad, über Gewerkschaftsarbeit und so weiter. Man ist doch in so einem Trott drin, man hat so seine Vertrauensleute, kommt ein Manager, will irgendwas anders machen, und dann hat man den Widerstand eigentlich zu schnell organisiert. Irgendwie so, ich glaube, da ist auch so eine gewisse Trägheit einfach einprogrammiert. Wir sehen das auch an trägen Denken, dass es in diesen Belegschaften, gerade in Baden-Württemberg, wo diese Ingenieure die Autos da bauen, dass es doch da auch so ein sehr rechtslastiges Denken gibt, und man sich so zusammen rottet und irgendwie auf der einen Seite hat man so eine träge Ingenieursbelegschaften, auf der anderen Seite so diesen Managerwunsch, komm jetzt machen wir es mal schnell, jetzt machen wir Konzernsprache Englisch, jetzt gehen wir mal auf den chinesischen Markt und so. Und das muss man erst mal, also so ein Tanker da mit zu reißen, ist glaube ich eine ganz schön große Herausforderung für diese neuen Chefs, die da da sind.
Zumal hinzugefügt werden muss, die Ingenieure werden nicht davon profitieren. Es geht hier darum, Aktionäre vorzumachen, deswegen macht man diese Aufteilung. Daimler wird weiter Lohnkosten senken wollen, das heißt andere Verträge, das heißt aber auch Entlassungen. Und es geht hier überhaupt nicht darum, dass man große Arbeitsplätze oder so was schützen will, sondern man will einfach sehen, wie kann man eine tolle Börsen-Performance hinlegen. Dafür ist Kellenius da. Deswegen ist es auch verständlich, dass man versucht, dort Widerstand zu leisten, sicherlich auch an falschen Stellen. Aber wenn man sich so anhört, worum es bei dieser Neuaufteilung des Konzerns geht, dann hat das nicht in irgendeiner Weise etwas damit zu tun, dass man die Bedingungen verbessern will für die Leute, die dort arbeiten.
Das Ziel hat Japan vorgegeben, Toyota baut genauso viele Autos wie VW, ungefähr so 10 Millionen im Jahr. Allerdings nicht mit 600.000 Mitarbeitern, sondern mit 300.000. Also da ist viel Spielraum.
Genau, wir hören mal, was er sagt zur Neuaufteilung des Konzerns.
Ja, man kann es nicht oft genug sagen, das ist diese deutsche Schlüsseltechnologie, um die sich die ganze Politik gestaltet eigentlich. Das sollte immer beschützt werden und zwar auch immer so ein bisschen auf Masse kommen, wir kaufen jetzt, was weiß ich, da in Amerika irgendwelche Chrysler und so was, die großen weltweiten Player und schützen VW und jetzt sehen sie, dass sie überall auf dem Abstellkreis und jetzt ist Tesla da ein Grünheide, noch näher dran an Berlin als Wolfsburg, was für viele Ingenieure bedeutet, ihr könnt jetzt in Berlin leben und trotzdem beim Auto arbeiten und ihr müsst nicht eine Stunde bis nach Wolfsburg pendeln und so, das sind alles so kleine Standort-Vorteile, die echt schmerzen da.
Was Kellenius auch wichtig ist, dass er ganz auf CO2-Neutralität setzt, denn da weiß er natürlich auch mit Blick auf Tesla, nur dort liegt die Zukunft, also wenn er da so super performen will.
Ich habe die CO2-neutrale Zukunft erwähnt. Das ist eine strategische Entscheidung für diese Firma. Und der erste echte Test und Probepunkt war, ob wir von dem Niveau, an dem wir 2019 waren, in Europa die sehr strengen Ziele treffen können. Aufgrund unserer internen Bewertung, mit der Sales-Footprint, die wir 2020 hatten, war unser Ziel im NEDC-Zykel 106, 6 Gramm. Und wir kamen, nach unserer Bewertung, an 104, 3 Gramm. Wir hatten sogar ein paar Margen. Und viel dieser Momentum kam in der zweiten Hälfte des Jahres.
Bill Gates hat dieses Buch jetzt über Klima geschrieben. Er sitzt bei Trevor Noah und die Reden so eine Viertelstunde miteinander. Und Bill Gates sagt so, naja, dass mit diesem Klima, John Kerry ja auch, Ursula von der Leyen, die sagen einfach Finance. Wir brauchen halt Green Finance, dann ist die Motivation da, die Anreizsysteme sind dann da und dann geht das schon in die richtige Richtung. Man muss halt nur die Känze von setzen. Und Bill Gates sagt so in diesem Gespräch, ja das eigentlich richtige Problem ist Zement und Stahl. Das sind die beiden großen CO2-Treiber. Und wenn wir die grün gemacht haben, ist es immer noch nur Zement und Stahl. Also das Produkt gewinnt keine Attraktivität, indem man es zehnmal teuer macht und sagt, wir machen jetzt den Hochofen nicht mehr mit Kohle, sondern wir machen es mit Wasserstoff, den wir erst durch Hydrolyse und so weiter in der Nordsee im Wind erzeugen. Das ist dann zehnmal so teuer, aber es ist trotzdem immer noch langweilige Stahl. Und das ist schwierig, den Leuten das zu verkaufen. Warum kostet Stahl zehnmal mehr? Und deswegen ja diese ganzen Exportschranken, Zölle und so weiter, was Ursula von der Leyen hat. Und für Bill Gates ist der Autosektor einer, wo er sagt, da muss man gar nichts machen. Ein Elektroauto ist im Vergleich zu einem Verbrennerauto so viel attraktiver für den Kunden, dass der Schiff von ganz alleine passiert. Leute steigen in den Tesla, machen den Ludacris-Mode an, beschleunigen so krass, dass ihnen der Hals danach wehtut und die sagen, das ist die Zukunft. Und da muss man niemanden erst noch kognitiv überzeugen, anders als bei Zement und Stahl, wenn man das verkaufen will. Und eigentlich ist das so krass, dass die deutsche Autoindustrie das so verpasst hat, wo Bill Gates schon sagt, also der Strukturwandel, den müssen wir nicht steuern. Einfach nur den Kunden zeigen, was ein Elektroauto ist, zack, funktioniert das von alleine. Und trotzdem haben die sich so dagegen gewehrt und sind jetzt so entzündet. Also es ist wirklich auch eine ganz erstaunliche deutsche Glanzleistung, die wir hier wieder mal dokumentieren.
Ja, sehr irritierend. Ich hatte es, glaube ich, auch schon mal angesprochen, dass jetzt ja so ein neues Beschäftigen mit Dingen stattfindet, womit man sich eigentlich gar nicht mehr beschäftigt hat. Die Autos, also die Verbrenner, sind ja so gut, dass man nie mehr über PS reden musste in na ja, ich müsste mal irgendwie noch ein bisschen schneller mit so einem Auto können, sondern diese ganzen tollen Top Autos wurden ja alle gedrosselt, weil sie viel mehr Motorleistung hatten, als man sie überhaupt irgendwo als normaler Mensch fahren kann. Da muss man dann wirklich schon ein Viertel oder so sein, um das wirklich ausfahren zu können, also sind die gedrosselt. Und da sind irgendwelche Familienkutschen dann mit 500 PS ausgestattet und die sind in drei Sekunden von 0 auf 100. All das ist ja etwas, was man überhaupt nicht mehr braucht. Jetzt fängt aber beim Verbrenner wieder diese alte Sache an, die ich so von meinem Vater noch kenne, wenn der erzählt, aus dem Ende der 70er, Anfang der 80er Jahre habe ich dann das und das Auto gehabt und der konnte so schnell und da war ich schneller als meine Freunde oder so was. Solche Geschichten kommen jetzt wieder, also wie lange hält so ein Auto, also wie weit kommt man damit? Kann das über 700 Kilometer schaffen? Was muss dafür getan werden? Das heißt, diese Debatte, die kann jetzt wieder neu aufgeholt werden und es ist so eine neue Technik-Faszination dafür da. Sicherlich ist momentan jeder Verbrenner noch dem E-Auto überlegen, aber das wird sich sehr schnell wandeln und Daimler hat jetzt auch angekündigt, eigentlich war das mal für 2039 geplant, ich nehme an, das war noch so eine Zetsche-Vorstellung, dann wird es keine Verbrenner mehr geben, dann produzieren wir nicht mehr. Kelenius will das jetzt fünf oder sogar acht Jahre früher machen und es ist auch angekündigt, dass 2028 die S-Klasse, also das Daimler-Auto schlechthin, die S-Klasse soll ab 2028 nur noch als E-Auto angeboten werden. Das geht sehr, sehr schnell. Und jetzt gucken wir mal, was China damit auch noch zu tun hat.
China hat eine wunderbare Reingabe. Ich meine, das ist, was ich nenne, eine echte V-formale Reingabe. Und wir haben in China in 2020 ein Rekord gesetzt, mit mehr als 770.000 Fahrzeugen.
Ja, dauert alles ein bisschen länger hier, bis das nicht V, das langsame U, wahrscheinlich dann zurückkommt. Also in China, ich hab das jetzt mal die Woche so geteilt, da kam natürlich gleich wieder so Widerspruch, pipa po, aber wir wissen alle wohin die Richtung geht. China wird das erste Mal ein, also wir haben schon über Shenzhen gesprochen, dass dort alle Taxis auf E-Mobilität umgerüstet worden. Da gibt es diesen einen Hersteller, so groß wie Tesla, rüstet das ganze Land aus. Und China wird jetzt, wie auch bei den Zügen, wurde ja auch nie exportiert. China wird jetzt erstmals ein Luxus-Limousin-Segment exportieren. Das Ding heißt NIO ET7, also N-I-O-E-T-7, und kommt mit einer Feststoffbatterie, keine Ahnung, das ist irgendwie nicht Lithium-Ion oder so, sondern irgendwas Neues, ist austauschbar. Der Akku ist austauschbar. Also man fährt an so eine Station, da wird der unten ausgedockt und ein anderer wird eingedockt und er lädt dann in der Stunde auf und dann kriegt er halt das nächste Auto. Also das ist so eine Infrastrukturfrage, die kann man ja in China, wo wir wissen, da läuft es ja ein bisschen anders, auch anders klären. Und die Frage ist, muss man den Akku überhaupt tauschen? Denn das Ding kommt mit zwei Motoren, vorne und hinten. Vorne 200 PS, hinten 400 PS, also 600 PS summiert. 1000 Kilometer Reichweite. Wir veranschlagen für das große Akkumodell 1000 Kilometer Reichweite. Das schafft kein Benziner. Also so weit kann man gar nicht fahren, ohne dann eh eine Pause machen zu müssen. Und in deren Sicht ist das doch hier für 2021 sieben Jahre, bevor dann auch die S-Klasse mal so richtig elektrifiziert nur noch so auf den Markt kommt. Ich glaube, in sieben Jahren werden wir aus China Autos haben, die dann 2000 Kilometer fahren. Und dann ist es wie bei Porsche, wo man dann auch feststellt, ja, eigentlich haben wir angegeben 600 Kilometer, aber fährt doch nur 350 und so. Ja, dass man da so ein paar Frühstückseier noch frühstücken muss, die uns verdauen muss, bevor man da dem Kunden wirklich ein zufriedenstellendes Ding für. Und das ist eben auch so eine Sache, dass das Ding da aus China wird irgendwie so 50.000 Euro kosten und nicht 170.000 wie so ein Porsche in Dingsta-Bups.
Und du hast es gerade gesagt, NIO, Marktkapitalisierung von Daimler, 71 Milliarden, habe ich eben gesagt. NIO liegt bei, ich glaube, 64, 65 Milliarden. Also sind jetzt schon fast gleich auch. Und man weiß, was solche Meldungen, die du jetzt gerade genannt hast, was solche Meldungen dann an der Börse nochmal auslösen. Ich bin sehr gespannt, ob Kelenius das wirklich schafft und ob das Trennen am Ende erfolgreich sein wird, wer davon profitiert. Fest steht, das war ein grandioses Jahr für Daimler. Und das ist auch etwas, was wir uns jetzt noch mal mit dieser ganzen Corona-Politik im Hintergrund, warum ist das dann jetzt eigentlich alles so gelaufen? Warum gab es eigentlich nicht von der Wirtschaft mehr Druck? Wir haben ja ein bisschen so diesen Diskurs gehabt. Ja, wir müssen jetzt mal die Wirtschaft zu Homeoffice und all dem verpflichten. Und da ist sicherlich auch viel dran. Also die Eisfabrik, du hast sie eben genannt. Andererseits haben ja solche Unternehmen wie Mercedes und so sich relativ vorbildlich, glaube ich, verhalten in der Krise. Und es gab aber auch von der Wirtschaft gar nicht sonst so viel Murren. Also es sind Einzelhändler, die immer noch ihre Geschäfte zu haben müssen. Zum Teil aus sehr fadenscheinigen Gründen. Aber die Großindustrie, die hat sich ja kaum beschwert über den Lockdown. Und jetzt kriegt man so mit, aha, die hatten so ein Top-Jahr. 53 Prozent ging es dann nach oben. Die Aktie ist jetzt auch mal ordentlich was wert. Und jetzt wagt Ola Kilenius mal so einen Ausblick. 2021 wird das dann wieder so gut. Und wir würden ja jetzt als Normalbürger fragen, ja, wann wird es dann mal wieder ein bisschen besser? Und er fragt sich jetzt, ja, wird es dann auch jetzt wieder so ein Top-Jahr?
Perl und Martin, wir haben ein phänomenales Job in Bezug auf Geldbefragung gemacht. Nicht alle der Verbrauchersprache, die wir in 2020 bemerken konnten, sind Dinge, die man 2021 wiederholen kann. Wenn ich eine Analyse in unseren persönlichen Leben benutze, habe ich in den letzten Jahren viel weniger Geld als ich in den letzten Jahren die Haare gekämpft habe.
Ja, Lohnkosten werden steigen dadurch, dass dann nicht mehr der Staat die Löhne bezahlt. Also dieses Großarbeitergeld, das ist eigentlich unglaublich, wie schnell man da das ganze Geld der Großindustrie gegeben hat, das dorthin transferiert hat. Die Aktionäre haben alle davon profitiert, müssen nicht irgendwas davon abgeben, sondern die können einfach, und das sind ja alles Großaktionäre, wir reden jetzt auch von internationalen Aktionären. Da wird ja immer dieses Bild gemacht, von dem Deutschen, der jetzt auch fünf Daimler-Aktien hat. Das mag es ja auch geben, ja, aber das ist ja vollkommen zu vernachlässigen. Das heißt, die haben genau von diesen Entwicklungen profitiert, während hier immer noch Künstler gucken, ob sie vielleicht doch in irgendeiner Weise noch eine Förderung bekommen. Da wurde dann immer nur gesagt, ja, wir übernehmen laufende Kosten, diese ganzen Anträge, die man dann erst im Februar stellen konnte, um mal den November bezahlt zu bekommen. Da ist ja auch Altmaier wirklich eine reinste Katastrophe. Das ist ja jemand, der nur dieser Industrie zuarbeitet. Also wir haben eigentlich eine Politik, die nur Aktionäre und die Großindustrie froh macht. Die alle anderen spielen keine Rolle, die werden mit irgendwas abgefertigt in der Hoffnung, dass sie nicht ganz so viele Proteste veranstalten.
Ja, die Sina Trinkwalder, die ja hier in Deutschland so um Bode herstellt, hat ja auch bei Maiprit Illner oder so im Fernsehen noch mal im Gespräch mit Peter Altmaier genau das Problem aufgezeigt. Das ist nicht nur die Geldsumme einfach, sondern es ist auch die Bürokratie. Wenn Peter Altmaier hunderttausend Beschäftigten helfen möchte, dann gibt es für ihn zwei Möglichkeiten. Er sagt, hier, großes Unternehmen, schick mir das fertig durch juristisch formulierte Ding, ich unterschreibe und damit fließt am nächsten Tag das Kurzarbeitergeld für 50.000 Leute. Auf der anderen Seite 50.000 Einzelanträge von irgendwelchen Künstlern, die irgendwie darstellen, was sie so machen. Und das muss natürlich erstmal bearbeitet werden. Und das dauert dann natürlich, da kommt dann die Novemberhilfe vielleicht im Februar und so. Wenn überhaupt. Und in der Ansicht macht sich das Wirtschaftsministerium, das da auch sehr einfach, indem die da einfach Key Account Manager, wir können ja unsere Pappenheimer, säuber jetzt jedes Morgen den Wisch rüberschicken, hier wir schicken schon mal das Geld. Also da einfach sozusagen so strukturelle Vorteile ausnutzen.
Wir enden literarisch mit diesem Vlog über die Entscheidungen und über die Entscheider. Wir haben jetzt doch gesehen, manche haben diese Krise als Chance begriffen, konnten extrem davon profitieren, andere dümpeln noch herum und es ist ja auch an uns zu fragen, wer hat denn jetzt eigentlich gerade richtig gehandelt, wie ist denn das eigentlich mit Donald Trump? Müssen wir da vielleicht irgendwann noch mal ein bisschen ihn rehabilitieren, insofern als er erkannt hat, okay, wir müssen diese Biontech-Impfstoffe besorgen, die brauchen wir dringend, wir müssen sehen, dass wir RNA verfolgen und geben da richtig Geld rein. Also das wird man auch im Nachhinein noch mal sehen und es hat ja Demisier angesprochen, es geht da um Leben und Tod, also wer trägt auch die Verantwortung für Tote, all das stellt sich. Und es gibt ein Stück, ich glaube, ich habe das hier schon einmal zitiert von Slavoj Zizek, das heißt Die drei Leben der Antigone und das Tolle an diesem Stück ist, dass er alle drei Sachen durchdekliniert, also einmal die offizielle Antigone, also wir wissen Antigone will ihren Bruder begraben, darf das aber nicht, Creon will das verhindern. Antigone folgt einem göttlichen Gesetz, sagt sie, aber Creon ist für eine positive Rechtssetzung, sagt nein, das darfst du jetzt hier nicht, außerdem müssen wir einen Bürgerkrieg verhindern und Zizek spielt jetzt so durch, wer hat denn, welche Möglichkeiten gibt es noch und was ist denn, wenn man sich eigentlich beide entledigt, Antigone muss weg, Creon muss weg, jetzt entscheidet das Volk und am Ende tritt dann der Schauspieler nach vorn zum Publikum und sagt hier ihr habt jetzt das gesehen, so ist es gelaufen, das waren die Optionen, man kann es auch vielleicht so sehen, das waren die Optionen, Schnelltest oder nicht, RNA oder Astra und so weiter und jetzt macht mal. Die alte Weisheit stimmt, den Klauen des Schicksals können wir nicht entkommen, doch was sie außer Acht lässt, ist, dass wir auch der Last unserer Verantwortung nicht entkommen können. Wir können unser Schicksal nicht als Ausrede benutzen, um zu tun, was uns gefällt. Wir sind am Ende der traurigen Geschichten um Antigone angelangt. Welcher von ihnen sollen wir folgen? Hatte sie Recht darin, bis zum Ende auf den göttlichen ungeschriebenen Gesetzen zu beharren? Hatte Creon Recht, das Gemeinwohl des Stadtstaats im Auge zu behalten? Oder hatte der Chor Recht, sich beider zu entledigen und eine Herrschaft der Gemeinschaft zu errichten? Es gibt keine einfache Antwort. Wir Schauspieler sind nur Schötten. Vor euch, unseren Zuschauern, breiteten wir die drei verschiedenen Schicksale aus. Ihr habt die Wahl. Auf eigene Gefahr müsst ihr sie treffen. Niemand kann euch dabei helfen, ihr seid allein. Wenn wir alleine sind, wenn nichts geschieht, kommt uns plötzlich das Raunen des Lebens an und in diesem Moment wissenweise, wie das Chaos aufzuhalten ist und entscheiden.
Ich überlege gerade, es gibt auch so eine, kriege ich jetzt bestimmt nichts zusammen, ich bin nicht sehr bibelfest, aber das geht doch auch irgendwie los. Am Anfang muss ja unterschieden werden, Himmel und Erde, Licht und Doppel, keine Ahnung wie.
Genau, das sind die binären Einteilungen, das finde ich nochmal ganz wichtig zu sagen. Wir haben oft in so einem postmodernen Diskurs, dass wir Binarität als etwas grundsätzlich gefährliches ansehen. Man muss aber sagen, wenn wir Dinge entscheiden, wenn wir Dinge abwägen, wenn wir sagen, das ist ein guter Impfstoff und das ist ein sehr guter Impfstoff, dann denken wir durchaus in Binaritäten, weil wir Vergleiche ziehen. Und das zeigt sich da schon im Ursprung der Welt, wie es geschildert wird in der Bibel.
Genau, also ich will jetzt nur spekulieren, aber die Bibel beginnt irgendwie mit, am Anfang war das Wort, zumindest in dieser lotter-lutheranischen Übersetzung. Man hat sich dann doch noch mal sehr viele Gedanken gemacht, war am Anfang wirklich das Wort oder hat sich Luther da einfach einen leichten gemacht, hat gesagt, ich übersetze mal Wort. Ja, wie ist das eigentlich zu deuten? Was war am Anfang wirklich? Und man kann, es gibt wohl auch Deutungen, die sagen, am Anfang war die Entscheidung. Und gerade hinsichtlich dieser ganzen Unterscheidung von Wasser, naja eben hell, dunkel, Himmel, Erde und so weiter, dass man da doch die Bibel falsch versteht, zumindest in diesem. Aber ich bringe das hier nur spekulativ ein.
Das ist eine Frage, die ja auch Faust beschäftigt im ersten Teil. Da setzt er sich ja mit der Bibelübersetzung auseinander und überlegt, wie man es denn noch korrekter oder richtiger übersetzen könnte.
Goethe hat es schon immer gewusst. Ich will mal weiter spekulieren mit dem Begriff Dispersion. Was heißt Dispersion? Man kann in der Wikipedia nachgucken, da gibt es ganz viele. Alexa, was ist Dispersion?
Laut Wikipedia unter Dispersion versteht man in der Physik die Abhängigkeit einer physikalischen Größe von der Frequenz einer Welle. In der Optik ist dies speziell die von der Frequenz des Lichts abhängende Ausbreitungsgeschwindigkeit des Lichts in Medien.
Okay, also irgendwas breitet aus und es hängt davon ab, wie das Medium geschaffen ist, in dem sich etwas ausbreitet. Und da gibt es doch jetzt eine große Diskussion. Also ich war echt super überrascht und ich mache es auch nur ganz spekulativ, denn in einem Podcast, den ich gerade gerne höre, mit Scott Galloway, einem Professor aus Amerika, der irgendwie mit Karas Wischer und so weiter zweimal die Woche so ein bisschen rumalbert, hat er den Griff Dispersion eingebracht und meinte, das ist wichtiger als Digitalisierung, denn Digitalisierung verstehen wir alle. Auf Dispersion muss man sich jetzt gezielt vorbereiten, gerade wenn man als Professor junge Studenten vor sich hat und denen die Welt erklären möchte. Bevor wir Dispersion sprechen, wieder Galloway, das Ein, also so richtig im appellativen Imperativ. Darum müsst ihr euch kümmern, so einer vorführenden. Greifen wir mal ganz kurz zurück und ziehen Bilanz zum Lieferkettengesetz, denn hier breitet sich ja auch etwas aus in ein Medium, das man mal kontrollieren möchte, die Lieferkette. Irgendwo gibt es einen Konsumenten, irgendwo gibt es einen Produzenten und dazwischen ist eine Lieferkette. Und das Lieferkettengesetz ist jetzt da, das ist sozusagen der Anlass. Ich will es in vier kleinen Clips besprechen, denn es gibt große Unzufriedenheit. Ich glaube, man kann sich zum einen anhängen an die Aufarbeitung, die Monitor gemacht hat. Also ich erinnere hier, es gibt eine ganz ausführliche Lieferkettengesetzbesprechung, in der die ganzen Wünsche vorgetragen wurden. Und der CSU-Mann Thomas Müller, Michael Müller, wie heißt er, unser Entwicklungsminister, Michael Müller, der noch mal, oder heißt er Thomas Müller, wie auch immer, der hat ja noch mal darauf hingewiesen, für alle von uns im Westen arbeiten 50 Sklaven. Das machen sie nicht mehr hier bei uns vor der Haustür, aber über die Lieferketten summiert sich das so auf. Er wollte da also Abhilfe schaffen und die wurde jetzt geschaffen. Es gibt jedenfalls jetzt ein Lieferkettengesetz, nach dem Hubertus Heil androht, ich mach's zum Koalitionsausschuss-Thema. Das war ja eigentlich, hatten wir damals besprochen, sozusagen die Ultima Ratio und zu der muss er jetzt greifen. Und jetzt ist der Gesetzentwurf da. Frank Schwabe von der SPD beschreibt es in der Monitorsendung wie folgt.
Das Wirtschaftsministerium hat alles versucht, diesen Prozess zu unterminieren und am Ende dafür zu sorgen, dass am Ende gar nichts dabei rauskommt. Und das Ganze ist ja im engen Schulterschluss gewesen und in enger Absprache mit den Verbänden der deutschen Wirtschaft.
Also die Wirtschaft hat sich wieder durchgesetzt. Wir kennen ja noch die Stolpersteine. Gibt es jetzt zivilrechtliche Haftung? Kann man jemanden verklagen dafür, dass in Bangladesch Fabriken kaputtgehen, wenn man hier in Europa das Zeug so billig ankauft, wohl wissend, dass diese Gefahren da bestehen und Arbeitsschutzstandards nicht eingehalten werden und so weiter und so fort. Greenpeace ist derselben Meinung wie die SPD.
Was hier am Freitag verkündet wurde, ist für Menschenrecht und Umweltschutz allerdings ein Schlag ins Gesicht. Hier sehen wir den Stempel der Wirtschaftsverbände aus Deutschland. Sie scheint wirklich den Stift von Peter Altmaier geführt zu haben und seit Jahren diesen Prozess so untergraben zu haben, dass das, was jetzt als Lieferkettengesetz verkündet wird, eigentlich nur noch ein ausgehölter Papiertiger ist.
Hm, das ist dramatisch.
Es ist so dramatisch, wie es klingt. Gerd Müller ist der Entwicklungsminister. Man kommt mit den ganzen Fußballern durcheinander.
Ich habe mir überlegt, irgendein Fußballer war es doch. Thomas Müller? Peter Altmaier redet sich hier natürlich raus.
Anfangs war geplant, die gesamte Lieferkette eines Unternehmens zu berücksichtigen. Im aktuellen Entwurf geht es nur noch um die unmittelbaren Zulieferer. Im aktuellen Gesetzesentwurf ist die zivilrechtliche Haftung komplett gestrichen. Weniger Unternehmen, weniger Zulieferer, keine zivilrechtliche Haftung. Ein verwässertes Gesetz, Nachfrage beim Bundeswirtschaftsminister.
Es war überhaupt gar nicht meine Absicht, irgendetwas zu verwässern, sondern es war meine Absicht, die Dinge so zu fokussieren, dass sie dem Menschenrechtsschutz zugutekommt.
Also in der harten Weise, in der Peter Altmaier mittlerweile vor laufender Kamera lügt und dabei auch grinst, erinnert an soziopathisches Verhalten. Man kann es nicht anders sagen, glaube ich.
Man muss es so benennen. Ich habe Altmaier ja mal vor zwei Jahren live erlebt. Und zwar hat er Kobenz einen Besuch abgestattet. Und dann gab es da mit Journalisten so ein Treffen. Und ich habe ihn dort erlebt. Und es ist unglaublich, was dieser Mann sich rausholt in seinem ganzen Auftreten. Also ein Auftreten, das wirklich eines ist, das, glaube ich, das er nur klug ist, alles weiß, absolut im Recht ist, egal, worum es geht. Und wenn man aber dann schaut, was er auch für Perspektiven in Deutschland sieht, dann kann man wirklich sagen, es ist eine Katastrophe. Ich will ein Beispiel nennen. Es ging damals ein bisschen hoch her, wer könnte denn Merkels Nachfolger sein? Ist da jemand? Da war das noch nicht alles so klar, dass Merkel nicht mehr antritt und so weiter? Oder müsste sie vorzeitig abgelöst werden? Und dann sagte Altmaier, na ja, da ist ja auch jetzt niemand. Also ihm würde jetzt einfallen, aber da weiß man nicht, ob er es machen würde. Als Nachfolger von Merkel, wer würde jetzt kommen? Jetzt würde man vielleicht noch sagen, gut, irgendjemand, der vielleicht 50 ist, oder so den nennt er, dann brachte er tatsächlich Schäuble ins Spiel. Und ich habe gedacht, was habe ich denn jetzt gerade da gehört? Also wir würden Merkel vielleicht erneuern können, nehmen wir Schäublewellen? Also wir tauschen Willi Milovic durch Jopi Hestas aus, oder was? Also das ist unglaublich, ja. Aber das war Altmaier und das sieht man auch da. Und so macht er seine Geschäfte mit der Wirtschaft und so wird da gekungelt. Und es ist wirklich schlimm, dass wir so regiert werden.
Genau, da möchte ich hier einen kleinen Appell loswerden. Ich meine, Schäuble als Innenminister und Finanzminister katastrophal. Als Bundestagspräsident, finde ich, kann man sich mit dem versöhnen als politischer Figur. Aber das sollte dann auch der letzte Job sein. Danach kann er durchaus in Rente gehen, ist auch alt genug. Peter Altmaier finde ich eine Katastrophe. Diese Arroganz, diese Überheblichkeit und diese absolute Unsensibilität, mit zu Themen umzugehen. Denn hier geht es wirklich um Leben und Tod. Bei der Pandemie in Deutschland mit den Künstler-Schicksalen usw. Aber hier weltweit mit diesen Lieferketten. Er weiß doch genau, was da los ist. Und wir haben ja damals auch gehört, wie betroffen die SPD-ler da aus diesen Minen irgendwo in Afrika zurückkommen und sagen, Leute, jetzt müssen wir einfach mal diesen Euro zahlen. Wir müssen jetzt einfach mal diesen einen Euro zahlen, der hier so viel verändern kann. Aber dieses Gesetz ist jetzt da. Und ich möchte auch noch mal die alternative Sichtweise. Neben Monitor, die das natürlich kritisch sehen und völlig angemessen kritisch, gibt es eine alternative Sichtweise von Harald Wälzer, die auch ein bisschen Bezug nimmt auf das, was mir wichtig ist. Es gibt eine Bundestagswahl dieses Jahr.
Ich finde es ja erstens schon mal wohltuend, dass es auch in Zeiten von Corona überhaupt noch Politik gibt, die nichts mit Corona zu tun hat. Und dann auch noch Gute. Ich finde es nämlich, dass das Lieferkettengesetz ein echter Anfang ist. Insofern, und obwohl der Kollege Altmaier einiges von einem ambitionierteren Gesetzentwurf von Hubertus Heil und Gerd Müller weggewalzt hat, trotzdem ist das Gesetz ein Einstieg in ein moderneres Wirtschaftsmodell und ein erster Hebel gegen solche skrupellose Ausbauung von Arbeitskraft im globalen Süden. Also man muss da ja mal das Potenzial sehen, was da drinsteckt. Künftig könnten nämlich Unternehmen wegen des Lieferkettengesetzes und der damit verbundenen Haftung vermehrt auf die Idee kommen, ihre Verträge zum Beispiel direkt mit Arbeiterinnen vor Ort zu machen oder auch mit Bauern und damit das Problem der Kontrolle der Subunternehmen überhaupt ganz vermeiden.
So, also zum einen steckt da drin, das ist Radio 1 Kommentar, Harald Wälzer hier. Zum einen steckt da drin, es gibt eine Bundestagswahl, wir haben jetzt schon mal ein Gesetz, das kann man ja dann nachbessern. Wir haben jetzt beispielsweise keine zivilrechtliche Haftung im Sinne von, da kann wirklich jemand kommen und jetzt ein deutsches Unternehmen verklagen. Aber es gibt eine Bußgeldstelle, es gibt also jetzt Menschen, die sind damit beauftragt, das zu beobachten, was da vor sich geht und am Ende auch mal ein Preisschild an irgendwelche Vergehen zu hängen. Das bedeutet für die Unternehmen, die müssen sich dann doch darum Gedanken machen, was sie für Lieferketten haben, sie können also nicht einfach aus Einfachheit sagen, wir nehmen mal so einen Aggregator-Händler, der irgendwie den Kontakt mit den Fabriken vor Ort hält und von dem kaufen wir das denn. Und da im Großraumbüro des Händlers ist aber alles in Ordnung, deswegen müssen wir nicht weiter gucken, was passiert in der Fabrik, sondern man kann ja durchaus direkt bei der Fabrik wieder kaufen, weil es sich lohnt, weil man damit dann auch Kontakt hat, was da passiert und das sieht. Und jetzt stellen wir uns aber mal eine ganz spekulative Frage und binden alles zusammen, Corona und so weiter und so fort. Wir haben auf der einen Seite, also auf der einen Seite sind wir. Auf der anderen Seite ist die Näherin in Bangladesch. Und dieses Gesetz betrifft jetzt das Verhältnis der Näherin in Bangladesch mit irgendeinem Händler, der in der Stadt noch eine Filiale hat. Noch nicht direkt mit uns. Können wir uns eigentlich direkt ins Verhältnis setzen zu der Händlerin, zu der wirklichen Handwerkerin in Bangladesch, also die, die wirklich das Produkt erschafft, bevor es dann in die Verpackung da Ding, Star-Marketing, Bipapo, was man auch alles nicht eigentlich bräuchte. Und ich bin hier über ein Ding gestolpert, da habe ich erst gedacht, ja gut, okay, so ein ganz lustiges Ding. Aber die Sarah Wagenknecht hat hier so einen Punkt aufgemacht, bei dem ich kurz dachte, da müssen wir vielleicht noch mal drüber nachdenken.
Also wir haben zum Beispiel den Einzelhandel, alles, was nicht Lebensmittel ist, dicht gemacht. Das heißt, wir verlagern das Geschäft beispielsweise zu Amazon. Beim Einzelhandel wissen wir nicht, wie viel Übertragung es gab. Aber bei den Amazon Logistikzentren, da ist bekannt, dass das vielfach Corona-Hotspots waren. Das heißt, die Frage ist, ob das überhaupt sinnvoll ist, was wir aktuell tun.
Ja, also hier kommt auch die Lieferkette nochmal insbesondere in den Blickfeld, weil wir sagen, wir schützen am Ende nur den Endkunden. Der soll nicht in den Laden gehen. Während derjenige, der uns das Zeug da irgendwie verpackt oder so im Amazon-Laden, der ist raus. Der ist im Dienst, der steht im Arbeitsverhältnis. Keine Ahnung, für den gilt Corona-Regeln irgendwie nicht. Für uns Publikum aber umso mehr. Also wir haben hier einen extremen Bias in der ganzen Corona-Politik auf Publikum. Wir müssen das Publikum schützen. Es darf Eis hergestellt werden. Bei Minusgraden stehen die Leute am Band und stellen irgendwie Eis her. Aber der Eis-Verkauf ist dann verboten. Du kannst jetzt nicht in die Saison gehen und Eis kaufen. Weil das eine betrifft Publikum, die freie Welt, das private. Das andere ist aber dieses dienstliche irgendwie. Und da gilt das alles nicht. Diese Corona-Politik, die spaltet auch so richtig die Welt in einmal diesen dienstlichen, privatwirtschaftlichen, einmal diesen Publikums, öffentlich-privatem Bereich. So richtig krass.
Und das hat man ja an der Börse besonders. Also man betrachtet ja als interessiertes Publikum das Ganze. Wie entwickelt sich etwas? Wie entwickelt sich ein Unternehmen? Haben wir da noch Erwartungen? Wird es nach der Pause genauso schön noch mal werden? Bleiben wir noch drin sitzen? Investieren wir? Sind wir noch länger investiert in das Ganze? Und das ist eine Publikumshaltung zu sagen, auch ich lasse das Geld für mich arbeiten. Das heißt aber immer dieser Satz, ich lasse die da bei Amazon sich infizieren mit Corona, ist nicht mein Problem, ich bin Publikum, mein Geld macht das ja. Nein, nein, ich lasse Leute für mich arbeiten und schaue dann als Publikum auf die steigenden Aktienkurse und sage 2020 tolles Jahr, guck mal, ob 2021 auch so gut wird, wenn jetzt auch noch plötzlich wieder Lohnkosten anfallen.
Genau, und da bei dieser Unterscheidung zwischen privat und beruflich, wo die Corona-Politik schon so krass unterscheidet, da greift jetzt dieses neue Wort Dispersion. Denn, wie eben gehört in der Physik, der Lichtstrahl kommt aus der einen Sphäre in die andere und dazwischen ist irgendwie so ein Medium und das macht irgendwas damit. Und jetzt ist hier der Scott Galloway, der in seinem Podcast mal über Dispersion spricht. Und mit der 3. meint er nach Elektrifizierung und Digitalisierung oder so. Dispersion ordnet also den Konsumenten, mit dem Produzenten beruflich, aber mal so richtig komplett neu. Er hat jetzt ein Beispiel des Films, das ganz Kino ist plötzlich außen vor. Das Kino als Distributor, da gehen wir hin, um Filme zu gucken. Ne, wir gucken die natürlich zuhause. Und die diskutieren das in den Podcasts durch, und man denkt sich so die ganze Zeit, Kinos, jaja klar, das liegt auf der Hand, das ist ja auch grad schon so. Universitäten, wer braucht eigentlich noch Gebäude und Institutionen? Es könnten doch diejenigen, die die Schulbücher herstellen. Wer bietet eigentlich Homeoffice-Unterricht an? Ist es die Schule? Warum Schule? Kann es nicht der Schulbuchverlag sein oder vielleicht sogar der Schulbuchautor? Kriegt man das eigentlich, dieses Verhältnis neu geordnet? Banken, wer braucht noch Banken? Jetzt haben wir alle diese Apps, die uns ermächtigen. Es gibt schon die ersten Banken, die gar keine Filialen mehr haben, sondern die nur noch im Smartphone funktionieren. Hausärzte, wir haben es aus Shenzhen gehört. Da stehen einfach so Zellen in einer Stadt rum, da setzt man sich rein. Da wird ein Foto vom Gesicht gemacht und mit irgendwelchen Wellen die Herzrequenz gemessen und so weiter. Dann wird mal geguckt in den tausendgängigen Diagnosen, welches denn am wahrscheinlichsten? Die Sonderfälle, klar, die kommen ins Krankenhaus.
Was ich allerdings glaube, ist, dass wir zum einen diese Disintermediation erleben, dass wir dann nicht mehr dort erstmal zum Hausarzt müssen, dass wir nicht auf die Bank müssen. Wir machen das über das Smartphone Bluetooth irgendwie selbst gerade. Ich überweis dir das, sitzt dir gegenüber, wir legen die Smartphones zusammen und schon ist das passiert. Brauchen wir nicht irgendwas zu unterzeichnen, brauchen wir keinen Bankangestellten. Aber zugleich haben wir auch eine Entwicklung, die eigentlich immer mehr Intermediäre verlangt. Und so ist es auch bei Wonder Woman, dass man den zu Hause sich ansehen kann, liegt wieder an Streaming-Anbietern, liegt daran, dass ich Abo-Modelle irgendwo abschließe, liegt daran, dass nur die und die von diesem Abo auch profitieren. Wir haben das ja bei Spotify jetzt auch immer mehr aufbereitet bekommen. Wer eigentlich davon profitiert, es sind nicht die Künstler, es sind selbstverständlich die großen Musikkonzerne, die wiederum investiert sind in Spotify, die ein Interesse daran haben, dass die Künstler wenig ausgezahlt bekommen. Das heißt, wir haben da auch wiederum zum einen eine ganz, ganz dichte Bündelung oder bzw. eine Unmittelbarkeit, die erzeugt wird. Aber diese Intermediäre, die werden auf der anderen Seite immer mehr. Also, dass auch jetzt nur noch das medial vorkommen kann in den Unterhaltungsmedien, was durch eine Agentur, durch was weiß ich alles irgendwie schon vertreten ist. Also, so funktioniert ja dieser Talkshow-Zirkus zum Beispiel. Oder so funktionieren diese ganzen Podcastgeschichten, dass da immer Leute in Agenturen sind. Diese Agenturen haben den Kursentrat zu anderen Intermediären, die wieder sind die Leute, die das nach Spotify und sonst wo hinbringen. Und dann sieht man, ach toll, da hat wieder irgendein B-Promien-Podcast bekommen. Also so haben wir, glaube ich, eine extreme Zunahme von Intermediären, die immer auf so einem Plattformmodell dann auch beruhen. Und ja, zum anderen ist es vollkommen richtig, dass wir das jetzt ganz nah an uns dran haben. Und die Sache ist noch, was sehen wir eigentlich nicht dabei? Also das ist ja auch toll, als Publikum könnte man ja sagen, was ist denn das eigentlich für ein Publikum, das gewisse Dinge gar nicht sieht. Also wir sehen die Näheren nicht in Bangladesch. Und wir sehen auch eigentlich nicht, wie es genau bei Amazon zugeht. Also wir wissen, dass das nicht so toll ist. Aber wir sehen das eigentlich nicht. Wir sehen nur denjenigen, der uns das bringt. Und man hat manchmal so ein bisschen ein peinliches Berührtsein, dass man jetzt ein großes Paket mit wenig drin bekommt. Und da ist jemand, der extrem im Stress ist und wirft das einem so gerade dorthin. Aber das war auch dann die Begegnung mit der Realität.
Genau, an dem Punkt schließe ich gleich nochmal an. Klar, es gibt auch neue Intermediäre. Also einer muss ja auch digitale Güter vermitteln. Nur im Kino sehen wir ja schon, das kann ja auch HBO selber machen. Und das kann ja auch Disney selber machen. Die brauchen ja nicht wirklich Netflix oder Amazon Prime Video. In deren Sicht muss man immer nochmal genau schauen. Haben wir jetzt nochmal neue Institutionen, die das Internet einfach nur nutzen, bevor wir aber dann sagen, das können wir wirklich per Internet machen, so wie wir auch für den Salon immer noch steady benutzen. Aber sobald jetzt irgendwelche Bitcoin kann es noch nicht. Aber diese Integration von Technik und Währung kann ja durchaus super eng, wie bei diesem Ethereum, wo es schon Smart Contracts und so weiter gibt. Pro Link wird einfach abgebucht. Pro geklickten Link kann nur bestätigt werden, wenn im Smartphone wirklich eine Zahlung ausgelöst wird. Also davon sind wir ja nicht weit weg. In der Ansicht dieser Kampf zwischen Institution und Internet. Wir haben jetzt sozusagen die Stufe 1 abgeschlossen. Die Institutionen selbst wurden digitalisiert. Videotheken, Amazon Prime Video. Aber der Kampf gegen das Internet von den Institutionen muss trotzdem noch mal ein paar mehr Sachen standhalten demnächst. Also in der Ansicht ist dieses Dispersionsargument, da glaube ich, zeigt schon mal so eine Richtung auf. Auch wenn wir immer noch mehr Interaktionen mit Institutionen haben. Jetzt hat er hier noch so einen zweiten Punkt, denn er will es natürlich gleich mal kritisch sehen. Das ist auch völlig zu Recht. Und ich will noch mal zurück an diese Ausgangsidee, beruflich und privat. Wenn wir Eis essen, Kino, Bank, Arzt, dann schwingt da drin schon immer mit, das ist nicht zu Hause. Da müssen wir irgendwo hingehen. Da brauchen wir öffentlichen Raum. Eine Straße, die als Straße funktioniert. Öffentlichen Nahverkehr, der funktioniert. Sicherheit, die gewährleistet wird. Umso mehr ich allerdings meine Kino-Filme zu Hause gucke und mich über meine Smartwatch diagnostiziere und nicht zum Arzt gehe oder meine Bankgeschäfte am Handy mache und eben nicht durch die Stadt laufe zur Bankfiliale, umso mehr findet eben auch Segregation statt. Also dein Argument zu Corona, dass wir hier alle nur noch zahlen, so eine Statistik sind und so weiter, das wird hier nochmal strapaziert. Es gibt nicht nur diese Richtung der Corona-Politik, sozusagen als Folge, sondern als Effekt auch noch diese Dispersion, die direkte Segregation mit sich bringt und eben einen ganz neuen Blick auf Gesellschaft führt. Denn wir bleiben alle mehr zu Hause jetzt. Wir fahren nicht mehr durch die Gesellschaft, wir sehen die anderen nicht mehr als individuell und irgendwie speziell und so. Sondern nur noch da drüben, das sind so die Assis, da sind die Babanen und da sind die scheiß Politiker und das sind die blöden Virologen.
Und man merkt das ja auch schon, wenn jetzt so diese, naja, Bürgerpolizei unterwegs ist, so will ich sie mal nennen. Kaum waren es paar Tage schön mal, da waren dann wieder unzählige Fotos in den sozialen Medien zu sehen. Guckt hier, dort tummeln sie sich wieder, die Menschen auf Spielplätzen, auf Wiesen. Was, da wird ja sogar gepicknickt, als hätten wir kein Corona. Also man geht als Einzelner durch, man ist ja selbst dort draußen. Also man fragt sich ja immer, wie entstehen solche Aufnahmen? Also das heißt ja, da hat ja jemand selbst das Haus verlassen, hat gesagt, oh, das Wetter ist schön, ich geh mal raus. Und dann geht man da raus und sagt, was, das sind ja andere Menschen. Wir können die nur, wir haben doch Corona. Jetzt fotografiere ich die mal ab und stelle die mal bloß in den sozialen Medien als unverantwortlich. Und da haben wir genau diese Segregation, die so verrückt ist, dass man eigentlich sagen muss, ach, die sind so wie ich. Nein, man sagt, das sind aber schlimme Menschen hier gerade.
Genau, die Psychologie dazu ist seit Jahrzehnten fertig geschrieben. Sie muss jetzt nur neu angewendet werden zu diesen ganzen Effekten. Naja, dann werf du noch ein Thema ein, bevor wir hier zu Apple, zu dem großen Kampf Apple gegen Facebook kommen?
GameStop war das große Thema im Januar und ist es immer noch oder jetzt auch wieder, denn die GameStop-Aktie setzt an zu einem neuen Höhenflug. Wir wissen jetzt gar nicht, wie es gerade weitergeht. Vielleicht, wenn der Podcast wenige Stunden später veröffentlicht ist, dann ist es schon wieder ganz woanders. Es geht auf jeden Fall hoch, volatil zu und da hat sich auch die amerikanische Politik gedacht, da müssen wir doch mal nachfühlen, mal nachhören, was ist denn da eigentlich los? Brauchen wir da neue Regeln oder wer ist denn eigentlich schuld an was gerade? Und es gab eine Anhörung im Kongress und die war sehr, sehr kurios. Die ging über fünf Stunden. Ich habe mir das ganz angetan. Man muss sagen, diese Leute verdienen ja alle kein schlechtes Geld, aber wieso können sie sich nicht mal ein Mikro für 100 Dollar kaufen? Es ist eine Katastrophe, was da zum Teil abspielt sich. Aber es gibt auch bemerkenswertes zu berichten. Und wir hören jetzt erst mal Maxine Borters von den Demokraten, die das Ganze leitet. Und sie ist 82 Jahre alt, war ich dann auch verblüfft, das zu lesen. Und na ja, die hat Haare auf den Zähnen. So, das ist erst mal die Diagnose einer Demokratin. Aber es gibt hier auch die Republikaner. Und da hören wir dann auch zu Eröffnung Patrick McHenry. Und der sagt, na ja, das ist jetzt hier Fortschritt. Da können wir nicht einfach mal einen Deckel drauf machen.
GameStop ist die Fortschritt der jahrelangen Frustration.
Siehe mal, dass für jede Geschichte jemanden, der ihr Studierendenrein oder von der GameStop-Kraft auskommt, oder, conversely, jemanden, der Geld verloren hat, die in Proteste investieren würden.
Das klingt jetzt ja fast sozialistisch, was er da sagt. Dass er erstmal sagt, naja, so die kämpfen da auch an gegen ein System. Die sind in prekären Zuständen dort diese Leute. Also wenn wir das erstmal mal ein bisschen zusammenfassen, bei GameStop ging es ja darum, dass wir es mit einer Aktie zu tun haben, eines Unternehmens, das sehr stark schwächelt, dadurch, dass wir es mit einem Unternehmen zu tun haben, das nicht mehr so ganz am Puls der Zeit ist. Jeder kennt vielleicht aus den Malls diese Shops, die GameStop-Shops. Dort kann man Computerspiele kaufen. Man muss aber heute das nicht mehr tun, sondern kann sie streamen. Dadurch ist natürlich so eine Ladenkette arg bedroht. Und dann gab es Überlegungen, ob jetzt diese Aktien noch weiter in den Keller sind. Die war schon sehr tief unten. Daraufhin hat ein Patchfond-Manager gesagt, ja, das wird so der Fall sein. Es gab aber auch wiederum jemand, der gesagt hat, nee, die könnte noch mehr eigentlich bringen, diese Aktien, wenn die sich ein bisschen umstrukturieren und so. Also das war so 2020 der Fall. Und dann gab es dort in Reddit-Foren, vor allem in dem Forum Wall Street Bets, Gamer und Leute, die sonst vorher nie mit Aktien zu tun hatten, die plötzlich anfingen und sagten, okay, wir haben den Hedgefonds, der wettet darauf, dass diese Aktie fällt. Wenn wir jetzt aber dafür sorgen, dass die Aktie im Wert steigt, dann geht nicht nur dessen Wette nicht auf, sondern dann macht er Riesenverluste. Wir können diesen Hedgefonds in den Ruin treiben und das kostet Milliarden am Ende. Und zugleich können wir den Kurs von GameStop nach oben pushen. Und die Aktie lag erst mal bei 3, 4, 5 Dollar und ist dann ja durch die Decke gegangen, war dann bei, ich glaube, 400 Dollar oder was oder ist noch höher dann gegangen. Dann hat Robinhood über diese App, eine Broker-App ist das vor allem organisiert worden, plötzlich den Kauf von GameStop-Aktien untersagt. Dann konnte man das einfach nicht mehr machen, sondern man konnte nur noch verkaufen. Das heißt, damit wurde dieser Kurssprung dann plötzlich gestoppt und davon haben selbstverständlich die Hedgefonds-Manager dann profitiert, insofern, als sie nicht noch mehr Verluste hatten. Und darum geht es selbstverständlich auch bei dem Kongress, wer hat da eigentlich wem zugeschussert, hat da Robinhood eigenmächtig gehandelt oder hatten die auch noch Geldgeber im Hintergrund? Citadel spielt da eine gewisse Rolle, das, muss man sagen, wird in diesen fünf Stunden nicht richtig aufgedröset. Das gibt es halt viele Lügen oder vieles, was nicht gesagt wird. Das wird die Zeit erst mal zeigen. Interessant ist mehr so diese grundsätzliche Debatte darüber. Und wir haben jetzt gerade den Republikaner gehört und der hat jetzt noch mal seine Vision hier, wie er sich das eigentlich vorstellt, welches Teilhabe-Potenzial doch in so was liegt, dass jetzt jeder ganz einfach mit Aktien handeln kann.
Ist es dir ein Wunder, warum die unheiligen Dynamiken des GameStop passieren?
Warum bezahlen wir nicht einfach die Leute mit Aktienoptionen?
Das ist nochmal die ganz alte Reagan- und Thatcher-Ideologie, die hier durchkommt. Dort hat man das ja gesagt, wenn wir alle Leute zu Aktionären machen, dann profitieren auch alle davon. Das Problem nur ist immer dabei, ja, Aktionär sein heißt dann auch, dass man zugleich an dem Ast sägt, auf dem man sitzt. Ja, also natürlich profitiert ein Unternehmen davon, wenn Lohnkosten gesenkt werden, wenn Leute entlassen werden, nur ist dann plötzlich der Aktionär derjenige, der auch noch der Arbeiter ist und der bekommt dann keinen Job mehr, hat aber noch die Aktie und hat dann so Teil an dem Erfolg des Unternehmens. Also man sieht schon, wie sich da die Katze in den Schwanz beißt. Und Patrick McHenry aber möchte keine Regulierungen und verweist da auf einen historischen Fall.
Ich gehe mal davon aus, damals gab es allgemeine Überlegungen und Gesetzgebungen, die nicht nur bei Apple anschlugen, sondern so grundsätzlich. Und jetzt nimmt das hier einfach Apple daraus.
Und das ist auch eine Illusion zu glauben. Es gibt keine Regulierung oder nicht mehr Regulierung, sondern alles pust ja schon auf Regulierung. Das heißt, es gibt nie irgendetwas, was im luftleeren Raum entsteht, sondern alles, was an der Börse passiert, ist im Rahmen von Regulierung. Die Frage ist nur, wie diese Regulierungen geschaffen sind. Wie kann es sein, dass da manche Leute ganz, ganz reich werden durch gewisse Konstruktionen? Also ich will es mal ganz beispielhaft machen. Diese Hedgefonds-Geschichte, dass man sich Aktien leihen kann, die einem nicht gehören, kann dann spekulieren mit diesen Aktien, kann die dann zu einem gewissen Termin wieder zurückzahlen, hat dann so eine Hebelwirkung drin. All diese Dinge, die dann dafür sorgen, dass man mit so einem Hedgefonds-Geschäft, George Soros hat das ja Anfang der 90er gezeigt, eine Milliarde verdienen kann. Also von jetzt auf gleich. Das ist ja etwas, was rechtlich hergestellt wurde. Das heißt, dieses Recht ist eines, das man verändern kann, das aber auch erst mal so gesetzt wurde, und da sind Regularien. Nehmen wir mal an, wir hätten jetzt zwischen uns beiden die Idee, könnten wir irgendwie Steuern sparen. Und jetzt würde es ein Gesetz geben oder eine Regel geben, die sagt, ja, wenn du mir dein Gehalt überweist, ich überweis dir meines, dann müssen wir beide keine Steuern zahlen. Wir müssen das nur einfach mal so hin und her transferieren. Dann würden wir das sofort machen. Wir wären dumm, wenn wir das nicht machen würden. Und genau solche Möglichkeiten existieren am Aktienmarkt. Die existieren für normale Leute nicht. Dann guckt man, dass auch wirklich jede Quittung stimmt. Und jetzt kommen diese Kandidaten hier zu Wort. Ich habe mal eine nicht mit reingenommen. Das ist nämlich eine Dame vom Cato-Institut. Und Cato-Institut ist halt ein sehr neoliberales Wirtschaftsinstitut, die dann so ein bisschen erklärt, wie das alles läuft. Aber das ist nicht weiter interessant. Und ich dachte auch, warum das Cato-Institut jetzt noch mal hier zu Gehör bringen. Dagegen ist ja Hans-Werner-Sinn-Sozialist. Und deswegen hören wir jetzt erst mal Vlad Teneff. Das ist der Gründer dieser App, Robin Hood, wie der in die Sache einsteigt.
Ich war in Bulgarien geboren, ein Land mit einem finanziellen System, das auf dem Weg von Verlust war. Als ich fünf Jahre alt war, habe ich mit meiner Familie in die Amerika in die Suche einer besseren Leben.
Finanzmöglichkeit für alle zu demokratisieren, hat eine sehr spezielle Signifikanz für mich. Die Plattform ermöglicht Menschen, von allen Hintergründen zu investieren, mit keinen Accountminimums und zero Kommissions. Also diese Leute, die da immer als Unternehmenschef vorgeladen werden, die haben irgendwie alle den gleichen Berater, denn die kommen alle mit ihren Kindheitserzählungen. Ganz genau, wir werden das jetzt gleich noch hören. Und dann erzählen die was von vor 20 Jahren. Also sie beantworten einfach keine Fragen. Aber wir haben hier nochmal jetzt dieses Bild, das natürlich den Republikanern gut gefällt. Der amerikanische Traum, Partizipation für alle. Jetzt können wir alle an den Aktienmarkt bringen. Man muss immer dazu sagen, was ist jetzt dieser Vorteil von Robinhood? Es ist sehr einfach und es ist sehr billig. Wer jetzt bei einem normalen Online-Broker ist, muss ja pro Transaktion eine Gebühr zahlen. Die ist oft so 9 Euro oder 15 Euro teuer. Das heißt, wenn man dort mit 50, 60 Euro rumspielen will, dann lohnt sich das nicht. Dann kriegt man nie den Betrag daraus. Aber bei diesen Apps kostet es nichts, beziehungsweise es kostet Daten und dann vielleicht doch noch ein paar andere Dinge. Aber es ist zumindest die Einstiegshürde sehr, sehr niedrig. Und das macht er ja nochmal deutlich. Jetzt hören wir Gabriel Plotkin. Der ist der Typ von Melvin Capital. Das ist jetzt der Gründer dieses Hedgefonds. Und wie steigt er wohl ein?
Ich bin in einer mittelklassigen Familie in Portland, Maine. Ich habe Melvin genannt, nachdem mein Vater eine Konvenienzstour anbringte.
Ich finde aber immer noch ungeschlagen. Ist Jeff Bezos mit diesem, ich bin in einer reichen Familie aufgewachsen, allerdings nicht reich an Geld, sondern nur reich an Liebe.
Ja, und er hat diese Werte, Disziplin, harte Arbeit, die bringt er jetzt in seinem Hedgefonds. Es ist selbstverständlich alles Quatsch. Also ich glaube, dass der Mann eine harte Arbeit hat. Der wird sicherlich mehr als 40 Stunden Woche haben. Er wird aber auch schon Milliardär vermutlich sein. Und was ich hinzufügen möchte, er sorgt dafür, dass so Leute wie seine Familie keine Existenzchance mehr in Zukunft haben werden. Und da ist nichts mit harte Arbeit. Aber er bringt hier dieses Bild von der schönen Kindheit und von den Werten, die man vermittelt bekommt. Und auch nochmal, dass er Familienvater ist. Das ist das klassische Narrativ aus jedem Hollywood-Film. Aber er ist doch ein Vater, so als sei das irgendetwas, was dann alles andere wettmacht. Und jetzt kommt Keith Jill. Er ist derjenige, der gesagt hat, da steckt Potenzial doch eigentlich in GameStop. Und wenn wir uns da mal ein bisschen organisieren, oder wenn ich darüber zumindest poste und schreibe in Reddit-Foren, dann kann das was geben. Und er ist da auch zu Gast.
Ich bin nur ein Individuell, dessen Investitionen in GameStop und Posten auf Social Media sind aufgrund meiner eigenen Forschung und Analyse basiert. Meine Familie war nicht wöchig. Mein Vater war Fahrer und meine Mutter eine registrierte Nurse. Ich war einer der drei Kinder und der erste in meiner Familie, um einen vierjährigen Schulabschluss zu erzielen, als ich 2009 aus Stonehill College begonnen habe.
Jo, da trifft sich die Unterschicht und verhandelt die wichtigen Fragen.
Ganz genau. Und er ist sicherlich so ein Working-Class-Hero, also dass er sich da jetzt durch diese Tätigkeiten in Reddit-Foren so hoch katapultiert hat, dass er rechtzeitig die Aktien kaufte. Er scheint aber auch ein bisschen Kapital gehabt zu haben, denn es reicht ja jetzt nicht, große Gewinne zu machen, wenn man nur 500 Euro investiert. Da muss ein bisschen mehr auch auf der hohen Kante liegen. Aber bei ihm ist diese Kindheitserzählung sicherlich noch eine, die ja in diesem Zusammenhang auch eine gewisse Authentizität gibt. Bei den anderen ist das eher Kulisse. Aber das hindert selbstverständlich die Republikaner nicht, das noch mal aufzugreifen. Was Tenev da erzählt hat, aus Bulgarien kommt der, da bekommt doch French Hill feuchte Augen. Ja, da weiß man gar nicht, was man sagen soll. Es ist ja so, dass wir es hier mit einer App zu tun haben, die dafür sorgt, dass jetzt ganz, ganz viele Leute an die Börse gehen und eine App, die einfach beschlossen hat, ja gut, jetzt habt ihr das mal da an der Börse ausprobiert mit dem GameStop, aber das wird uns jetzt hier zu bunt. Wir sind eben ein proprietärer Markt und können deshalb auch jetzt darüber befinden, ihr dürft nicht weitermachen.
So ein bisschen. Also die waren ja auch wirklich in Zugzwang bei Robinhood, denn die haben ja ein neues Geschäftsmodell entwickelt, in dem sie sagen, wir selber sind so eine Art Marktplatz, auf dem man dann tätig werden kann als Käufer von kleinen Aktienpaketen, für die das dann kostenlos ist. Dadurch werden diejenigen, die die Aktien tatsächlich kaufen, zum Produkt in diesem klassischen Sinne, dass man deren Verhalten auswertet. Das kennen wir ja. In den Börsen brauchen sie ganz viele soziale Signale. Da wird ja auch Twitter gelesen und Facebook. Und dann werden danach diese kleinen Investmententscheidungen getroffen. Und deren Vermutung ist einfach, die Leute, die über uns Aktien kaufen, werden sich schon irgendwas dabei gedacht haben. Also aggregieren wir einfach mal deren Verhalten und werten das selber aus. Und wenn wir da sehen, die gehen alle in eine Richtung, dann nutzen wir das mal für uns, reignen Investitionsentscheidungen. Und damit es zu diesem Verhalten kommt, kostet es nichts. Machen wir es für die Leute kostenlos. Dadurch ist aber Robin Hood selber als Finanzakt-Teilnehmer auf dem Markt, also am echten Börsenmarkt dann beteiligt, indem sie nämlich das Geld von dem einzelnen Nutzer nehmen, einkassieren und dann damit am Aktienmarkt die Aktien kaufen, die bestellt wurden. Was bedeutet, dass wenn sie 10 Uhr 10er Order kriegen für eine Game-Stock-Aktie und dann kriegen sie die 200 Dollar und dann kostet die aber 10 Uhr 2 oder 10 Uhr 12 schon 50 Dollar mehr, dann muss Robin Hood diesen Mehrbetrag, der allein über die Zeit entstanden ist, auffangen. Und das konnten sie dem Clearing House, das dann das Aktiengeschäft tatsächlich macht, nicht mehr rechtfertigen, sondern die haben dann Robin Hood die Auflage gegeben. Also ihr könnt jetzt hier nicht einfach für so und so viel Milliarden plötzlich Game-Stalk-Aktien kaufen, weil ihr braucht ja selber erstmal eine Sicherheit, dass ihr den Kauf dann auch wirklich machen könnt, denn wenn ihr hier 10 Uhr 10 Milliarden bekommt und ihr müsst aber 10 Uhr 5 plötzlich 11 Milliarden bezahlen, weil der Kurs in der Zeit so hoch gestiegen ist, dann hat Robin Hood einfach gesagt, okay, wir müssen ja mal die Reißleine ziehen und uns selber sozusagen in Sicherheit bringen. Wir können diese Volatilität nicht mehr abarbeiten, weil wir einfach das finanzielle Polster dafür gar nicht haben, das wir eventuell brauchen. Sonst werden wir selber ausgeschlossen. Also sonst sagt einfach das Pflegenhaus, also die Börse selbst, also bei dir sind wir uns nicht so sicher, ob das alles gelingt. Wir nehmen dich dann mal lieber raus. Und deswegen kamen die selber, in Zug zwangern mussten das dann dann reglementieren. Allerdings war der Move dann so, dass sie einfach gesagt haben, okay, jetzt kriegt einfach jeder kann nur noch eine Aktie kaufen und nicht mehr 100. Und dann kam natürlich AOC gleich auf den Plan, in sozusagen Schulterschluss mit Ted Cruz und so weiter, wo sie meinten, die Kleinen dürfen jetzt nicht rausgenommen werden. Also es war sozusagen auch so eine PR-Geschichte, dass das so in die Richtung dann gedreht wurde. Wahrscheinlich liegt die Wahrheit irgendwo dazwischen.
Und Tenif streitet das in der Anhörung, ich habe die Clips jetzt nicht rausgenommen, streitet das ja ab, dass es irgendwelche finanziellen Schwierigkeiten gibt, was er wahrscheinlich muss. Also er versucht das immer zu umgehen, selbstverständlich. Also das, was du da gerade geschildert hast, dieses Szenario. Zugleich hätten sie aber auch von niemanden einen Druck von außen bekommen. Also das ist sehr, sehr dubios, was da eigentlich passiert.
Genau, er war noch in einem Gespräch zugeschaltet mit Elon Musk bei Clubhouse. Also Elon Musk wurde in einem Clubhouse-Gespräch eingeladen und da kam dann auch er als Robin Hood-Chef dazu. Und dann hat Elon Musk ihn halt so ein bisschen lockerer gefragt, komm, sag uns, was los war und so weiter. Dann erklärt er so, wie das so funktioniert. Es sind ja drei Robin Hood-Unternehmen, die das dann untereinander und so weiter und so fort. Und bei dem einen kann man halt Aktien kaufen und das andere ist dann am Markt tätig. Und dann wird das da so hin und her geschoben. Und da stellt er so ein bisschen da, wie tricky das einfach so insgesamt ist. Weil du machst so ein kleines Unternehmen, denkst so, na ja, pro Kunde sind das irgendwie 500 Euro, die hier umgesetzt werden. Wenn man das alles schnell genug abwickeln, dann kommt es auch nicht zu großen Abitragezwängen, die uns da plötzlich aufkommen. Und plötzlich wollten die Leute aber so, so viel Game-Stalk, und zwar alle, über Robinhood kaufen, dass quasi nur noch das ganze Geschäftsbegangen von Robinhood daran bestand, möglichst schnell Game-Stalk-Aktien zu kaufen. Und dadurch ist der Preis so schnell nach oben gegangen, dass sie gar nicht selber so schnell hinterherkaufen konnten, wie sie den Leuten versprochen haben, dass sie es ohne Gebühren usw. machen konnten. Und na ja, es brachte doch einige in Zugzwang. Also in der Ansicht hat das auch noch mal so eine kleine Schwachstelle da aufgezeigt in diesen neuen Geschäftsmodellen, diesen Fintech-Kram. Das muss man ja sagen, das ist ja alles so ein Fintech-Spielplatzzeug.
Ja, Spielzeug, da kommen wir gleich zu. Wir machen noch mal gerade einen Turn, denn das ist sicherlich das große Problem bei der Angelegenheit, bei dieser Anhörung, dass niemand eigentlich so richtig versteht, wie das mit dem Aktienmarkt funktioniert. Jetzt kommt mal ganz symptomatisch ein Demokrat zu Wort, der etwas sagt. Und dann müssen wir das wirklich mal kritisch in den Blick nehmen.
Genau, das ist vollkommener Unsinn, denn es sind immer solche Informationen. Wenn jetzt der Daimler-Chef heute irgendwie liegt oder selbst an die Presse geht, wie auch immer, dass dann den Leuten untergejubelt wird, ja, wir kaufen NIO auf oder NIO kauft uns auf, dann haben wir oder wir haben, Entschuldigung, das ging ja schon zu weit, wenn er sagen würde, wir haben Interesse an NIO, dann würde man sofort sehen, wie der Aktienkurs sich entwickelt. Das heißt, es ist immer nur die Reaktion auf eine Information oder auf eine Erwartung oder eine Hoffnung, die in irgendeiner Weise genährt wird. Und das ist jetzt unerheblich, ob jetzt da der CEO eine Pressekonferenz gibt oder ob irgendjemand etwas twittert. Das macht dann vielleicht die Masse der Tweets dann am Ende aus. Aber man kann ja auch sagen, es war ja richtig. Also es ist ja nicht so, dass alle getwittert und gepostet haben, die GameStop Aktie lohnt sich und dann ist nichts passiert, sondern die haben das geschrieben und die GameStop Aktie ging tatsächlich nach oben. Und das ist der Effekt. Und dann gibt es diese Ideologie, dass das mit der realen Wirtschaft nicht mehr zusammenhängt. Ich habe das ja eben genannt. Bei Tesla sprechen wir von einer Marktkapitalisierung von 700 Milliarden, bei Daimler von 65 Milliarden. Das hat auch nichts mit Realwirtschaft in dem Sinne zu tun. Das ist nicht daran geknüpft, wie viele Autos werden produziert und der hat die beste Aktie. Dann wäre ja Daimler ganz klar vor Tesla. Es ist aber nicht der Fall. Bei den ganzen Start-ups sieht es vollkommen anders aus, wenn man sich sieht, wie rot da die Zahlen sind, die geschrieben werden. Das heißt, diese Idee, dass es um eine reale Wirtschaftsleistung geht, die an der Börse abgebildet wird, das ist vollkommener Unsinn. Und das wird hier nur in einer sehr amüsanten Form sichtbar. Aber der Effekt ist ja keineswegs neu.
Vor allem, wann ist Facebook an die Börse gegangen? Keine Ahnung, seit 2009 oder 2010? Irgendwann relativ, nee, 2011, 2012. Die haben erst Instagram für eine Milliarde gekauft. Da haben die Leute gezeigt, das kann durchaus mal einen Milliardenbetrag wert sein. Und dann sind sie selber an die Börse gegangen für unglaublich viel. Sie haben sich vorher schon an Microsoft-Arteile verkauft, wo dann Facebook so klar war, die sind 15 Milliarden wert. Und alle so, eh ist das, hat Microsoft hier nicht ein bisschen viel bezahlt. Die haben damals irgendwie 2, 3% für irgendwas gekauft. Und am Ende hieß es, das gibt so einen Gesamtrahmen von 15 Milliarden. Jetzt ist Facebook um die 500 Milliarden wert. Und die eigentliche Kennziffer, das Kurs-Gewinn-Verhältnis, was ja immer so zu ganz alten Zeiten so ausschlaggebend war. Also ich habe Aktien und wie viel Unternehmensgewinn gibt es eigentlich und fällt dann als Dividende ab und so. Das fällt ja völlig aus dem Rahmen, aber jetzt schon seit Jahrzehnten. Während das in Deutschland immer noch so gemächlich, dass ja von 60 Milliarden Börsenwert bei, keine Ahnung, 40 Milliarden Umsatz oder so bei Mercedes, ja, das ist fast 1 zu 1. Und bei Facebook ist das so 1 zu 15, 1 zu 20, 1 zu 30. Also da Facebook hat ja noch lange keinen zweistelligen Milliardenbetrag Umsatz, Umsatz, nicht mal Gewinn, Umsatz gemacht. Und da war der Kurs schon über 100 Milliarden. Also in der Ansicht fällt das ja schon seit Ewigkeiten auseinander, dass irgendwelche materiellen, wie er das eben sagte, materiellen Grundlagen ausschlaggebend sind für irgendwelche Börsenkurse. Und das recht nicht seit diesem Frequency, High Frequency, High Frequency Trading, seit es diesen Hochfrequenzhandel gibt, wo es eh alles, wo kleinste Kursbewegungen ausreichen und die nicht materiell versichert werden müssen, sondern wo einfach nur die Kursbewegungen selbst ausgenutzt werden. Und da kommt es natürlich nur auf Informationen an.
Und das ist sehr, sehr schade, wenn man sich diese ganze Anhörung einmal zu Gemüte führt, dass so sehr immer noch diese Idee, die reale Wirtschaft, die bildet sich ab in Börsenkursen. Und man muss noch hinzufügen, auch die reale Wirtschaft hat etwas sehr Spekulatives. Das heißt, das ist hochspekulativ, was Kelenius da jetzt gerade macht, mit Daimler zu sagen, bis 2028 müssen wir auch die S-Klasse nur noch als E-Auto anbieten. Er spekuliert darauf, dass das auch der Wunsch der Konsumenten sein wird. Er spekuliert darauf, dass das technisch möglich sein wird. Er spekuliert auf so vieles. Also auch die Realwirtschaft hat eine hochspekulative Seite. Das darf man auch nicht immer so ganz klar voneinander trennen.
Ja, VW möchte alle Autos elektrisch verkaufen. VW verkauft 10 Milliarden Autos im Jahr. Das heißt, am Ende 10 Millionen Elektroautos. VW hat also 2018 mehr, also vertraglich festgehalten, mehr Batterien auf dem Weltmarkt gekauft, als der Weltmarkt überhaupt herstellen konnte. Sondern die sind einfach damit rein und haben gesagt, werdet ihr schon liefern können dann in zwei Jahren, oder? Das machen wir hier mal. Das ist wie Impfstoff kaufen. Als es so heißt, ey, könnte funktionieren. Gleich mal eine Milliarde kaufen. Gleich mal den Vertrag. So macht, also das ist gängige Praxis. VW kauft so Batterien. Und dann muss man halt gucken, ob die Struktur der Semantik mithält. Ob da die Wetter aufgeht oder nicht.
Gaming. Sprechen wir mal darüber in Bezug auf die Börse. Das scheint ja das wirklich Revolutionäre daran zu sein. Nicht, dass jetzt einfach nur Kleine mit traden können, sondern diese Gamification der Börse. Das ist etwas, was wir im Blick behalten müssen. Denn das sorgt dafür, dass ganz, ganz viele mitmachen. Wir hatten ja in den vergangenen Monaten immer wieder die Thematisierung von Glücksspiel. Böhmermann hatte da auch was zugemacht. Und wir sehen auch, wie da die Lobby, zum Beispiel bei der FDP, sehr erfolgreich war, dass es solche Ausnahmebundesländer gibt. Glücksspiel wird immer wichtiger, Sportwetten werden immer wichtiger. Wir sprachen mal darüber, dass Disney da investiert. Die Bild-Zeitung hat doch immer ihren Wett-Opa oder wie der heißt, der dann sagt, so sind die Sportwetten am Wochenende, das muss man machen. Man sieht, da wird sehr viel Sucht produziert. Und hier sind wir jetzt eigentlich auf einer neuen Stufe angelangt.
Wie ich in meinem ersten Statement erwähnt habe, haben Robinhood-Komplizierte über 35 Billionen Dollar in unrealisierten und realisierten Waren im Begriff ihrer Erhöhungen. Absolut, es ist Investieren und es ist eine building-building.
Ich glaube, es ist eine Möglichkeit für Investoren, in den Markt zu teilnehmen, so wie Institutionen teilnehmen.
Funny Money. Ich glaube, es gilt die Logik. Wir haben jetzt mal gesehen, wie der Börsenhandel da funktioniert. Nur weil mehr Leute teilnehmen, heißt das nicht, dass da irgendwelche Spielregeln geändert wurden, sondern so funktioniert es halt.
Ganz genau. Und erinnerst du dich noch an Uli Hoeneß, der doch damals auch bei seiner Steuerhinterziehung davon fragte, ja, das war halt Spielgeld. Es waren bei ihm halt ein paar Millionen, er hat das nicht jetzt mit ein paar hundert gemacht. Und dann die Reaktion von Beckenbauer auch darauf. Ja, ich kenne den Uli, er ist ja schon ein Schlamper. Da sind einfach mal so ein paar Millionen unter den Tisch gefallen. Also das hat sich gar nicht so verändert. Aber das App-Design, das lädt zum Spielen ein. Das macht jetzt Nidia M. Velasquez deutlich im Gespräch mit Teneff.
Natürlich verstehen viele von uns, dass das Investieren kein Wandel ist und eine wesentliche Risik hat.
Wir kennen ja solche Äußerungen auch von anderen Social-Media-Plattformen, wenn dann immer wieder gesagt wird, wir sind da ganz verantwortlich, und wir wollen nur Möglichkeiten bieten. Und dann ist es ja auch üblich, dass man noch irgendeine Kampagne macht. Aufklärung, Bildung, das ist ja so wichtig. Jetzt ist ja herausgekommen, dass die Frau unseres Bundespräsidenten Schirmherrin ist bei dieser komischen Facebook-Social-Washing-Veranstaltung. Wie heißt das? Hero? Social Media Hero? Sie ist da die Schirmherrin und Facebook engagiert sich da. Und auch Robin Hood, erklärt jetzt Teneff, möchte sehr viel dafür tun, dass wir was begreifen, wie die Finanzmärkte funktionieren. Wirtschaftsaufklärung.
How do we make long-term investing accessible for people around the country? And we're making huge investments in education and customer support to support that.
Ganz, ganz furchtbar. Aber du siehst das jetzt hier auch in Deutschland. Dort gibt es ja auch schon so Finanz-Apps und die holen sich jetzt alle Influencer ins Boot. Und die sitzen dann auch da und sagen dann Ja, ich zeige euch jetzt mal, wie ich so investiere. Und es gibt ja auch die und die Möglichkeiten. Und dann wird dann 18-Jährigen auch schon gesagt, jetzt nimmt man euer Taschengeld und investiert jetzt mal da. Und das sind diese Finanz-Apps. Das ist ja so eine Blase, die sich die ganze Zeit in Berlin da rumtreibt.
Ja, ich glaube, an diesem Fall hier wird auch Friedrich Merz zugehört haben. Dann, ah, hier haben wir die Chance verpasst. Wir hätten da so eine hippe App, wo da so ein Info-Reiter, da steht noch mal drin, wie toll so Index-Dinger sind, weißt du, so iShares oder so. Dann direkt mal die BlackRock-Dinger da raushauen.
Ja, die Demokraten sind da selbstverständlich ein bisschen klüger, auch wenn sie vielleicht nicht so ganz die Börsenmechanismen verstehen, was sehr schade ist, was man auch viel stärker politisieren müsste. Das prendet aber in Deutschland auch nicht statt. Jetzt ist ja gerade Fabio Di Masi noch weggegangen. Damit ist jetzt auf der linken Seite fast kein Verständnis mehr für finanzpolitisches da, ich glaube, das kann man ganz drastisch so sagen.
Ich will seinen Brief mal schon reservieren für den Salon.
Machst du das?
Falls du den vor...
Ja, okay, dann mach du das. Ein sehr, sehr guter Brief, unbedingt müssen wir darüber sprechen. Aber die Demokraten haben zumindest verstanden, na ja, Partizipation, da hängt es ja vielleicht auch an etwas anderem noch.
Aber Leute, die Zugang zu den Stockmarketten haben, sind gut, aber wenn sie nicht Geld haben, um zu investieren, dann ist es wirklich nicht Demokratisierung. Und das ist der echte Grund, warum 80% der Stockmarkette von 10% der Menschen gewohnt sind.
Nur, ja, das kann man, wenn man Geld hat, dann kann man selbstverständlich profitieren. Das ist aber genauso, wenn ich sage, ich kaufe mir jetzt mal zehn Eigentumswohnungen in Berlin, dann werde ich sehr davon profitieren. Aber ich brauche halt diese Startkapital, um sie mir leisten zu können. Und das wird vollkommen aus dem Blick genommen. Und wir wissen ja gerade, wie viele Menschen schon in finanzielle Schieflagen geraten, wenn die Waschmaschine kaputtgeht und dann vielleicht auch noch das Auto irgendwas Neues braucht. Dann funktioniert es schon nicht mehr. Und die können nicht mal gerade noch ein bisschen mit Spielgeld rumhantieren. Denn wenn sie es dann flüssig machen müssen, ist vielleicht gerade der Kurs unten. Und dann hat man ein großes Problem, während diese Leute natürlich einen langen Atem haben und warten können. Und jetzt haben wir schon mal, ich glaube, es war, als wir über The Social Dilemma gesprochen haben, beziehungsweise den einen Protagonisten, der bei Facebook gearbeitet hat und der sagte, ja, man arbeitet da mit Kognitionswissenschaftlern, mit Psychologen und so weiter zusammen, um so eine süchtig machende Funktion herzustellen. Und das finden wir jetzt bei Robin Hood auch wieder. Auch darauf kommen natürlich die Demokraten.
Und so weiter.
So wird jetzt noch verrückter. Wir haben da Confetti. Confetti knallt da, wenn da Transaktionen gemacht werden.
Es kann natürlich sein, dass sie einfach nur andere Apps nachgebaut haben und dann später ihnen gesagt wurde, das ist übrigens alles Gamification.
Es ist möglich, wenn du seine Frisur siehst, könnte das sein. Jetzt geht noch ein Schritt weiter.
According to a memo from the Financial Services Committee, there's one feature in particular that encourages retail investors to tap on the Robinhood app up to a thousand times a day in order to improve their position on the waitlist for Robinhood highly coveted cash management feature. Das ist für mich ein Sign von Erdbewegung.
Es ist ganz furchtbar und ja, das ist von dieser App zu halten. Wir können das im Blick behalten, wenn wir an die deutschen Produkte denken, die ähnlich operieren und das ist sicherlich der falscheste Weg, sich mit der Börse auseinanderzusetzen. Dazu kann ich nur auffordern, denn es ist nicht nur sehr interessant, sondern ich glaube, das ist eigentlich das, wo man jetzt politisch dringend was verändern muss und davon würde man auch profitieren und zwar alle würden davon profitieren, aber wenn wir jetzt einen solch spielerischen Umgang damit bekommen, in einer Weise, dass wir abhängig werden jetzt noch von was Neuem, dass es nicht nur darum geht permanent zu gucken, wie viel Likes habe ich bei Instagram, sondern auch noch permanent ins Portfolio zu gucken, dann sind wir auf einem guten Weg dorthin, dass eigentlich diese Transferierung des Kapitals von unten nach oben fröhlich weiterläuft, aber man zugleich noch diese Illusion bekommt, dass wir auch Teil dieser großen Entwicklung sind, dass wir partizipieren.
Ja, ja, ja, das ist ein Drama, aber ihr habt ja Wohlstand für alle, auch alle abonniert. Ihr haltet uns ja da auf dem Laufenden.
Ja, hoffentlich.
So, was wir hier mal brauchen, ist, glaube ich, ein ordentlicher Krieg. Ich meine jetzt nicht so eine Föhtort-Diskussion zum Thema, das ist aber irgendwie schlecht, wie das Robinhood so macht, wie die Leute da rein getrickst werden und tausendmal am Tag auf irgendwelche Buttons klicken, damit sie irgendeine Debitcard kriegen oder so, sondern einen anständigen Krieg brauchen wir. Beispielsweise vom Betriebssystem gegen solche Apps. Wer stellt Betriebssysteme her? Apple stellt zum Beispiel Betriebssysteme her. Wer macht solche Apps, die funktionieren wie Robinhood? Facebook zum Beispiel, die haben damit angefangen. Die Gamifizierung, die Kalkulierung, wie viele Likes kriege ich, wann bin ich berühmt, wann bin ich cool, wann bin ich ein toller Influencer und so weiter. Und wir wissen, Facebook funktioniert auch wie Robinhood. Da kommt es auf das Verhalten an, das wird ausgewertet, man wird dann vermarktet als Angucker von Werbung und so weiter und so fort. Und wer hätte es gedacht? Der Krieg ist ja längst da, dieser Krieg. Und ich sage ausdrücklich Krieg, der ist ja längst da. Wir hören uns mal warm in das Thema Facebook gegen Apple. Und wir hängen es dann vor allem auf an einer Rede, die Tim Cook gehalten hat im Rahmen einer Konferenz, die nicht weiter von Relevanz ist. Aber diese kleine Rede, die eine Viertelstunde geht, die er natürlich remote wegen Corona aus seinem Büro ausgesendet hat, die hat es doch in sich. Vorher aber, worum geht es hier? Wir kolliken uns mal wild durch YouTube. Hier zum Beispiel bei Tech Vision, wo er am 26.12. als ich so langsam anbahnte, hier ist doch etwas, eine kleine Einstimmung auf die Privacy Wars eingesprochen. Es klingt ein bisschen komisch, aber ich glaube, so macht man YouTube heute.
This month the battle for control over our online data reached boiling point, with a pair of titans making power moves, hoping to secure access to it over the coming years. So today we're strapping on our flak jackets and wading onto the battlefield so we can examine the so-called Privacy War kicking off right now between Apple and Facebook. From next year, whenever Facebook updates its app, users will be asked to opt in to its Information Harvesting Program on a data point by data point basis. That means you, as an iPhone user, will be asked specifically if you're happy for Facebook to continue collecting data on your specific whereabouts, say, or your spending habits or your marriage or status.
So bisher fließen ja die Daten frei. Du trägst deine Daten ins Facebook-Profil ein, die werden dann aus der App übertragen, nach und so weiter. Jetzt schaltet sich das Betriebssystem dazwischen, möchte es jedenfalls, über die Details gleich, und sagt Name, Datum, also Geburtstatum, Beziehungsstatus und so weiter. Da haben wir doch noch mal einen Finger drauf. In der Hinsicht, dass wir den Finger dem Nutzer noch mal zugestehen, der nämlich sagen kann, willst du diese Daten eigentlich auch übertragen, oder hast du die erstmal nur hier in deinem Profil eingetragen für dich? Welche Daten möchtest du eigentlich wirklich über unser iPhone jetzt rausgeschickt haben in die Welt? Apple mischt sich also eigentlich das Verhältnis zwischen Unternehmen und Nutzer und reagiert darauf, weil sie Angst haben, dass das alles verändert, denn wir wissen wie Apple, wie Facebook funktioniert, haben wir ja breit und quer hier verhandelt, die brauchen natürlich genau diese Signale, diese sozialen und verhaltenen Signale, um das an die Werbekunden weiter zu verhökern und dann einfach aufaggregiertes Publikum und so weiter zu verhökern. Also reagiert Facebook wie folgt ein bisschen angepisst mit Werbekampagnen.
Unsicherlich ist Facebook stark an dieser Verkundung auf seinen Weg und kämpft mit dem Gehör in einer sehr öffentlichen Faschion. Eher dieses Monat hat Facebook die vollen Anbieter in den Washington Post, die New York Times und die Wall Street Journal-Konzerne ausgeführt. According zum Anbieter, werden etwa 44% der kleinen oder medizine Businessen dieses Jahr ihre sozialen Medienabgabe erhöhen.
So Facebook hat jetzt eine Tagline Werbeanzeige Stand up for small eingedingst, denn sie sagen, wenn sich Apple als Betriebssystemanbieter einmischt in das Verhältnis von Facebook zu seinem Nutzer, dann ist das ja nicht wirklich das Verhältnis Facebook zum Nutzer, sondern Facebook zu anderen Facebook-Nutzern, beispielsweise Unternehmen, die als kleines Business irgendwie ihre Pizzeria, ihren Friseur oder was weiß ich da promoten, weil die verlieren ja dann Zugang zu dem Nutzer, weil der nicht mehr angibt.
Genau, die kaufen die Daten, sonst können die nicht vor Ort werben. Das nutzt ja nichts für die Pizzeria, wenn die in München ist und aber in Hamburg plötzlich wirbt.
Die Pizzeria will ja wissen, wo ich wohne und wie alt ich bin, ob es sich lohnt, mich anzuschreiben. Der Friseur will ja wissen, wie lang sind eigentlich meine Haare. Der will mein Profilbild mal sehen, sonst gibt es dieses Angebot nicht. Sonst bucht der nicht bei mir Werbung. Und das ist ja dann keine zielgerichtete Werbung mehr. Das ganze Social-Targeting funktioniert ja nicht mehr. Tim Cook jedenfalls twittert dazu, also wir sind ja immer noch so im Dezember. Genau genommen am 24. Dezember ist dieses folgende Video von Nate Schmidt bei YouTube publiziert. Wie hat Tim Cook sich eigentlich mal zu diesem ganzen Ding geäußert? Denn bisher ist das ja nur so ein, ja, keine Ahnung, Apple plant da irgendwas mit iOS 14.5, ist es glaube ich. Das kommt jetzt so im März, aber man weiß eigentlich noch nicht so viel.
So, what actually is this update? We believe users should have the choice over the data that is being collected about them and how it's used. Facebook can continue to track users across apps and websites as before.
So, und Tim Cook hat in diesem Tweet, der uns gerade vorgelesen wurde, noch mal diese kleine Meldung angefügt. Also man macht die Facebook-App auf, auf seinem iPhone, und dann kommt die Meldung, diese App, Facebook, track deine Activity, möchtest du das? Und dann kannst du einfach sagen, ja oder nein. Also entweder kannst du es erlauben oder nö, Facebook soll mich mal nicht tracken. So, und jetzt ist natürlich großes Rätselraten, wenn jetzt die ganzen, also erstens wie viele Leute sagen hier, nee, ich will nicht, dass Facebook mich trackt. Also ja, die dürfen so ein paar Profildaten haben, die ich selber eintrage, aber bei allem anderen sage ich mal, nö, nicht tracken bitte. Also weder meine Standorte Bescheid sagen im Sinne von, ich stehe jetzt gerade neben der Pizzeria oder sonst irgendwas. Und jetzt ist natürlich hier so ein gewisses Rätselraten.
Wie wird das uns als E-Commerce-Advertisers beeinflussen? Diese E-Mail von der AdLeaks Facebook Gruppe ist ein wirklich, wirklich starker Ressort für das Verständnis, wie es uns alle beeinflussen wird.
So, und da muss man schon mal sagen, Wolfgang und ich, wir sehen, wie dieser Brief aussieht. Wir wissen, wie Apple und Facebook kommunizieren, wenn sie was verhökern wollen. Das sind das tolle Webseiten, wo es richtig... Hier diese Sache, die klären doch die Unternehmen unter sich und da ist es halt wirklich einfach nur so ein Brief. Da muss man jetzt echt im Detail irgendwelche Briefe lesen, die halt... Aber es wird uns hier mal so ein bisschen vorgestellt.
Es sagt in kurzer Zeit, dass Apple in März 2021 mit dem mandatory Rollout von iOS 14 für alle Apple-Mobile-Fones ein Opt-in-Prompt für die Spieler auf jeder App für die Möglichkeit, 3-partige Sites, wie Facebook und andere sozialen Medien-Sites, zu beantragen, um ihre User-Data zu tracken. User-Data kann Dinge wie Konversionen, Website-Visitorien und Tracking entgegen, was Interesse-Targeten erfolgt, und ein paar andere Dinge. Von du.
So wir wissen zum Beispiel, wenn man bei Amazon was sucht, wertet Amazon 500 verschiedene Signale aus, wie schnell hat er gg scrollt, wo hat er was geklickt, was hat er sich vorher angeguckt und so weiter und so fort. Und jetzt sagt Apple, ihr dürft nur noch 8 solcher Signale verwenden. Jetzt müssen die Unternehmen erst überlegen, wie organisieren wir das, welche 8 und ja, wie also das ist jetzt ein richtiger Aufwand, sozusagen mit diesen Restriktionen plötzlich zurechtzukommen.
Lass mich eine Frage einwerfen. Was würdest du sagen, ist das primäre Interesse von Apple daran? Ist es zum einen nur auszubauen, eigene Werbekundschaft nochmal, also dass man in einer anderen Weise sie attestieren kann, wenn man sagt, wir machen es mit unseren Daten, also wir erheben weiterhin sehr viel mehr Daten als nur acht verschiedene Geschichten. Das ist ja die Möglichkeit. Das andere ist ja, das haben wir ja schon hier mehrmals herausgestellt, dass Apple als Unix-Selling-Point schon lange erkannt hat, Datenschutz, Privatsphäre sichern ist etwas ganz, ganz Entscheidendes. Und da waren die immer vorne dran. Und das versuchen sie jetzt noch mal stärker zu machen und versuchen damit auch noch mal ein ganz neues Verkaufsargument herzustellen. Wir sagen und guckt, wir schützen euch auch vor den Big-Tech-Konzernen, die ja zu Recht in der Kritik sind wegen Trump und all dem.
Du wirst gleich überrascht sein, was du für O-Töne bekommst, um diesen Fragen zu klären. Ich kann aber schon mal vermuten oder sagen, es ist zweiteres. Apple hat diesen Unix-Selling-Point erkannt, aber sie sind eben auch mit dem ersten gescheitert. Sie wollten selber Ad-Plattform werden und beispielsweise alle In-App-Ads, die man so hat, also alle Werbung, die in iPhones angezeigt wird, in Apps von jemanden, die jemand anderes herstellt, dass man das über Apple organisiert. Also man schreibt eine App und sagt dann einfach im Code, hier soll die Apple-Werbung angezeigt werden und dann kriegt Apple 30 Prozent und man selber kriegt 70 Prozent von diesem Umsatz, der da generiert wird. Das gelang aber nie. Apple hat es nie so richtig hinbekommen. Entweder waren die App-Schreiber gar nicht in der Lage, so richtig diesen Platz freizuräumen, dann hat die App die Werbung auch immer gestört. Dann war es für die App-Schreiber sehr viel attraktiver zu sagen, wir machen hier einfach mal so eine Werbung, die eigentlich nur so ein Platzhalter ist, die nerven soll, weil wir die Leute dann dazu bringen, zu sagen, für 5 Euro im Jahr oder so ist diese Werbung ausgeblendet, dass man diesen Weg dann ging. Also Apple hat versucht, daraus auch einen Markt für sich zu machen, ist damit gescheitert und geht jetzt einfach all in Privacy. Also es ist sozusagen eine funktionale, fast zynische Erklärung. Sie haben es halt nicht geschafft, auf dem Gebiet zu punkten. Deswegen sagen sie jetzt, da machen wir das grundsätzlich jetzt mal.
Machen wir den Laden dicht.
Wir ärgern jetzt auch mal die anderen, denen das gelangt. So ungefähr, kann man glaube ich schon sagen. So und bevor wir jetzt in diese Tim Cook-Räder einspringen, es wird existenziell, also diese Frage, die hier gestellt wird, ist ganz ernst so unter Facebook, also unter Leuten, die in dieser Wirtschaft da Geld verdienen und auf YouTube geklärt.
Das neue App-Tracking-Transparenz, das Apple implementiert, könnte wirklich sehr schlecht sein. Ich denke, dass es Facebook-Ads viel weniger effektiv machen könnte.
Ja, also die fragen sich ganz ernsthaft, ist das das Ende von Facebook? Wenn die jetzt auf iPhones mit Android-Nutzer verdienen, verdienen sie sowieso weniger. Also es ist ja schon mal ein tolles Signal zu sagen, jemand nutzt überhaupt ein iPhone. Das war ja schon mal einer, der richtig Wert brachte. So ein Nutzer, der hat iOS-Ticket nutzt, war ja immer viel mehr wert. So, und jetzt war Tim Cook Anfang Februar oder Mitte Februar in so einer Konferenz eingeladen, die nichts weiter zur Sache tut, denn er hat ein Video aufgenommen an seinem Schreibtisch und das gucken wir uns jetzt an. Es geht nur eine Viertelstunde und hat ungefähr 500.000 Views und es geht wie folgt los und ich bin fast vom Stuhl gefallen. So, und jetzt alle Hörer, seid ehrlich. Wer von euch hat gewusst, dass Tim Cook vor zwei Jahren 2019 im Europäischen Parlament war, um dort eine Rede über den Daten-Industriellen-Komplex zu halten?
Noch nie von gehört.
Ich auch nicht. Ich war ein bisschen überrascht.
Aber war die dann nicht öffentlich oder war das ein Hinterzimmertreffen?
Die gibt es auch bei YouTube und die hat auch 50.000 Views.
Ach ja.
Es ist wirklich erstaunlich. Also das ist wenig, meine ich. Es ist ein Europa-Parlament, ja, hat Tim Cook also wirklich die wichtigste Industrie der Welt, hat einen Marktführer und dessen Chef steht in Brüssel und redet dort von Daten-Industriellen-Komplex. Und wir erinnern jetzt nur kurz an den militärisch-industrieren Komplex Eisenhower und so weiter. Die große Warnung, irgendwann wird der amerikanische Verteidigungsversatz halt 700 Milliarden wert sein. Und das haben wir heute alles, Kriege überall auf der Welt und so weiter und so fort. Also wir hören mal kurz rein in diese Rede Tim Cook von vor zwei Jahren im Europaparlament.
Wahnsinn, dass das nicht rezipiert wurde, wie kann das nur sein? Ja, da könnte alles einpacken, ne? Ja, in einer Klarheit, das hätte ein Schirmacher zustande gebracht, aber sonst doch kaum einer.
Ja, es ist wirklich ganz erstaunlich, Tim Cook steht da und sagt, Daten sind nicht das neue Öl, sondern die neuen Waffen. Wir haben es hier mit einer Industrie zu tun, die mit militärischer Präzension versucht, den kleinsten Vorteil für sich rauszuholen und damit alle Kosten auf sich nimmt, und sei es die Zerstörung der ganzen sozialen Welt.
Und auch so schön deutlich macht, die sind für sich genommen harmlos. Aber dann als Bündel.
Genau, dieses große Aber. Das lässt nicht das Silicon Valley darüber bestimmen, was da passiert. Sondern hier, das ist mal so richtig all in. Und der Ansicht kann man auch so ein bisschen jetzt verstehen, das ist echt der Krieg. Das ist wie der Autokrieg zwischen Deutschland und China und so weiter. Das ist richtiger Wirtschaftskrieg, der hier innerhalb des Silicon Valleys ausgetragen wird zwischen Apple und Facebook. Und diese Rede, wir kommen jetzt zurück ins aktuelle Februar 2021. Tim Cook sitzt also da und er redet hier mal über Facebook. Er nennt natürlich Facebook nicht beim Namen. Das ist indirekt, aber wir wissen ja, wie sowas funktioniert. Und das ist einfach uiui.
Das Fakt ist, dass ein interkommandiertes Ökosystem von Unternehmen und Datenbrokern, die eine Verwaltung von Fakten und Fakten von Fakten, die nur nur auf einen kurzen Schuss schauen, ist mehr im Leben vorhanden, als es vorher gewesen ist.
Wie gesagt, wenn wir uns ein bisschen das Business-Modell von Facebook umschreiben und sagt auch ganz klar, was er da von hält. Also da ist bei ihm glaube ich nichts mehr weich zu klopfen oder so, sondern dieses Update wird jetzt kommen im März und dann ist hier am Anfang.
Nee, der sagt nicht, also wenn die mal ihren Hero-Award dann vergeben, dann ist wieder alles gut.
Genau, da ist auch so ein bisschen die föhtanistische Sprache aufgreift. Spielen wir das hier einfach mal.
As I've said before, if we accept as normal and unavoidable that everything in our lives can be aggregated in soul, then we lose so much more than data. We lose the freedom to be human.
Er lobt die Datenschutz-Grundverordnung.
Proving cynics and doomsayers wrong, the GDPR has provided an important foundation for privacy rights around the world, and its implementation and enforcement must continue.
Genau, die ist ja bisher nur eine europäische Datenschutz-Grundverordnung, und hier muss natürlich nachgearbeitet werden.
As I said in Brussels two years ago, it is certainly time not only for a comprehensive privacy law here in the United States, but also for worldwide laws and new international agreements that enshrine the principles of data minimization, user knowledge, user access and data security across the globe.
Das ist am Reißbrett, genau das sind die Bausteine, das sind die Stellschrauben, hier muss gearbeitet werden, also ganz grandioses Ding. Er vergleicht jetzt mal seine Technologie, also das iPhone, die Uhr, was die Uhr so kann, medizinisch auch als Hilfsgerät usw. Und dann hat er so diesen Vergleich, wie die einen damit umgehen, er und wie andere damit umgehen. Dieses Peace of Mind-Ding ist vielleicht ein bisschen unterschätzt, aber darum geht es ja am Ende. Ich erlebe jedenfalls ganz häufig erst diese Woche wieder, dass wir so am Gartenzaun stehen. Und die Frage aufkommt, ich brauche ein neues Handy, kannst du mir was empfehlen? Und das erste, was so eingeworfen wird, ist, nimm ein iPhone. Peace of Mind schwebt da so im Hintergrund. Nimm ein iPhone, da kannst du nichts falsch machen. Aber Android, einmal ist es nicht falsch richtig eingestellt, sagt, bis sie in der Datenhölle gefangen, weiß nicht, was passiert und so. Und ich meine, das Einzige, was Apple jemals ja wirklich schlimm passiert ist, ist, sie lassen halt Fotos in diese iCloud hochladen. Das ist ja so eine normale Funktion, um Speicherplatz zu sparen. Und dass das halt mal gehackt wurde, dass dann die ganzen Hollywood-Stars plötzlich ihren Nacktfuss und so weiter. Aber das wäre wirklich so das Einzige. Diese ganzen medizinischen Sachen, was die Uhr jetzt mittlerweile so kann und so, da habe ich noch von keinem Problem jetzt irgendwie gehört, da ist mir noch nichts untergekommen. In der Ansicht haben sie da schon so ein bisschen, auf ihrer Seite einfach so ein Argument zu sagen, mit dem iPhone Peace of Mind, anders als wenn du jetzt weißt, die Facebook-App auf einem Android-Gerät, also da bist du echt verloren einfach. Das gibt man auch nicht gern seinen Kindern in die Hand oder so. Die kriegen natürlich irgendwie alle iPhones, sofern man sich das leisten kann. Aber mittlerweile kann man ja auch die billigeren iPhones, die älteren Modelle und so weiter, das fallen ja genug ab. Es gibt ja genug Hipster, die sich immer das neueste Modell holen und dann wandert das so durch die Generation irgendwie und so. In der Ansicht hat sich Apple da schon ganz schön krass. Also ich habe es diese Woche wieder gemerkt, wie krass sich der Apple eigentlich positioniert hat. Er stellt jetzt eine neue Technik vor, die sie da bei Apple so nutzen. App-Tracking-Transparenz.
Every app, including our own, must share their data collection and privacy practices. Information that the App Store presents in a way every user can understand and act on. The second is called App-Tracking-Transparency.
Ja, das erinnert mich immer wieder an diese alte digitale Dis-Debatte, die wir in der FAZ da geführt haben. Schömer hat ja immer diese Sprüche, wer liest wird gelesen und so weiter. Und es war ja ganz lange so, dass man im Grunde auf seinem iPhone, auf seinem Telefon, auf seinem Smartphone was gemacht hat und dann wusste man nie, was ist damit eigentlich. Bis hin zu, dass dann Amazon aufgrund der Kindle-Leser-Sachen irgendwie Auswertung gemacht hat, wann brechen Leute die Bücher ab? Was kann man daraus für den Autoren lehren? Wie soll da das nächste Buch schreiben? Dass man bei einem iPhone das erst jetzt so positionieren will im Sinne von, solange du deinen Bildschirm niemanden zeigst, kann niemand sehen, was auf deinem Bildschirm angezeigt wird. Also du musstest wie ein analoges Buch jemanden hindrehen und sagen, guck dir mal dieses Bild an. Und solange du das nicht machst, sieht niemand dieses Bild. Ja, und das ist, ich hätte es damals für unmöglich gehalten, dass man so eine Denke wieder reinkriegt in die Technik, weil eigentlich galt damals alles als verloren. Aber er versucht jetzt seine Geräte wieder so in diesen Zustand zu bringen.
Also du glaubst nicht, dass das so eine pro forma Geschichte ist, wie wir das jetzt gerade hier haben, dass wir immer alles schön brav okay drücken, damit wir schnell an der Seite weiterkommen. Also das ist ja dann auch die Frage des Nutschings am Ende. Wie ist es konstruiert, dass ich dann eine tatsächliche Entscheidung darüber treffe, was gebe ich jetzt gerade frei? Oder ist das einfach dieser Nervbutton, der irgendwo aufpoppt und ich klick drauf, damit es wieder verschwindet und ich weiter auf meinem Smartphone surfen kann?
Also die Gefahr besteht immer. Natürlich, weil wir sind mittlerweile dran gewöhnt, alles wegzuklicken. Allerdings wird hier genau darüber informiert, was man da gerade wegklickt. Also das ist ja eine sehr standardisierte Sache. Bei den Cookies auf den Webseiten, da sieht ja jede Meldung anders aus. Hier weiß man ja bei iOS, worauf man achten muss. Nämlich erstens, da wird die App genannt und die es gerade geht. Und dann wirklich die einzelnen Funktionen. Und ich könnte mir durchaus vorstellen, dass man bei einem Apple-Gerät so eine gewisse Praxis entwickelt. Einfach. Also ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass man die Kindle-App auf einem iPhone tatsächlich so benutzen kann, dass man sich sicher ist, mein Lesestatus wird gerade nicht an Amazon zurückgemeldet. Sondern dass es so restriktiv ist. Und ich bin immer wieder beeindruckt von, wie sich die Diskussion gedreht hat. Denn als damals Apple mit dem iPhone kam, 2007, hat man ja schon gesehen, hm, okay, da sind so ein paar Apple-Apps drauf, aber da ist noch ganz schön viel Platz auf dem Bildschirm. Wann kommen eigentlich die anderen Apps? Also wann wird es freigegeben als Plattform für andere? Und dann war ja Apple ganz streng mit diesem, jede App muss von uns erst begutachtet werden. Man kann ja nicht einfach eine App hochladen, sondern das dauert eine Woche, bis sie dann mal so von uns durchgewunken wird. Und das damals zu verfolgen, auch hier so in den deutschen Podcast-Bits und so, wie die sich immer vom Bergwerk sprachen. Das muss alles erst durch das Bergwerk durch. Und wie krass Apple da auch wirklich Sachen raus sortiert hat einfach. Oder das auch selber nutzen, haben wir ja gesehen bei Spotify. Plötzlich dauert so ein Spotify-Update drei Wochen, während die Apple Music App natürlich die ganze Zeit topaktuell da durchläuft und so.
Oder was jetzt gerade mit den Computerspiele-Anbietern passiert.
Genau, Epic.
Die selbst innerhalb ihres Spiels etwas machen wollen, wo Apple sagt, da wollen wir aber auch nochmal mitverdienen ganz groß.
Genau, so was. Epic wurde da komplett, also Fortnite und so, richtig verbannt. Wir hören jetzt von Google, dass sie schon seit Wochen keine Updates mehr geschickt haben, weil sie eben Angst haben vor diesem, wenn die Nutzer dann mal gefragt werden. Also Google überlegt gerade genauso wie Facebook, wie tracken wir eigentlich weiter unsere Leute. Und in deren Sicht scheint Apple da doch so ein anfangs kritisiertes Regime an. Wir haben die Kontrolle auch über andere Anbieter. Bis hin heute zu, das muss wirklich alles durchsigniert werden. Also jede einzelne App muss einmal von Apple signiert werden, dass sie genau wissen, wie sieht der Code aus und wann wurde er verändert und so weiter. Dass man da auch nicht mehr Teile des Dings dann... Ja, man könnte ja sagen, man lädt erstmal eine allgemeine App hoch und lädt dann so unter der Haube so ein bisschen andere Software nach und so weiter. Aber die haben ja mittlerweile alles ausgeschlossen. Also die können das. Wenn sie es wollten, technisch, glaube ich, steht da nichts mehr im Wege, dass sie da wirklich die Daumenschraube so anziehen und dass sie es jetzt hinsichtlich Privacy so promoten. Ja, finde ich wirklich erstaunlich. Es ist schon, also da steckt doch schon einiges drin. Naja, jetzt hat er hier diese ATT genannt, die App Tracking Transparency. Und klar, das ist jetzt wieder, das findet innerhalb der Unternehmen statt. Er hat einen PDF veröffentlicht, es gibt ein Paper zum Nachlesen. Ja, also sie sind richtig hinterher, dokumentieren das auch alles, was sie machen, damit bloß keiner später kommt, wir haben ja nichts gewusst und so, sondern ne, ne, es ist doch alles da, genau so geht's. Und jetzt greift er hier diesen tollen Jean-Jarine Lagnier, der Buchpreis 2015 hier, Friedenspreis des deutschen Buchhandels, Jean Lagnier ist so, weißt du, der also gegenüber des Silicon-Vallies da in der Uni sitzt, Georgetown und immer ist Georgetown, wie auch immer, und da so den kritischen Blick drauf hat. Na er ist ja für einen Satz berühmt und den greift hier Tim Cook auf. Er macht hier einen sehr wichtigen Punkt, das finde ich einfach eine Sensation.
Ja, das ist ja mit voller Wucht gegen die anderen Gefahren, die genau das tun. Und ich frage mich ja ohnehin, weil er das jetzt gerade so schön sagt. Die Werbeindustrie hat das früher nicht gebraucht. Braucht sie das eigentlich heute? Jetzt kann man sagen, ja, der Vorteil ist aber doch dann, dass man jetzt ganz gezielt werden kann. Wir haben doch früher erlebt, dass sich so vieles versendet hat. Wo fruchtet eigentlich eine Zeitungsanzeige? Man weiß es nicht so genau. Man weiß in etwa etwas über die Leser, weiß aber gar nicht, ob die bis zur Seite 7 kommen. Gucken die mehr nach unten oder mehr nach oben auf der Seite? All diese Dinge sind sehr unklar. Es gibt Erhebungen darüber, aber das ist nicht vergleichbar mit dem, was man da hat. Jetzt hat man diese gezielte Werbung. Man kann mit Adblockern oder so ein bisschen umgehen, aber man hat sie doch sehr gezielt. Ich frage mich nur jetzt auch, ist das nicht auch eine gewisse Illusion der gezielten Werbung? Wir haben sicherlich diese Influencer, die direkt für etwas werben können, was sehr eng mit ihnen verknüpft ist und sie haben eigene Produkte und das. Aber diese gezielte Werbung, die jetzt irgendetwas ausliest, mein Verhalten bei Google, Amazon und sonst was, die dann dafür sorgt, dass, wenn ich mir irgendwas bei YouTube ansehe, dann eine gezielte Werbung kommt, das trifft ja ganz oft nicht zu. Also ich bin eigentlich verblüfft über die Dummheit der Algorithmen, die so aussieht, dass wir im Wirtschaftspodcast immer irgendwelche komischen Werbung für Finanz-Apps und Finanz-Coachings davor haben, wo nicht nur wir wissen, dass wir das nicht machen und niemals machen würden, sondern auch die anderen, die eine ähnlich personalisierte Werbung angezeigt bekommen, weil sie sowas öffnen, niemals einen Finanz-Coach engagieren würden, weil sie ja wohl schon für alle gucken und wissen daher, wie doof das ist. Spätestens seitdem sie das dann gucken, seitdem sie wohl schon für alle genießen. Oder ich will ein ganz konkretes Beispiel nennen. Ich bekomme bei YouTube seit bestimmt acht Wochen oder noch länger, zwölf Wochen, fast täglich die Werbung von Asos angezeigt. Sneaker-Style bei Asos. Asos ist wie Zalando und man kann dort vor allem so Sportmode kaufen, sportliche Mode, Sneakers. Kurz und gut alles Dinge, die ich nie trage, kann man dort kaufen. Ich bekomme seit zwölf Wochen diese Werbung angezeigt. Ich würde mich ja gerade zu freuen, wenn ich mal Werbung für einen Anzug, Lederschuhe oder ein gutes Parfum bekomme. Aber nein, ich bekomme immer Werbung für Sneakers und Sportmode angezeigt. Wie ist das möglich? Ich weiß, ich habe zu Sneakers ein bisschen recherchiert. Wir sprachen ja hier auch im Podcast drüber. Aber irgendwann muss doch dieser Algorithmus auch mal wieder gescheckt haben. Der Mann trägt eigentlich gestärkte Hemden.
Ja, also die Algorithmen sind halt, sie funktionieren halt wie sie sollen. Also wie man sie programmiert hat. Man weiß ja selber nicht genau, was man von ihnen will. Und entsprechend liefern sie auch wenig Resultate. Ich würde aber sagen, die Diskussion ist müßig. So ein bisschen wie bei Ist Astra Senegals 70, 78, 85 oder 87. Weil dann hat man eine Studie und dann kommt nächste Woche die nächste Studie und dann kommt nächste Woche die nächste Studie und in einem Jahr kommt immer noch eine neue Studie und dann hat man noch eine neue Studie. Und irgendwann weiß man dann Bescheid, dann kommt wieder eine neue Studie. Ich würde sagen, wir haben es ja mit so einem Metier zu tun. Also personifizierte Werbung aufgrund von Spionage ins Individuelle hinein, dass man sagen kann, wie bei Gesichtserkennung, einfach echten. Sollen Wissenschaftler über diese Diskussion, was können sie, wie auch immer, ich würde sagen, einfach verbieten. Ist technisch möglich, aber einfach mal verboten. So, dass man es einfach echtet und dass man sagt, so wie er. Und das stimmt ja, das ist ja das Argument, was er hier gemacht hat. Die Technologie selbst funktioniert ohne das. Nur das Finanzierungsmodell für die Technologiehersteller, die braucht das halt, die platziert halt der Werbung. Aber die Technologie selbst braucht das nicht. Und das stimmt. Facebook funktioniert einfach so. Wenn ich wirklich mal wissen will, also wenn ich Facebook ein Signal geben will, hinsichtlich ich bin jetzt hier und brauche eine Pizzeria, dann kann ich das auch als Signalworte in die Suchmaschine eingeben. Da muss keine Unternehmensideologie zu mir kommen und sagen, wir kennen dich so gut, dass wir schon die Antwort haben, bevor du die Frage stellst.
Das brauche ich ja gar nicht. Ich kann nach Mannheim fahren und sagen, ich gebe mir einen Standort an und gucke, was in der Umgebung ist, oder ich kann auch Pizzeria Mannheim angeben.
Genau, wir haben ja alle einen sehr virtuosen Umgang mit Suchzeilen, indem wir was eintragen. Das ist mir bei meiner Tochter jetzt wieder aufgefallen. Zweite Klasse, sie kommt also gerade ins Lesen, will aber irgendeine Bibiontina-Geschichte hören, von der sie nur so Schlagworte kennt. Was macht man normalerweise? Man geht zu den Eltern und sagt, ich möchte die Geschichte hören, in der der Hund im Zoo usw. Und man geht ins Detail, umso mehr Details, umso besser. Jetzt fängt sie an zu schreiben. Sucht also eine Folge und trägt bei Spotify oben ein Bibiontina, die Folge mit dem Hund im Zoo usw. Wir alle wissen, möglichst unspezifisch rangehen, nur Schlagworte nennen und dann selber das Suchergebnis durchschauen. Umso spezifischer du es machst, umso weniger wird überhaupt ein Resultat angezeigt. Wir haben ja mittlerweile alle einen virtuosen Umgang mit Suchen. Wir sind ja wirklich in der Lage, mit unserem Gehirneinsatz eine Suche zu machen und dann eine Pizzeria zu finden, wenn wir eine brauchen. Wir brauchen ja keine Werbeanzeige, die uns dann gerade Tornschuhe anzeigt, weil das geht halt doch häufig schief. Deswegen würde ich sagen, Tim Cook hat ja absolut recht. Diese Technologie funktioniert jetzt schon, die braucht das alles gar nicht.
Man könnte sogar noch weitergehen durch diese Kommerzialisierung, durch diese Werbemodelle, wird die Suche erschwert. Also es ist ja gerade so bei Google, dass dadurch, dass es dieses Ranking gibt, dadurch, dass Dinge, die bezahlt haben, nach oben kommen, es sehr viel schwieriger ist, genau das zu finden, was man sucht. Also ich kenne das zum Beispiel, wenn ich gewisse Hemden suche, Stehkragenhemden, dann bekomme ich erst mal 50 Ergebnisse angezeigt, die nichts damit zu tun haben, aber da kommt heute das Wort Hemd vor.
Genau, und in deren Sicht würde ich auch sagen, wir machen mal wieder diesen Versuch, einfach allgemeine Werbung anzuzeigen. Es ist ja nicht alles dann verboten. Es wird ja nur von 500 auf 8 Signale runtergedimmt und halt die Sachen, die man in sein Profil einträgt, Alter, Geschlecht und so weiter. Das muss dann nicht groß sophisticated, ja, durch irgendwelche Rechnungen ausgemittelt werden, ist er jetzt schwul oder nicht. Sondern da weiß man einfach, okay, wenn das jemand einträgt, kann man es halt verwenden, wenn nicht, dann nicht. Also so viel Hoheit über die eigenen Daten sei dann zugestanden. Wenn man es in sein Profil einträgt, weiß man, wie Facebook das nutzt. Und dann macht man einfach allgemeine Werbung. So wie das in Podcastgeschäften ja auch. Der Leo Laporte, den haben wir ja schon häufiger gespielt, der sagt ja auch, Werbetreibende kommen auf mich zu und fragen mich, wer hört denn das hier? Und dann sagt man denen, ja, lassen sie doch ihre Hospitalen einfach mal drei Folgen hören von dieser Ausgabe hier, dann haben sie ein Gefühl dafür, wen sie hier erreichen, wenn sie hier werben. Das sind halt dann, ja, keine Ahnung, das Publikum ist ja doch sehr leicht einschätzbar. Und dann kann man den Investment einfach mal ausrechnen, so nach zwei Wochen. Ja, legt man es mal drauf an. Es ist jetzt nicht weniger erfolgsversprechend, als wenn man halt dieses mega krasse Tageding da irgendwie macht. Er jedenfalls, Tim Cook, sieht hier, er möchte einfach, dass Technologie gut funktioniert und dieser Ganze, was so im Verborgenen abgeht, eben nicht gemacht werden muss. Und er möchte jetzt hier über die Konsequenzen mal nachdenken. Und das ist vielleicht der stärkste Moment dieser ohnehin schon extrem starken Rede.
Was sind die Konsequenzen der priorisierenden Konspiratistik-Theorien und der kranken Ansteigung, nur wegen der hohen Ratsverwaltung? Was sind die Konsequenzen der nicht nur tolerierenden, sondern auch befreundeten Content, die öffentlichen Vertrauen in lebenssinnige Vakzinationen unterliegt?
Das ist natürlich herausfordernd für die linke Blase, ob sie es einsieht und versteht, dass ausgerechnet das wertvollste Unternehmen der Welt den Ruf nach moralischer Verantwortung am besten gehört hat bisher.
Weil es ein Profitinteresse gibt.
Auch, aber das ist ja natürlich klar, aber das kann ja auch. Die Frage ist ja, wo spielt Moral statt? Primär nie, dafür sind das halt Unternehmen, da muss man dann in den NGOs gehen. Aber ich würde sagen, wir sind ja schon mindestens auf der sekundären, ja, vielleicht tertiaren Ebene. Und da kann man einfach mal sagen, da gehört es hin, da ist es richtig, da muss das so gemacht werden. Das ist ja schon auf der Ebene, der Unternehmenschef spricht selbst zur Presse und delegiert das nicht an irgendwen, der mal so eine Veranstaltung managt. Ja, da gibt es ein kleines Budget und dann macht man das halt. Das macht Google so. Google feuert die ganzen Ethik-Leute, die man da in einer AI-Kontrolle drin hat, macht aber gleichzeitig immer diese Programme, irgendwie mit Diversity und dem ganzen Kram. Hier bei Tim Cook hat das doch so eine gewisse Funktion gefunden, also dass der Unternehmenschef selber sich hier so skin in the game-mäßig hinsetzt und einfach mal sagt, Leute, wenn hier ein Sturm aufs Kapitol stattfindet, dann können wir nicht einfach sagen, wir haben damit nichts zu tun, sondern das ist dann, ja, da müssen wir uns alle mal fragen, was hat das mit uns zu tun? Und da gibt es ein paar Unternehmen, die müssen diese Frage ernst erstellen und die fordert ihr ja oft darüber nachzudenken.
Und fest steht, dass er der Vorreiter dann nun mal ist, beziehungsweise die Politik es nicht gebacken bekommt. Wir haben eben über Dezision, über Souveränität gesprochen. Er ist der Besitzer, sag ich jetzt mal, eines proprietären Marktes. Er kann da Spielregeln aufstellen und kann sagen, hier ab sofort nur noch acht Daten werden rausgegeben und nicht mehr 500. Und das ist aber etwas, was er da jetzt gerade tut, was man auch auf die gesamte Politik übertragen könnte. Und sagen muss, ja, generell ist das so. Also nicht nur auf der Plattform, die Apple betreibt, ist das so, sondern generell nicht mehr als acht Daten. Das ist eine Regel, die man vorgeben könnte, die wir in ganz vielen anderen Dingen haben. Aber wir sehen hier einmal mehr, und das ist ja etwas, was sich seit der ersten Folge der Neuen Zwanziger durchzieht, dass die Wirtschaft eigentlich der Politik weit voraus ist, in dem, was sie als Möglichkeit empfindet, während hier immer noch eine Doro Behr Interviews gibt und sagt, ja, wir müssen uns auch einmal ein bisschen vom Datenschutz verabschieden, damit wir nicht Unternehmensmodelle kaputt machen. Und deren Sprecherin, die ist dann jetzt, oder es ist die Büroleiterin, die ist dann inzwischen jetzt schon rekrutiert von Facebook als Lobbyistin in Brüssel. Und das ist gleichzeitig noch die Lebensgefährtin von Andy Scheuer. Und so wird darüber nachgedacht. Insofern, ja, ich bin auch froh, dass es jemanden wie Tim Cook gibt.
Ja, und lassen wir ihm diesen letzten Satz hier noch durchgehen.
Wir nennen uns naiv. Aber wir glauben immer noch, dass die Technologie, die von Menschen gemacht wurde, für Menschen, und mit der Wohlung der Menschen in der Erinnerung ist, ein Werkzeug zu verlassen, zu verlassen.
So, und ich will dieses Paradox aufgreifen. Er ist ein Unternehmer. Er möchte Profit machen, und er hat hier einen Weg gefunden, Profit zu machen, den ich moralisch sehr hoch werte. Weshalb ich den Appell habe, das müssen alle als unternehmerischen Wert anerkennen. Und umso mehr Profite kann Apple damit machen. Und umso besser ist das dann für alle. Also hier steckt durchaus eine moralische Komponente drin, die man hier zu Markte tragen kann. Und das sollte man dann auch tun. Das Angebot ist jetzt da. Wer gute Technik haben will, da kann sie bei Apple halt tatsächlich erwerben. Und da kann man es dann mal vergleichen mit dem, was Google so bei Android anbietet. Und dann kann man einfach die Schlüsse ziehen. Ja, aber das marktwirtschaftliche Angebot ist hier da und da keine falsche Skepsis, nur weil es eine marktwirtschaftliche Angelegenheit ist. Ja, in der Sicht. Wir haben ja viele Hörer, die hier immer mal wieder ein bisschen Sonderappell brauchen.
Richtig, ist das so?
Ich glaube schon. So ein bisschen Blasendeck besser hier dabei.
Aber jetzt sag doch mal, wie ist es denn mit Australien? Da tut doch Facebook ganz viel für die Pressefreiheit, oder?
Genau, wir schließen mal an bei Ursula von der Leyen. Die haben ja vorhin bei der Münchner Sicherheitskonferenz gehört. Da hat sie kurz noch was dazu gesagt.
Wir können nur nicht auf Entscheidungen gehen, die einen großen Impakt auf unsere Demokratie haben, um Computerprogramme ohne menschliche Überwachung oder die Board-Ruhe in Silicon Valley zu machen.
Die neueste Entscheidung auf Facebook um Australien ist nur ein anderes Zeug dafür.
Sie bleibt im ungefähren. Sie nennt es nur, sie erklärt es nicht. Was ist damit in Australien? Ist irgendwie das ist Proof für irgendwas. Also in Australien gibt es eine Gesetzesinitiative, die heißt News Media Bargaining Code. Also News Medien, die miteinander irgendwas verhandeln und das in den Code gegossen soll, mal Gesetz werden. Es ist noch kein Gesetz, wird aber seit drei Jahren geplant und betrifft vor allem Google und Facebook. Das kennen wir ja auch aus der europäischen Gesetzgebung. Haben wir ja gehört, Digital Markets Act und Services Act. Da unterscheidet man noch mal zwischen, es gibt so Marktteilnehmer, dann gibt es so besondere Marktteilnehmer, die Gatekeeper, die richtig großen, die man auch namentlich fast nennen könnte. Da haben wir ja von Festake gehört. Also hier geht es um Google und Facebook, weil das diejenigen sind, die News auf den Markt bringen, unter der Annahme, dass es die Unternehmer nicht selber können, weil keiner geht mehr auf Webseiten, man will das aggregierte Ding. Und jetzt gibt es eine Wettbewerbsbehörde, die heißt ACCC, das Australian Competition and Consumer Commission, oder D-Commission, und die hatten das vorgeschlagen, dass man einfach sagt, die Unternehmer mit drei Monate Zeit miteinander zu verhandeln, was Nachrichten wert sind, das heißt, ein Nutzer teilt irgendwas newsmäßiges auf Facebook, Facebook wehrt sich dagegen nicht, und dann damit ist es publiziert, und damit muss da auch ein Preisschild dran gehängt werden, und wenn dann irgendwie festgestellt wird, das sind so und so viele News-Artikel, die auf Facebook geteilt werden, dann muss Facebook an die News-Hersteller, also die Medienhäuser, was zahlen. Und wenn die sich nicht einigen können innerhalb von drei Monaten, dann gibt es eine Entscheidung eines Gremiums, das dann einfach sagt, der Preis ist jetzt so und so. Der Modus genauer, Casey Newton, hier schon häufiger genannte Autor, auf den ich mich jetzt auch häufiger beziehe, der meint so, ja, dieser finale Preisfindungsmechanismus ist dann wahrscheinlich so, wenn sich die Unternehmen untereinander nicht einigen, also Facebook und Newscoop, Murdochs großer australischer Laden zum Beispiel, dann macht einfach jeder ein Angebot und dann kommt ein Gremium und sagt, dieses ist uns schlüssiger, wir nehmen dieses. Da muss also jeder überlegen, wie kann ich jetzt nicht über die Stränge schlagen, aber den anderen noch irgendwie so ausboten. Und dann kommt man da irgendwie zu der Lösung. Das ist aber alles nur, ja, genau, so ein bisschen Spieltheorie, das ist aber alles nur bisher so, ja, keine Ahnung, mal gucken, das Gesetz ist ja noch nicht mal durch den dortigen Senat und so weiter.
Dann jedoch gab es ja ein interessantes Ereignis, dass Facebook sich so sehr in die Enge geträgt hat.
Ja, ja, genau, wir nähern uns mal langsam, denn irgendwann hat dann Facebook auch gesagt, ja, dann sperren wir halt immer, war alles so, ne? Wir beginnen aber bei einer ganz normalen Nachrichtensendung, Pipapo, wir schalten mal so mittelrein ins australische Fernsehen, wo das so diskutiert wird.
It said that 39% of Australians use Facebook for general news. But this is the important one. 49% of Australians actually use Facebook to gain news about COVID.
Also 39% holen allgemeine Nachrichteninhalte aus Facebook, 49% holen ihre COVID-Nachrichten aus Facebook. In Australien gibt es ja zum Beispiel kein COVID, deswegen weiß ich nicht genau, warum das jetzt so mega Ding ist, aber er meint, das ist ganz wichtig.
Was ja erstaunlich ist, denn Zuckerberg betont doch gern, dass nur 4% Medieninhalte bei Facebook liegen nur bei 4%, aber wenn es 39% dann...
Ja, also widerspricht sich nicht muss, sondern man kann ja sagen, man guckt ganz viel Fernsehen, aber nur 4% davon ist wirklich die Viertelstunde Tagesschau. So, in deren Sicht muss man halt viel gucken, aber wir konsumieren ja auch viel Facebook, die Leute, und deswegen passt das dann irgendwie. Naja, also es geht darum, jetzt ist ja jetzt die Frage, wer muss ja eigentlich wem was bezahlen? Ist ja auch klar, Facebook wirkt interessanter dadurch, dass da auch echte Nachrichten da sind, und nicht nur Katzenbilder. Gleichzeitig sind halt mehr Leute da, die dann diese Nachrichten auch wirklich konsumieren. Und Facebook ist halt hier Vermittler. Also klar, man liest manchmal nur Überschriften, aber man klickt ja da die Links auch an und ist dann plötzlich auf den Seiten der Newsmedien. Und naja, und jetzt kommt gleich der Dreh des Korrespondenten. Ja, es macht nicht nur Sense, sondern es macht gleich Common Sense, was er jetzt beschreibt. Und er sagt hier so, wenn jemand deinen Content nimmt, Facebook nimmt sich ja nicht wirklich den Content, sondern es sind ja die Nutzer, die ihn da posten. Also das ist schon mal so ein bisschen problematisch, das so zu sehen. Auf der anderen Seite versteht man natürlich, dass er sagt, naja, wenn die Nutzer damit bespielt werden, irgendwer muss es ja herstellen und das kostet halt Geld. Also versteht man so was.
Wann begann denn diese Debatte in Deutschland? Das war doch auch 2011.
Leistungsschutzrecht.
Leistungsschutzrecht. 2011 war das doch, dass Springer da auch ganz vorn weg war und sagte, wir müssen da doch auch mal pro Artikel 10 Cent, 20 Cent quasi kassieren, wenn das angezeigt ist bei Google, wenn es angezeigt ist bei Facebook. Es war ja auch immer diese Sache. Na ja, man kann die ersten drei, vier Zeilen ja dann schon lesen, ohne die Seite zu verlassen. Die meisten Leute, reicht das. Also profitieren die von unseren Inhalten. Das ist halt wie, wenn man einen Song nicht komplett spielt, aber doch ein Stück, dann muss man auch was dafür zahlen.
Ja, das ist alles eine ganz traurige Geschichte, dieses Leistungsschutzrecht und in Australien ja auch. Springer hat sich das damals erkämpft und dann hieß es gleich, aber ihr kriegt eine kostenlose Lizenz. Und seitdem schlummert das ja so vor sich hin. Und niemand hat ehemals irgendwo was bezahlt oder irgendwie irgendwas verboten. Springer hat ja mal so ein Selbstexperiment gemacht, hat gesagt, wir lassen uns nicht mehr indizieren. Nach einem Tag haben sie es rückgängig gemacht, weil hier irgendwie 40 Prozent der Leser oder so abhanden kamen. In Australien heißt es mittlerweile 20 Prozent weniger Traffic auf den Nachrichten sein, nachdem Facebook da kurz blockierte. Naja, die Moderatorin fragt jedenfalls mal so ein bisschen, sie versucht zu vermitteln nach.
Wir müssen nicht auf Facebook gehen für unsere News, es ist nur ein Habit.
Aber dann auch damals war es wieder der Kommunikationsminister, der gesagt hat, dass er bereits mit Microsofts Bing Web Server und auch DuckDuckGo als Alternative begonnen hat.
So, also irgendwie ist hier irgendwas in der Luft, keine Ahnung. Die Nutzer nutzen irgendwie Nachrichten. Man weiß nicht genau, wie irgendwie möchte man jetzt mal, aber es ist doch alles eine Gewohnheit, wie wir das machen. Stimmt.
Gibt es Alternativen zu Google DuckDuckGo? Hast du das mal genutzt? Hast du das mal ausprobiert?
Ja, damals. Und es war schrecklich.
Ich hab's auch mal ausprobiert und kann auch nur sagen, dass es schrecklich war.
Ich empfehle Startpage, denn Startpage hat einen sehr langen Vertrag noch mit Google, um einfach Google-Suche anzubieten. Allerdings gibt Startpage keine Signale von dir weiter, sondern nur den Suchbegriff. Das kommt also als sogenannten Dark Traffic bei Google an. Die geben dir dann einfach nur das Allgemeine. Okay, das sind die zum Suchbegriff gehörenden Ergebnisse. Und dann werden die das aus. Also wir haben hier in der Schwebe ein Gesetz, das irgendwie kommen soll und jetzt wird es so ein bisschen hitzig und man droht sich schon gegenseitig irgendwie. Und dann taucht bei Sky News der Treasurer, Josh Frydenberg auf, das ist so der Schatzmeister-Finanzminister und sagt, historischer Tag, das Gesetz ist zwar noch nicht da, aber wir haben schon eine Einigung. Die ersten beiden Unternehmen haben sich miteinander verständigt, in dem Fall ist es Google.
Das ist ein historischer Moment.
So, das heißt jetzt konkret, Google hat mit News Corp, also Murdochsladen und noch 2-3 andere, dort Verträge abgeschlossen, deren Inhalt wir nicht kennen, deren Geldbeträge wir nicht kennen, von denen wir nur wissen. Ja, es gibt so ein paar Content Sachen, die laufen jetzt bei Google News in so einer bestimmten Sektion ab, wo beispielsweise auch Sachen, die üblicherweise hinter einer Firewall sind und bei Google angezeigt werden können. Wer also hinter eine Firewall möchte, kann jetzt entweder direkt zu den Anbietern gehen oder aggregiert, Google hat es für dich bezahlt, zu Google. Da würde ich sagen, das treibt natürlich auch ziemlich viele jetzt einfach zu Google, wenn die wissen, ach so, ich kann jetzt Sachen, die eigentlich Geld kostet bei Google kriegen, dann gehe ich jetzt noch mehr zu Google. Also es ist auch so ein kleines Werbeding für Google. Ich glaube nicht, dass es jetzt, klar, es bringt ein bisschen Geld für die Hersteller der Nachrichten, aber so hat es eine gewisse Schieflage. Naja, der Frydenberg hier ist jedenfalls sehr froh, dass jetzt alle mal an einem Tisch sitzen und erstellt ja noch mal diese Final Offer Arbitration, so heißt sie da. Ja, Final Offer Arbitration, also jeder gibt ein finales Gebot ab und dann sagt halt einfach so eine dritte Partei, oder nehmen wir jetzt mal das statt dem. Er fühlt es hier noch mal ein bisschen aus, was ihm so wichtig war, danach stellen wir uns mal eine Frage. Sind, mal zusammensitzen. Das liegt natürlich irgendwie auf der Hand, das ist so dieses sozialpartnerschaftliche, die beiden, die betroffen sind. Es gibt allerdings nicht nur Robert-Mörder-Laden dort und noch so andere Milliardenunternehmen, sondern was ist denn jetzt mit den Kleinen? Müssen die jetzt auch so eine Anwaltschaft, bindet sich da irgendwie so ein Verbands zusammen, der dann irgendwie da Verhandlungen mit Google führt, oder wie kriegt man da denn die Inhalte weiter legitimerweise auf Google News, oder werden die dann auch aussortiert, weil es da keine Verträge gibt? Ja, was sieht dieses Gesetz eigentlich vor? Niemand weiß es so richtig. Und auf der anderen Seite muss man sagen, Google ist jetzt auch nicht so einverstanden, damit wie das da läuft. Ja, weil das hat natürlich auch Vorbildcharakter, müssen sie jetzt in jedem Land irgendwie zahlen. Deshalb gab es dann auch von Google nochmal ein Video, wo sich die Googlesprecherin von vor Ort mal dazu äußert und nochmal vergleicht, wir haben ja eben den Journalisten gehört, der sagt, na stellen sie sich mal vor, das muss ja jemand bezahlen. Facebook nimmt den Content und na klar, müssen die dann dafür bezahlen. Sie macht jetzt dieses Gegenargument, das wir auch schon aus allen Himmelsrichtungen eigentlich kennen.
Und es unterstellt auch, wie die Web funktioniert.
Kann man das vergleichen?
Nee, kann man natürlich nicht.
Kann man natürlich nicht. Allerdings ist es ja so, dass es ja sein mag, dass ganz viel auf der Plattform stattfindet. Ich habe aber auch den Eindruck, und das ist jetzt nicht statistisch gedeckt, sondern eher erfahren, dass viele Leute durch den Social Media Gebrauch, und ich rede jetzt nicht von den Aluhüten, sondern von den normalen Menschen, durchaus auf sehr viele Medieninhalte stoßen, die sie sonst nicht rezipiert hätten, in einem noch analogen Zeitalter, das so ausgesehen hätte, man konsumiert die Abendnachrichten, man hört vielleicht ein, zwei Mal am Tag Radio und hat die Tageszeitung da, und die Tageszeitung meint in aller Regel die Regionalzeitung, vielleicht hat man noch einen Wochenmagazin, Stern, Spiegel oder so. Heute sehe ich doch bei ganz normalen Leuten, also ich betone das normal, um zu sagen, keine journalistischen Kollegen, sondern wirklich ganz normal Leute, die posten was aus der New York Times, die posten was aus der FAZ, aus Spektrum Wissenschaft, was auch immer.
Genau, und das kriegt man eigentlich nicht, also das ist eine lebendige Medienlandschaft, die würde ich auch, das ist unbedingt zu erhalten und zu pflegen auch so ein bisschen. Und deswegen ist es sehr schade, dass wir ja einfach gesagt wurden, die beiden Unternehmen sollten das mal miteinander klären und die müssen da niemanden drüber aufklären, sondern hier könnte man ja auch einfach sagen, liebe Frau Google-Austraia, das ist natürlich ein schönes Bild. Man fragt seinen Freund und dann soll der Freund, plötzlich der die Empfehlung gegeben hat an den Kneipier, an den er den Kunden auch vermittelt hat, was bezahlen. Hier geht es ja darum, dass alle den gleichen Freund fragen. Und das bringt natürlich eine gewisse Machtsituation einher, bei der man sich wirklich fragen muss, ist der nicht korrumpiert? Kennt man ja von dem Umgang mit Touristen, von Taxifahrern irgendwo, die sagen, sie wollen zu einer Kneipe fahren, ich fahre sie zu meiner Kneipe. Also da sind ja doch so kleine Machtdinger im Spiel. Deswegen finde ich zum Beispiel, Casey Newton und so, alle sind unzufrieden mit diesem Gesetz. Ich auch so ein bisschen. Weil hier wird einfach Geld bezahlt an News Corp, nicht an die Journalisten, die die Inhalte wirklich herstellen, sondern es geht wieder an den Verleger, der macht sich dann damit die Taschen voll und investiert das wahrscheinlich nicht in Journalismus, sondern sagt dann wie beim Kotzer bei der Geld und Mercedes, wir haben einen tollen Gewinn gemacht, nehme ich hier nochmal 500 Millionen drauf. War die Kotzer bei der Sache, aber egal, ist jetzt unser Unternehmensgewinn, der wird natürlich an die Dividende ausgezahlt und nicht als Lohnbonus oder sowas. Man braucht hier eigentlich ein Gesetz, das klassischerweise einfach abschöpft, das diese Macht von Facebook und Google einfach kalkuliert und sagt, das schöpfen wir jetzt ab. Zum Teil wird dann damit entschädigt, geht dann an die Medienhäuser, kommt man glaube ich nicht drum rum, weil die haben es nun mal hergestellt, aber man könnte damit auch direkt Journalismus funktionieren, äh, finanzieren, Überstiftungen und so weiter, die man damit dann, so wie ein bisschen wie beim Lotto, ja, man macht so ein Lottospiel für alle und dann die Einnahmen nimmt man und gibt die dann dem Vereinssport oder sowas, dass man irgendwie solche Modelle findet. Denn so geht es irgendwie nicht und das hat sich Facebook auch gedacht, so geht es irgendwie nicht, ja, also Google hat klein beigegeben, hat so still und heimlich irgendwie, keine Ahnung, Google hat sich nie dazu geäußert, es gibt genau nichts davon zu spielen, man weiß nicht und so. Facebook hat sich einfach mal geweigert.
Ich bin nicht von all den Negotiationen, die die Regierung mit den verschiedenen Online-Plattformen hat, aber ich bin auf Facebook verabschiedet. Es ist schwer zu glauben, dass sie politische Leader aktiv silenzieren. Ich bin nicht sein Nummer 1-Fan, aber Zach Kirkup, der Staatsanwalt-Lehrer, hat seine Facebook-Page im Mittelpunkt geschlossen. Das ist keine öffentlich-freie, demokratische Aktion von Facebook. Sie silenzieren einen meiner Staatsanwalt-Komplexer, Amber Jade Sanderson, eine Starrin der Labor-Fraktion in West-Australien. Und sie silenzieren Leute wie das Telefon-Kind-Institut. Ich meine, was Facebook auf der Suche tut, sie tun es in der dummsten und schittesten Art. Sie spielen mit den Menschen die Möglichkeit, zu kommunizieren. Die Führungsservice in West-Australien wurde durch Facebook silenziert. Ich meine, es ist einfach über die Schleifung, was sie getan haben.
So, was ist passiert?
Cancel Culture einmal anders. Facebook hat einfach mal gesagt, jetzt sollen wir die Zeitungen sehen, wie sie ihre Artikel an den Mann und an die Frau bekommen. Nicht mehr über unsere Seite. Wir machen einfach mal dicht für die.
Alles schwarz. Wenn die einen Verhandlungspartner, News Corp, Seven West Media, Nine Entertainment, das sind alles so die, die so richtig milliardenschwer sind, so die großen Springers dort, die haben von Google wahrscheinlich immer so 30 Millionen pro Nase bekommen. Und Facebook sagt jetzt, da machen wir nicht mit. Bei uns spielt News gar nicht so eine große Rolle. Jetzt sagt das Gesetz aber, wenn es hier keine Verhandlungsergebnisse gibt, könnt ihr keine Nachrichten anzeigen. Und zwar nicht nur von denen, mit denen die Verhandlungen gescheitert sind. Die könnte man ja einfach auf so eine Blacklist stellen und sagen, an dieser Link kann ihr nicht geteilt werden. Sondern grundsätzlich mit allen Nachrichteninhalten. Das Gesetz ist aber so unspezifisch, dass sich Facebook sagte, ja, da müssen wir mal künstliche Intelligenz anwerfen, um herauszufinden, was hier Nachrichten ist und was nicht. Plötzlich hat Facebook seine eigenen Seiten dort gesperrt. Also man konnte Links zu Facebook nicht mehr posten, Links zu irgendwelchen Regierungssachen usw. Und das wurde dann ein mega großes Thema im Parlament. Also man muss ja noch mal sagen, australische Nachrichten waren plötzlich weltweit gesperrt. Und weltweite Nachrichten waren in Australien gesperrt. Also man konnte gar nicht mehr irgendwas mit Nachrichten posten. Facebook war quasi nur noch so eine private Nachbarschaftssache oder sonst irgendwie unter Freunden. Man teilt sich so die Sachen, die man wirklich selber generiert. Bilder, die man so selber macht, kleine Sprüche, wie auch immer. Alles andere ging plötzlich nicht mehr. Und dann muss im Parlament darüber gesprochen werden. Hier hören wir jetzt Kommunikationsminister Paul Fletcher, der im Parlament darüber aufklärt, was Facebook so alles gesperrt hat.
In Bezug auf die Verkundung von Facebook, die in der Verkundung von vielen Pages heute blockiert, hat das sehr seriöse Fragen. Wenn du sagst, dass du den News-Media-Bargaining-Code abweichst, warum würdest du die Pages von den Regierungsdiensten, den ÖPNV-Organisatoren, das Büro für Meteorologie, das 1800RESPECT blockieren? Diese Pages würden niemals von dem Code zu beantworten. Warum bist du so festgehalten, die Verwaltung der Blockungsrequiremente unter unserer Legislaturperiode in Bezug auf ein hohes und violentes Material zu haben, obwohl es aus der Wahrheit kommt, dass du tausende Pages von hohe und unerwöchentlichen Content über Nacht blockieren kannst? Der Founder Rachel Chappell hat mir heute gesagt, dass sie 25.000 Follower hat. Warum ist es eine gute Idee, mit einer politischen Maßnahme zu reagieren, die an deinem Marktwesen gerichtet wird, mit einem Überdrehen dieses Marktes zu sein? Und warum erinnerst du dich nicht, dass unser Regierung mit diesem Code engagiert ist? Wir sind mit dem Gesetz engagiert. Und was wir suggerieren, ist, dass Facebook wieder auf sensibelem Gespräch mit dem Staat kommen muss. Wir werden das weiterhin tun, aber was wir nicht ändern werden, ist unser Gesetz, diesen Code zu legislieren.
Das ist natürlich alles britischer Commonwealth. Da geht es im Parlament genauso zu wie in England auch. Facebook hat sogar eine Beratungsstelle für Opfer von sexueller Gewalt geblockt. Hier war richtig was los in Australien. Und das fand natürlich dann der Schatzminister oder Finanzminister Josh Frydenberg auch nicht alles so cool, also auch er hat sich als zweiter Minister dazu geäußert. Und der Paul Fletcher, der Kommunikationsminister, schob dann mal folgendes nach und das gibt uns glaube ich einzubedenken.
Ich habe heute Morgen auf Facebook gesprochen und gesagt, dass das Regierung sie erwartet, diese Pages so schnell wie möglich zu verringern.
Ich glaube, das bedeutet das eigentlich, dass wir Facebook als eine Institution erkennen müssen, die eigentlich eine staatliche ist, die zwar jetzt noch gerade in privater Hand sich befindet, deswegen nehmen die sich auch solche Dinge raus, aber eigentlich müssen wir sagen, es ist wie eine staatliche Institution, eine solche Wichtigkeit hat das Ganze. Wir sehen, wie dramatisch das ist. Es geht ja nicht darum, dass ein paar Zeitungen, ein paar Profite an dem Tag nicht machen konnten, sondern dass man sagt, die haben einfach die Leute jetzt von der Außenwelt abgeschnitten, dass wir jetzt so sagen, wir drehen mal dem Stefan für einen Tag den Strom ab, weil es uns danach ist. Das heißt, man muss eigentlich sagen, das muss als Institution, als eine staatliche begriffen werden und auch der Art reguliert werden, dass eigentlich das gar nicht mehr möglich ist, dass die das dürfen. Denn hier wird ja wirklich das Argument gebracht, dass etwas Dramatisches passiert, also dass die öffentliche Sicherheit und Gesundheit in Gefahr ist.
Genau, ich würde staatlich, finde ich, ein bisschen begrifflich übertrieben. Geht aber in die richtige Richtung. Wir haben ja noch den öffentlichen, also den Begriff der Öffentlichkeit, öffentlich-public-safety. Und wir kennen ja auch in Deutschland, und das ist zum Beispiel auch im deutschen Kartellrecht festgehalten, du kannst privat eine Brücke betreiben, die so wichtig sein kann für den deutschen Infrastrukturbetrieb, dass sie als wesentliche Einrichtung gilt. Beispielsweise hier zwischen Mainz und Frankfurt gibt es diese Schiersteiner Brücke oder so, die wurde jetzt ein Jahr lang renoviert und konnte deswegen nicht benutzt werden. Jetzt könnte man ja als Betreiber von so einer Brücke, kann ja durchaus in privater Hand sein, wie viele Tunnel und so in Europa auch, könnte man ja sagen, ach so wichtig ist euch das, ja dann kostet das rüberfahrend jetzt mal 15 Euro und dann kommt das deutsche Gesetz und sagt, also das Kartellrecht und sagt, nee das ist eine wesentliche Einrichtung. Die ist zwar privat betrieben, aber du kannst hier nicht alles machen, was du willst. Die ist zu wichtig, als dass du jetzt einfach da ein Preisschild dran klebst und sagst, wenn die Leute das so viel, ist wie bei Impfstoffen, ja. Es ist kein Geheimnis, dass die Impfung 1500 Euro volkswirtschaftlich wert ist pro Nase und sie wird trotzdem für 50 Euro angeboten und nicht für 150 Euro, die hätte man da auch rausziehen können. Ja, dann wäre es frech gewesen. Sondern es gibt eine, also in Deutschland heißt das wesentliche Einrichtung. Das ist der Begriff aus dem Kartellrecht. Und was heißt es eigentlich, wenn in Australien ein privates Unternehmen sagt, ja, ich mache jetzt mal die und die Entscheidung, bei mir kann man keine Links mehr posten. Und dann stehen zwei Minister des Landes auf der Matte und sagen, dass es geht zu weit, das greift ja in unsere Public Safety ein. Ist das nicht ein Zugeständnis an Facebook, ist es so wichtig, dass wir hier grundsätzlich mal anders drüber nachdenken müssen. Also in der Hinsicht hat sich dieses australische Ding einiges gezeigt. Und jetzt ist auch interessant, wer verhandelt hier eigentlich miteinander? Die Politiker wollen, dass irgendwie Facebook mit den Unternehmen verhandelt. Facebook sagt sich so, ja, wir wollen aber auch noch mal ein anderes Gespräch führen. Und jetzt hören wir noch mal hier diesen Frydenberg, also den Finanzminister. Also er diskutiert jetzt mit. Wir haben das ja von von allein gehört. Beim Thema Klima müssen wir mal die Unternehmenschefs genau an den gleichen Platz setzen, wo sonst die Staatschef sitzen und dann mit ihm auf Augenhöhe und so weiter. Und das ist hier fast schon Augenhöhe. Also ich habe mal mit Mark Zuckerberg telefoniert, dem Staatschef von Facebook.
Bestätigt aber auch noch mal Bill Gates. We need governance. Also das ist jetzt nicht etwas, was jetzt die Unternehmer unter sich mal ausklüngeln können, denn das passiert dann, wenn jetzt die Politik sich erst mal heraushält oder nicht entscheidend mitmischt.
Genau und jetzt versucht die Politik da einen starken Max zu machen. Das schaffen sie natürlich. Hier haben wir noch mal Frydenberg. Denn Facebook ist zurück. Facebook postet wieder und es gab wohl Einigungen. Und jetzt will ich mal vorlesen hier. Fatsnet. Christoph Heyn berichtet aus Singapur, ist wahrscheinlich am nächsten dran, um für Australien zuständig zu sein. Die australische Regierung hat dann auch mal bei Modi angerufen in Indien. Wir wissen ja von Indien, die sperren auch mal TikTok. Was bedeutet, es gibt da jetzt zwei TikTok-Konkurrenten, die so richtig abgehen in Indien, weil die Leute wollen TikToks, muss aber nicht das echte sein. Genau wie in Australien, die Leute so Nachrichten haben wollen. Es muss ja nicht von Google sein, dachte sich Google als Gefahr, und ist dann gleich mal eingegangen. Und dann jetzt mal Zitate von so richtigen Ministern. Hier zum Beispiel. Kanada steht in dieser Schlacht in der ersten Reihe. Wir sind in der ersten Gruppe von Ländern rund um die Erde, die etwas unternehmen, sagt Steve Gilbert, Minister für das kanadische Kulturerbe. Er stellt sich also nicht nur an die Seite der australischen Regierung, sondern sieht sie selber noch in der ersten Reihe. Ich gehe davon aus, dass wir sehr schnell 15 oder 15 Länder haben werden, die sich jetzt ähnlichen Regeln geben. Wird Facebook dann seine Beziehung zu Deutschland abbrechen, zu Frankreich? Das geht doch überhaupt nicht. Julian Knight, Vorsitzender der Digitalkommission im britischen Parlament, also die äußern sich auch, sagt, Facebook soll sich, Zitat, schämen für seine Abschaltung in Australien. Zitat, mit Blick auf die Beziehung rund um die Erde und Plattformen sozialer Medien hat Facebook die Uhr gleich mehrere Jahre zurückgedreht. Ich denke, Facebook hat sich Australien ausgesucht für eine Art von Schlägen zur Bestrafung, um dem Rest der Welt effektiv zu zeigen, dass Facebook einseitig in Aktion treten wird, wenn die Länder mit Gesetzen für die Plattformen sozialer Medien aufkommen. Im Grunde handelt es sich um Aktionen eines Schulhoftyrannen. Beugt sich Australien jetzt, werden wir die Nächsten sein, sagen die Briten. Also in deren Sicht ist hier doch einiges losgetreten worden. Klar, es ist irgendwie blöde, das Gesetz. Es könnte besser sein, aber es ist überhaupt mal ein Gesetz gegen Facebook und Google und jetzt stehen noch sehr viele stramm und sagen, gar nicht so ein schlechter Move. Also da hat sich Facebook vielleicht auch wirklich ein bisschen verzockt hier mit der Aktion.
Ganz genau. Und das ist sicherlich etwas, was bei diesen Silicon Valley Leuten auch erst einmal verplüffend sein mag. Mark Zuckerberg wurde doch gefragt, du hattest mal diesen Ausschnitt gebracht, ob er dann auch Leute hat, auf die er hört. Und die Antwort war ja, er sei mehr jetzt im Dialog mit Gott. Und der denkt, okay, jemand anderes als Berater, akzeptiert er schon gar nicht mehr, geschweige dann noch ein Politiker, sondern er ist nur noch dem Höchsten unterstellt direkt. Und da kann man sehr schön aber sehen, bei diesem Fall in Australien, nein, die Politik ist diejenige, die dafür sorgt, dass ein Rahmen vorgelegt wird. Und in diesem Rahmen muss man sich dann entsprechend verhalten. Und das hat sie immer zugunsten solcher Leute wie Zuckerberg gemacht. Und das kann sie aber auch in eine andere Richtung bewegen. Und der Staat, auf den ist auch ein internationaler Konzern noch angewiesen, wenn er in diesem Staat stattfinden will. Also jetzt ist das vielleicht noch mal ganz möglich für Facebook zu sagen, wir sind nicht mehr in Deutschland, aber zu sagen, wir sind nicht mehr in der EU oder wir können in den USA nicht mehr unser Geschäft machen, da geht es nicht. Insofern ist das ein ganz, ganz großes Problem für die, wenn die jetzt plötzlich erkennen, wir sind doch nicht die Mächtigsten überhaupt, sondern es bleibt am Ende der Staat und man sieht ja auch gerade in Amerika, wie Facebook und wie auch Twitter versuchen, ein bisschen gute Mine zum bösen Spiel zu machen, sich ein bisschen einzuschleimen. Man hat dann wenige Tage vor dem Ende nochmal Trump gebannt, hat ihn verbannt von diesen Plattformen, weil man selbstverständlich eine große Angst hat vor den Demokraten, die fordern, wir müssen da zerschlagen, wir müssen besteuern und und und. Insofern hat man sich ein bisschen jetzt freigeschwommen, hat dann den Demokraten gezeigt, guck, so schlimm sind wir ja doch nicht, aber ich glaube, das wird nicht ewig anhalten.
Ich bin auch mal gespannt, wie das alles so weitergeht, hier ist jedenfalls Bewegung drin und manchmal denke ich mir, wie macht das Mark Zuckerberg überhaupt Gründe, dass das Ding dann hauert, irgendwie um so ein Facebook, also ein Gesicht, lebendige Adressbücher zu haben und dann 10 Jahre, 15 Jahre später stehst du plötzlich da und wirst zum einen von Tim Cook kurz und klein geschlagen und zum anderen von der australischen Regierung und alle solidarisieren sich gegen dich. Das ist natürlich auch brenzlig insgesamt, aber alles, was zur Abschaffung Facebooks führt, ist natürlich zu goutieren, naja.
Wir blicken auch auf den Salon, wir sprechen ja über ein Buch, das wir gemeinsam lesen, History Has Begun, das wird sehr interessant werden, weil wir da einen Perspektivwechsel vornehmen müssen, der uns vielleicht gar nicht so leicht wird. Wir können durchaus mal sagen, wir blicken mal von Shenzhen aus auf den Rest der Welt. Aber wenn wir über den Westen nachdenken, denken wir halt über den Westen nach als Europa und USA doch sehr im Einklang. Auch wenn wir das eben ein bisschen kritisiert haben, ist unsere Denkweise doch sehr so geprägt. Und was ist eigentlich, wenn man den Fokus, wenn man über den Westen spricht, auf Amerika legt und wir blicken auf Amerika und merken plötzlich als Europäer, spielen wir da eine sehr, sehr untergeordnete Rolle und das ist ein Buch, das zumindest diskussionswürdig ist. Und ich glaube, dass es etwas sehr Sinnvolles darüber jetzt zu sprechen, denn da wird sich einiges verschieben, auch wenn die jetzt so ein bisschen tun, als könnte man einfach anknüpfen an vergangene Tage, so wird es vermutlich nicht laufen.
Genau, ich bin noch nicht sehr weit, aber ich habe am Anfang schon gelesen, dass es tatsächlich als Antwort auf das Ende der Geschichte von Fukuyama auch eingelegt ist. Und in deren Sicht ist das natürlich, denn wir wissen ja, was für eine Geschichte da endete. Ansonsten mal gucken, Inside Huawei, wie sie heißen, ist natürlich immer sehr chinesisch jetzt. Ich weiß nicht, ob ich jetzt so ein Bias habe oder so. Denn auch im Spiegel gab es jetzt mal so ein Text, das zuerst Elektronik aus China kam und mittlerweile Mode von Unternehmen, die vor fünf Jahren noch 200 Millionen Umsatz gemacht haben und plötzlich 15 Milliarden, die übrigens Dispersion genau wissen, die Leute gehen eh nicht mehr in die Innenstadt, um sich ihre Mode zu holen. Also machen wir das lieber präsentieren, wir schicken uns ein Foto und wir kleiden sie an. Dann können sie auf dem iPad gucken, wie sie aussehen. Das kann ja ein deutscher Einzelhandel gar nicht machen, sondern das kommt dann halt direkt aus China dann so ein Zeug. Naja, in Frankreich geht es wohl auch ab.
Ja, ich würde noch mal ein bisschen Klatsch mit reinbringen. Das ist ja etwas, was mir sehr liegt. Ich bin ja klatschsüchtig geradezu. Und es gibt jetzt tatsächlich das Buch von Baptiste Giabicconi auf deutsch.
Ich hole meine Antigen-Tests. Du stellst das Buch.
Ja, jetzt wird es natürlich spannend. Jetzt kommen die Antigen-Tests. Jetzt ist unser Stefan sicher. Nun, dieses Buch von Baptiste Giabicconi ist das Buch einer Freundschaft. Und zwar Baptiste Giabicconi war die letzte Muse von Karl Lagerfeld. Er war sehr eng mit ihm befreundet und hat jetzt ein Buch darüber geschrieben. Karl und ich heißt es. Und ich bin sehr gespannt ein bisschen auf Interna. Das ist dann ja doch sehr, sehr interessant bei einer Figur, die sich so abgeschottet hat, zu erfahren, was da eigentlich so los war. Ich glaube aber, dass es nicht zu indiskret wird. Dafür war diese Freundschaft sicherlich zu eng und zu vertraulich, als dass jetzt da noch mal in irgendeiner Weise schmutzige Wäsche gewaschen werden soll. Zumal es ja auch so ist, dass diese Freundschaft ja bis zum Ende bestand hatte. Und Lagerfeld ist ja immer einer gewesen, der diese Diskretion auch wirklich gelebt hat. Da möchte ich noch eine kleine Anmerkung machen, weil ich da viele Nachrichten bekam nach unserem letzten Podcast. Ich zitierte einen Brief aus dem 18. Jahrhundert von einem Vater an seinen Sohn, der dort sagte, wenn du in die Stadt gehst, dann verstell dich, gib nicht alles preis und so. Ich hatte damals wohl vergessen, anzugeben, von wem der ist. Das ist Lord Chesterfield. Der hat diese Briefe an seinen Sohn geschrieben und diese Briefe sind auch auf Deutsch erschienen. Ich hatte damals in dem Auszug, den ich zitiert habe, ein Zitat genommen, das ich gefunden hatte in dem Buch Tyrannei der Intimität von Richard Sennett. Aber es gibt diese Briefe auch so übersetzt, sind im Manesse-Verlag, soweit ich weiß, erschienen. Und dann wird es bei mir noch um ein ganz schmales Büchlein gehen, ein Dialogbüchlein mit dem französischen Sinologen und Philosophen Francois Julien. Der hat ein sehr gutes Buch vor zwei Jahren über Identität geschrieben. Und in diesem Büchlein geht es jetzt nun darum, warum wir nicht mehr ich liebe dich sagen sollten. Und die anderen beiden sollten wir nicht mehr machen. Das heißt aber nicht, dass wir die Liebe der Liebe eine Absage erteilen, sondern wir müssen eine neue Form des Kommunizierens finden. Sehr, sehr klug. Und dann die anderen beiden Texte, die anderen drei Texte, die noch kommen, die verrate ich noch nicht. Und jetzt hast du die Schnelltester. Ich packe aus.
Hier ist natürlich Filme.
Das ist jetzt Unboxing mit Stefan Schulz. Da sind die Stäbchen.
Die sind aber ganz schön lang. Ich muss sie doch gar nicht so tief in meine Nase stecken. So, und das sind hier die Kiste. Die ist natürlich versiegelt noch. Ich verletze jetzt das Siegel. Ich habe hier eine Schere. Es sind übrigens die, die österreichischen Schüler gerade alle benutzen. Die müssen jetzt zweimal die Woche Antigen-Tests machen. Sonst dürfen sie nicht in die Schule. So, Deckel auf. Also, das funktioniert wie folgt. Ich habe hier ein kleines Lösungsmittel, wie du siehst. Davon habe ich zwei. Denn das reicht. Zwei für alle. Und dann hier so ein Dings jeweils. Und dann nimmt man so ein Stäbchen, schneuzt sich einmal alles, was man hinten in der Nase hat, nach vorne. Und das ist nämlich das Tolle, man muss nicht bis in den Rachen. Also während die Ärzellobby im Spiegel ja noch mal schrieb, es müssen einem die Tränen kommen und der Wirkreflex muss ausgelöst werden, sonst ist es kein echter Test. Dann nimmt man hier das Stäbchen relativ weit vorne, geht zwei Zentimeter, so wie man an die tiefsten Stelle mit dem Taschentuch kommt. Also nicht dahinter. Streicht dann 15 Sekunden lang im Kreis und fügt das dann, ich öffne es jetzt nicht, in so ein vakuumverpacktes Ding ein. Tröpfelt dann zwei Tropfen von der Lösung drauf und wartet 15 Minuten und sieht dann die Verfärbung auf einem extra Papierstreifen, bis zu dem sich die Flüssigkeit hin ausbreitet. Und dann weiß man, ob man Corona-ansteckend ist oder nicht. Es ist wirklich so einfach. Man muss nicht tief in die Nase. Man hat alles, was man braucht. Hier die Stäbchen, die Lösungen und dieses kleine Test-Kit. Das faltet man auf. Da steht genau, hier müssen Sie jetzt den Tupfer ablegen und dann 15 Minuten warten. Und man weiß, ob der Test funktioniert hat, weil man hat ja einen Kontrollstreifen. Der schlägt dann an. Und wenn der zweite Test-Streifen negativ, also weiß bleibt, dann ist man negativ.
Man hätte es prima jeden Abend erklären können in ARD, ZDF, in all den dritten Programmen. Da hätten sich doch Eckhard von Hirschhausen, Ranga Yogeshwar, Jean Pütz alle gerne angeboten, denke ich. Vielleicht auch noch mal, wie hieß sie noch mal, die die Knopf-Hoff-Show früher moderiert hat? Die hat auch noch mal solche kleinen Spiele für zu Hause dann noch vorbereitet, das kann man zu Hause machen. Es war Ramona Lais. Die könnte man auch noch mal aktivieren.
MyLab hat jetzt einen Exklusivvertrag gestern bekommen im CDF. Sie darf jetzt nur noch im CDF klug sein.
Aber schade, dass sie nicht in ihrem neuen Video noch mal über Schnelltests geredet hat und da auch einfach nur sagte, dass AstraZeneca ja so toll sei und gar nicht darauf eingegangen ist, dass es halt noch einen sehr guten Impfstoff gibt. Aber gut, so ist es.
Sehr gut. Dann haben wir den Februar hier verhandelt.
Salon wieder.
Sehen wir uns im Salon. Ich bin ganz überrascht, dass doch sehr viele Leute die Bücher, die wir da vorstellen, dann auch tatsächlich kaufen und selber noch mal lesen. In der Ansicht überlegen wir mal, ob wir zumindest was das eine Buch pro Monat angeht, hier mal so eine gewisse Empfehlungsstruktur einbauen. Hinsichtlich, wenn schon jemand was tolles gelesen hat und uns das kurz darstellen kann, warum sich das so lohnt, dass es zum einen wir nochmal besprechen und dann aber auch sozusagen hinausgegeben wird als Empfehlung. Vielleicht finden wir da mal ein Modus, dass wir da so ein, auch Sachen, die wir dann nicht besprechen, dass die mal festgehalten werden kurz oder so, dass wir auf der Webseite nochmal so was einrichten. Aber da überlege ich mal jetzt, ich habe jetzt ein bisschen Zeit, bis zum nächsten März, dass wir das dann mal so irgendwie organisieren. Sehr gut. Na dann, bleibt alle gesund, testet euch fleißig und geht zur Impfung natürlich, auch mit einem trennenden Auge, aber müssen wir alle durch. Bis dann.